Die 2. Liga, sie ist seit fast 3 Wochen offiziell beendet und ihr bekommt jetzt endlich eine Saisonabschlussfolge, welche Teams und Spieler richtig überzeugt haben und was eigentlich rund um den letzten Spieltag Entscheidendes und Spannendes passiert ist. Das hört ihr jetzt mit Anna Lautenbach, Matthias Kneifel, Marc Schwitzki und mit mir. Viel Spaß. Und mein Hörnicks. Perfekt. Hallo.
Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Rossi ist zu kurz abwehrt, lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Marc Grapf, Martin Farka.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kurt aus dem Bivou.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, willkommen zurück zur Rasenfunk Ligatour zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Mein Name ist Eva Lothar-Bohle, aber das wisst ihr hoffentlich alle, wenn ihr diese Saison akribisch hier in der Ligatour begleitet habt. Ich freue mich sehr, dass ich diese Folge nicht alleine begleiten muss, weil das wäre ziemlich langweilig, glaube ich, und sehr einseitig. Und daher freue ich mich sehr, dass ich ja in dieser Folge mal eine andere Art von Zusammenstellung begrüßen darf. Zum einen ist mein Co-Hust Marc an meiner Seite. Hallo Marc.
Ich grüße dich Eva und ich habe auch ganz, ganz große Lust auf diese Folge.
Das ist super und das hoffe ich auch von den anderen zwei Gästen hier in dieser Folge. Denn es sind noch zwei Mitglieder des All-Star-Teams dabei. Zum einen Anna Lautenbach vom Gegengrade-Podcast. Hallo Anna.
Hallo in die Runde. Ich freue mich auch wirklich sehr.
Hab Bock. Und dann ist Matthias Kneifel vom Kick-Schuh-Blog auch dabei. Grüß dich.
Servus, hallo zusammen.
Ja, ich erkläre euch einmal kurz, wie diese Folge ablaufen wird. Und zwar wollen wir zu Beginn einmal drauf schauen, was eigentlich seit unserer letzten Folge, als Marc und ich euch erzählt haben, was denn für den letzten Spieltag so alles passieren könnte, passiert ist. Quasi ein Lage der Liga, letzter Spieltag, Relegationsedition. Und dann haben wir ein bisschen orientiert an die Abschlussfolge quasi vor dem Royale zur Bundesliga der Männer, eine Awardshow für euch. Und zwar haben wir die zwei geteilt. Einmal haben wir das All-Star-Team gefragt, aber eben euch auch als Community zu bester Trainer, bester Spieler etc. pp. Und das werden wir ein bisschen besprechen. Und dann haben wir noch uns ein paar sonstige Awards ausgedacht, die eben auch noch mal ja vielleicht auf ein paar Themen auch auf und neben dem Platz Sachen beleuchten sollen. Vielleicht kurz zur Begründung, vielleicht haben sich manche das erhofft, dass es einen Rückblick über alle 18 Vereine geben wird. Wir haben uns tatsächlich dagegen entschieden, weil zum einen, dass es wirklich sehr, sehr viel Aufwand ist, immer diese 18 Vereine abzublicken. Und wir das meistens dann ja so gemacht haben, dass immer unterschiedliche Gäste unterschiedlich Vereine aufnehmen. Und das ist einfach für die restlichen Gäste irgendwann so ein bisschen, ich sag mal, an einigen Stellen langweilig. Und das ist einfach auch viel zu lang hinten raus. Und wir haben ja durch den Vorteil dieses neuen Konzepts in dieser Saison eben so, dass wir ja schon immer viel die Vereine abgeblickt oder ja abgedeckt haben. Und es wird ehrlich gesagt einfach ein bisschen den Rahmen sprengen. Und ich glaube, so viel Neues würdet ihr dann über die Vereine eh nicht mehr haben. Deshalb haben wir uns dagegen entschieden.
Und ich glaube, dazu kann man sagen, dass wir einfach nicht die gleichen Kapazitäten haben, wie Max in der Erstliga-Version, der dann halt noch den Royale so ausführlich gestalten kann, dass man da jedem Verein eine eigene Sendung nochmal widmet. Die Zeit haben wir nicht, das heißt, wir müssen es in einer kompletten Folge machen. Und den 7-Stunden-Brecher, weiß ich nicht, für alle Beteiligten glaube ich dann eher eine Tortur als alles andere.
Das stimmt, aber ich würde sagen, wir starten dann mal rein in unsere Lage der Liga. Marc, willst du uns vielleicht einmal abholen, was ist denn seit dem letzten Spieltag so passiert?
So einiges. Wir werden, um das mal kurz zu fassen, fünf neue oder auch alte Gesichter, je nachdem wie man es denn sehen möchte, in der zweiten Liga begrüßen. Das liegt daran, dass es drei Aufsteiger geben wird aus der zweiten Liga in die erste Liga hoch. Wir wissen ja schon lange, dass der FC Schalke 04 dazugehören wird am allerletzten Spieltag. Und dann auch in der Relegation hat sich aber eben auch entschieden, dass der SV Elbersberg und der SC Paderborn, während bei uns hier in Krasel gerade die Welt untergeht, auch schön, es ist fast ein bisschen zur Stimmung, wenn ich gleich zu den Absteigern komme. Der SV Elbersberg und der SC Paderborn, die sind aufgestiegen als Platz zwei und drei. Und es gibt zwei Absteiger. Auch da Preußen Münster war ja dann schon länger klar. Aber am letzten Spieltag sehr dramatisch. Ich glaube, das wird später auch in die Awards vielleicht überleitet. Zumindest bei mir kann ich so weit spoilern. Ich habe diesem Spiel oder auch Fortuna Düsseldorf selbst einen Award auf jeden Fall gewidmet. Die Fortuna verabschiedet sich nach langer, langer, langer Zeit aus den ersten beiden Ligen und ist tatsächlich jetzt Drittliges. Und ja, da nochmal liebe Grüße an Thorsten, unseren Mitstreiter hier aus dem All-Star-Team. Das ist eine sehr bittere Geschichte. Ihn verlieren wir an die 3. Liga. Zeitgleich verlieren wir aber auch Kevin und Nele an die 1. Liga. Keine Sorge, wir haben es schon geklärt. Es gibt weiter laufende Verträge. Wir haben uns da Optionen in Klauseln gesichert. Die werden hier trotzdem noch im All-Star-Team mal vorkommen. So ist es nicht. Was aber zeitgleich auch gesagt werden muss, ist eben, dass der VfW Wolfsburg– ai ai ai– als Schwergewicht, zumindest finanzieller Natur, in die 2. Liga nach knapp 30 Jahren zurückkehren wird. Und der FC St. Pauli und natürlich auch der 1. FC Heidenheim sind nun auch wieder Zweitligisten. Und neu begrüßen dürfen wir auch den VfL Osnabrück und den FC Energie Cottbus. Die kommen hoch. Osnabrück, ja durchaus ein gesehener Gast der 2. Liga in den letzten Jahren. Also hat schon so leichte Fahrstuhl-Vibes zuletzt gehabt. Der FC Energie Cottbus auch, wobei da der Fahrstuhl zuletzt eher nur nach oben gefahren ist, muss man sagen. Also die sind jetzt beide hochgekommen. Essen hat sich in der Relegation nicht gegen Fürth durchgesetzt, also bleibt das Kleeblatt der 2. Liga erhalten. Dementsprechend auch Michi, das ist eine schöne Sache. Und Rot-Weiß-Essen hat das eben nicht gepackt. Nun gut, das sind die Geschichten, die dramatischen Geschichten, die sich am letzten Spieltag ereignet haben. Ja, sind wie gesagt natürlich der Natur, wer wurde zweiter, wer wurde dritter. Da hat sich wie gesagt Elversberg zunächst durchgesetzt, aber Paderborn in der Relegation mit dem rüben, rabenvollen Ralf Kettemann dann ja auch noch eine Positivgeschichte geschrieben. Und wie gesagt, das Fürth-Düsseldorf-Spiel, was an Dramatik nicht zu überbieten war, in dieser Konstellation und dann ja auch, ja, zumindest für eine Mannschaft geliefert hat, sagen wir mal so, oder für die zumindest Unterhaltungswert der gesamten Liga gesorgt hat. Das ist eben auch noch am letzten Spieltag passiert. Zeitgleich, Anna, hat sich auch deine Eintracht zum Beispiel ja gerettet. Einige Vereine mussten ja bis zum letzten Zittern, sei es Bielefeld gewesen, aber selbst so Mannschaften wie Dresden hatten ja theoretische Chancen noch auf einen Abstieg. Aber letztendlich haben sich Braunschweig, Magdeburg, Bielefeld, Kiel, Dresden, all diese Mannschaften, die lange noch drin waren, am Ende gerettet. Und was man auch sagen kann, was ich oben noch nicht erwähnt habe, Hannover 96 hat es tatsächlich hinbekommen, das noch wegzuchoken. Sie sind am Ende Vierter geworden. Das, was wir, Eva, ja so ein bisschen in unserer Folge vor dem letzten Spieltag befürchtet haben, dass dieses Nervenkostüm am Ende auch ein bisschen Tiz-typisch nicht halten würde. Auch das ist passiert. Also ja, ein paar Geschichten gab es auf jeden Fall. Das ist so die Lage der Liga nach dem letzten Spieltag. Ein paar Vereine bleiben uns freudigerweise erhalten, ein paar gehen bittere Weise nach oben und nach unten weg, aber es gibt auch neue Gesichter. Freut man sich drauf.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und also ich muss sagen, ich fand es zur einen Seite am letzten Spieltag, also ich weiß nicht, wo ihr alle so unterwegs wart, aber ich war im Stadion und ich sag mal so netz in so einem Stadion, das ist ja immer so kontraproduktiv gut und also wir hatten dann schon so zwei, drei Leute, die dann immer die Tabelle aktualisierten und ich hab immer nur gesagt, nehmt das ja nie aus meinem Gesicht, bitte. Ich kann es nicht mehr sehen. Aber Anna, ich starte einfach mal bei dir, weil du ja auch noch so vom Gefühl her so ein bisschen mehr Aktien noch drin hattest. Wie hast du denn so vielleicht den Endspurt der Saison erlebt generell? Und wie geht es dir heute?
War halt tatsächlich total gut. Ich kann das irgendwie schwer beschreiben, wie sehr man eine Sommerpause genießt und jetzt ja auch eine anstehende Weltmeisterschaft, bei der man sicherlich aus unterschiedlichen Gründen mit gemischten Gefühlen draufgucken kann oder sie gerne auch gar nicht verfolgen kann. Aber vielleicht könnt ihr das teilen, wie wenig Lust man auf Fußball hat, wenn der eigene Verein einfach im Stich lässt. Also phasenweise ist es ja sogar so, dass ich irgendwie Zusammenfassungen anderer Vereine nicht gucken kann, weil ich denke, Tore schießen ist so einfach. Warum kriegen wir das nicht hin? Ja, das ist natürlich ein absolutes Up-and-Down gewesen nach diesem überlebenswichtigen Auswärtssieg in Casaslautern. Man so verhalten optimistisch, nachdem man dann doch wieder mit dem Rücken zur Wand stand, dann aber Dresden zu Hause schlagen konnte in einem wirklich sehr aufregenden Spiel, in dem Torben Hoffmann einen Elfmeter gehalten hat. Und abgesehen von den Punkten, selbst wenn wir das Spiel doch noch gewonnen hätten, hätte uns dieser Elfmeter einfach die Klasse kosten können, einfach weil wir einen Tor mehr gefangen hätten. Und am Ende ging es ja tatsächlich um ein Tor. Und dieser letzte Spieltag auf Schalke war tatsächlich, also es war das erste Spiel, dass ich, ich habe abgeschaltet. Ich bin dann in der sechzigsten Minute, habe ich ausgemacht und bin mir am Hund gegangen. Das ist kein Scherz, sondern ich habe dann überlegt, okay, ich weiß ungefähr, wenn ich da und da lang gehe, dann komme ich erst nach Hause, wenn es auf jeden Fall vorbei ist. Und dann habe ich beim Spaziergang überlegt, wie informiere ich mich? Und dachte, ich mache erst das Handy an und gehe zuerst in WhatsApp in den Chat von meinem Freund, weil er wird es so mir geschrieben haben, dass ich es verkraften kann. Wenn da steht, oh nein, es tut mir so leid, dann bin ich schon vorbereitet und alles andere ist ja gut. Und genauso habe ich es gemacht, weil ich mein Führer hat ja losgelegt, wie die Feuerwehr. Und erst war ich darüber sehr begeistert und als sie dann nicht aufgehört haben, Tore zu schießen, dachte ich so, stop the count, also what the, hört doch auf damit, Düsseldorf, reiß dich zusammen. Und dann irgendwie hat Schalke ja doch auch ernst gemacht. Und dann hat der Kommentator gesagt, ja, wir freuen uns auf Eden Dzeko, der wird sich noch angemessen verabschieden. Ich habe so Angst. Also wirklich schlimm. Ich fand es nicht schön. Ich finde es so lächerlich, wenn Leute sagen, ich wünsche dir viel Spaß beim Fußball. Mit Spaß hat das einfach gar nichts zu tun. Und am Ende war ich einfach nur erleichtert. Das ist so ein bisschen wie, wenn jemand die Dunstabzugshaube abstellt und du denkst, Gott sei Dank, ey, das ist vorbei.
Das Bild fühle ich. Das Bild fühle ich ja komplett.
Das ist immer vorbei.
Gott sei Dank, Gott sei Dank. Inzwischen habe ich mich sehr gut eingerichtet in meinem Standard-Amateurtopf im DFB-Pokal. So kurz vor knapp Klasse gehalten.
Ey, aber Anna, da müssen wir kurz auch noch mal drauf gucken. Ich habe mir das gerade nämlich aufgerufen, weil ich mich gefragt habe, wie war das in den letzten Jahren? Das ist ein absolutes Kunststück, was Braunschweig in der Durchschnittsplatzierung hinbekommt, weil wenn man auf die Saison 17, 18 guckt, sind sie als 17. abgestiegen, in zwei Jahre dritte Liga, dann sind sie wieder als 17. abgestiegen und seitdem sind sie 15., 15., 16. und 15. geworden. Du kannst in der Theorie nicht schlechter sein und in der Klasse bleiben, als es Braunschweig seit jetzt irgendwie gefühlt sechs, sieben Jahren macht. Das ist fast schon wieder eine Kunst.
Ja, es geht tatsächlich seit genau zehn Jahren so. Wir haben in der Saison 16, 17, da sind wir in einer Relagation gelandet, mit 66 Punkten, möchte ich an der Stelle noch einmal erwähnen, nicht geschafft, weil Bielefeld uns komplett geschlachtet hat am vorletzten Spieltag. Das war wirklich ein traumatisches Erlebnis, dass auch– von Bielefeld geschlachtet werden, kenne ich nicht. Also, ja, es war ein ähnliches Gefühl, glaube ich. Dann sind wir abgestiegen in Kiel, in die 3. Liga, und zwar mit 39 Punkten. Und dann ging es um den Klassenerhalt in der 3. Liga, wo wir gegen Cottbus gewonnen haben und auch mit einem Tor die Klasse gehalten haben zur Qualifikation 3. Liga. Und es geht immer entweder hoch oder runter. Und deswegen ist ja das Credo tatsächlich, wir wollen einfach nur mal unsere Ruhe. Wir wollen gar nicht Erfolg haben, sondern einfach nur mal ein bisschen smooth so um Ostern rumdenken, ach cool, man könnte schon den Kader planen. Und in der Klasse, also nicht negativ sein.
Ja, schon klar.
Genau, also insofern, also insgesamt lange Antwort, mir geht es gut, ich fühle mich wohl. Und ich freue mich vor allem so sehr, das ist ja hier in unterschiedlichen Zusammenhängen schon angeklangt, wirklich sehr, dass ich auch Teil der Gruppe bleiben darf. Weil es einfach wirklich ein so cooles Ensemble ist und ich profitiere davon so sehr weirde Fakten in unerwarteter Tiefe über Fürz oder Darmstadt, so ist es fantastisch, ja großartig.
Matthias, bevor ich an dich weitergehe, ich muss einmal kurz auf dieses 6 zu 0, Eintracht gegen Bielefeld. Ich war zu dem Zeitpunkt in Irland auf einer Farm. Ihr könnt euch ungefähr vorstellen, wie gut das Netz war. Immer noch besser als auf jeder Bahnstrecke in Deutschland.
Und im Stadion.
Trotzdem nicht gut, also es lief halt wirklich nur über WLAN, weil sonst kein Netz und ich hatte den Fehler gemacht, damals ist Sky Go immer noch abgestürzt, wenn du irgendeine Art von Benachrichtigung bekommen hast. Und ich hatte vergessen, die Kicker-Benachrichtigungen auszumachen und jegliche andere Benachrichtigung auch. Das heißt, ich hab keins dieser Tore bei Sky gesehen, weil es immer abgestürzt ist. Und ich gleichzeitig die restlichen 7 Leute, die mit mir auf dieser Farm gearbeitet habe, dazu überreden mussten, bitte ihre Serien voneinander zu gucken, weil ich bräuchte das WLAN jetzt. Es war sehr schwierig, dass 5 Leute, die absolut gar nichts mit Fußball zu tun hatten, zu verklickern und dem Kölner. Dem Kölner, dem war ja alles egal. Aber gut.
Ja, da war ich, also, genau, technisch irgendwie auch eine andere Zeit. Ich war mit meinem Bruder da und wir sind Auto gefahren und dann saßen wir danach wirklich sehr frustriert im Bus und wollten auch gar nichts mehr eintippen oder so. Und Hannes war der Meinung, das lief schon über Sprachsteuerung ganz gut und hat dann seinem Handy gesagt, bitte navigiere uns von Bielefeld nach Braunschweig und das Handy antwortete mit dieser noch nicht besonders optimierten Stimme. Aminia Bielefeld, Eintracht Braunschweig, 6 zu 0 verloren. Wir waren da. Ja, danke.
Oh wow, naja, das musste, den nächsten Kurs musste ich kurz noch machen. Aber Matthias, du konntest ja so ein bisschen entspannter, möchte ich sagen, in diesen letzten Spieltag gehen. Aber vielleicht da auch bei dir die Frage, wie hast du dann so die generell vielleicht diese 2. Saison, ohne jetzt irgendwie schon weiß, wie viel vorauszugreifen, aber wahrgenommen und bist du am Ende vielleicht auch doch ein kleines bisschen enttäuscht, dass es dann am letzten Spieltag nicht mehr um alles ging?
Ja, also als Darmstadt 98-Perspektive war die Rückrunde vor allem das letzte Viertel eine Vollkatastrophe, kann man schon fast sagen. Also in der Hinrunde auf Platz 3 in der Rückrundentabelle, auf Platz 16, das muss man auch erstmal schaffen.
Das ist Florian Kohfeldt in Reinform, das war ein Stück weit auch.
Ja, also deshalb war der letzte Spieltag dann für uns in Darmstadt tatsächlich unter einem anderen Label gestanden. Der Verein hat alles dafür getan, dass der Abschied von Fabian Holland alles überlagert. Das fand ich dann schon ein bisschen too much, auch wenn er sehr verdient ist. Also ein Spieler, der seit langen, langen Jahren hier alles mitgemacht hat. Einzug in die 1. Liga, Klassenerhalt, 1. Liga, runtergegangen, wieder hochgegangen, Kapitän geworden. Auch wenn er jetzt nicht der Lautsprecher ist oder der extrovertierteste Spieler, aber nicht das trotzdem sehr verdienter Spieler, der auch so das verkörpert, was Darmstadt immer noch wertschätzt. Aber im Endeffekt war der letzte Spieltag dann so, dass wir natürlich Paderborn zu Gast hatten. Für die ging es noch um was. Haben dann 2-0 gewonnen, auch wenn es das Expected-Goals-Verhältnis nicht hergab. Liedberg wollte Torschützenkönig noch werden. Das hat man ihm angemerkt. Hatte auch Pfosten-Treffer vor dem 1-0 für Paderborn. Und leider hat Alexander Vukovic die zwei Tore aufgelegt oder zumindest begleitet. Hätte kein Sieg werden müssen. Auch Paderborn wirkte auf mich so, als ob sie es nicht zwingend erzwingen müssten. Aber sie haben es dann angenommen. Und um mich rum gingen auch viele Handys an und haben so den primären Abstiegskampf mitverfolgt. Und nachdem da wirklich viertelos legte wie die Feuerwehr, dachte ich auch so, oh, hätte ich jetzt nicht in dem Maße erwartet. Hab mich dann auch ein bisschen genervt, dass immer so der Blick aufs andere Spielfeld da war und nicht so auf das Geschehen, das man vor der Nase hatte. Also mich hat es ein bisschen abgetörnt. Und schlussendlich hatte ich es gar nicht so auf dem Schirm, dass Braunschweig da noch ganz tief mit reinrutschen kann. Also hätte der Goethe zum Schluss zu 4-0 gemacht, wäre ja, glaube ich, Braunschweig tatsächlich noch auf den Relationsplatz gerutscht. Und das ist natürlich dann, wenn du siehst, dass minus 18, minus 19, minus 20 am Endeffekt so die Platz 15 bis 17 darstellten, ist es schon krass. Also ich glaube, nachdem, was auch Anna gerade alles über die letzten Jahre erzählt, muss das gefühlte Alter der Braunschweiger Bevölkerung plus fünf im Gegensatz zur gesamten anderen Bevölkerung in Deutschland sein. Also es ist schon bemerkenswert, wenn mir was klar ist, dass da Braunschweig so einen Run hat, immer so knapp vor dem Strich einzukommen. Und Leberknecht war ja auch in Darmstadt Trainer, deshalb habe ich das auch noch vor Augen, diese 39-Punktesaison seiner Zeit, die ja wirklich von Maledeit war. Also da fette Props an Braunschweig und die Fanschar, die da viel aushalten muss und sich nach einer unspektakulären Saison sehnt. Also kann ich fühlen, in Darmstadt heißt sowas. Unspektakulär können wir nicht. Sorgenfrei Saison heißt sowas in Darmstadt.
Vielen Dank, das ist sehr freundlich.
Herr Tater auch eine sorgenfreie Saison.
Marc, wie oft hast du nach dem Sonntag den Instagram-Kanal von Fabian Reese aktualisiert?
Da stehe ich drüber. Aber es ist schon, also es ist tatsächlich ja nicht nur ein Reese-only-Problem, aber es hat sich einfach niemand nach dieser Saison, außer jetzt die Verantwortlichen, die ja dann in etwaigen Interviews waren, mehr geäußert. Das ist schon, aber klar mutet es nicht gerade glücklich an, wenn die ersten drei Posts von Fabian Reese nach der Saison sind. Hier sind übrigens meine Kick-Pace-Punkte, die ich irgendwie Leuten erwirtschaftet habe. Und hier ist mein neues Fotoshooting für den Berliner Zoo. Das ist dann, ja, ist okay. Und man kann jetzt irgendwo den Reese-Fuß, kann man sich jetzt irgendwo auch hinstellen, habe ich gesehen. Der wurde auch für irgendeine Werbeaktion abgemessen. Also das kann man von mir aus alles machen, ist aber nicht glücklich, wenn man sich ansonsten als Kapitän und Galionsfigur, die man ja auch gerne sein möchte für den Verein, wenn man sich dann darüber hinaus nicht zur Saison äußert, ist kein, also wie gesagt, Dries ist da nicht der Einzige, das gäbe auch neben ihm ja Führungsspieler, vermeintliche im Kader, die sich auch hätten äußern können. Es spricht aber glaube ich auch ein Stück weit für diese Mannschaft, dass es dann so zu Ende ging und dass man sich bis heute, ehrlich gesagt, auch nicht so richtig verabschiedet hat. Da hat man einfach sehr das Gefühl, dass es am Ende, dass diese Mannschaft am Ende eines Zyklus angelangt ist und dass da jetzt sehr viele das Weite suchen werden. Also da wird der Kader schon zerbrechen, wenn jetzt auch so jemand wie Marten Winkler, der jetzt nun auch nicht der Unterschiedspieler ist, sehr offen in einem Kicker-Interview sagt, also ich würde schon gerne gehen. Da merkt man immer schon, okay, dann ist da offensichtlich auch nichts mehr gewesen und das hat ja diese zweite Halbzeit in Bielefeld bewiesen. Da hat ja niemand mehr für etwas gespielt. Nicht für sich selbst, nicht für die Mannschaft, nicht für die Fans, nicht für die, keine Ahnung, TV-Tabelle, was ja auch gerne mal als Motivation hergeholt, wo man sich immer denkt, ja, ich glaube nicht, dass das Spieler sonderlich interessiert, da bin ich ganz ehrlich. Aber nun gut, ich soll ja heute auch keinen Hertha-Schwerpunkt geben. Filme ich nur gerade ein bei Sorgefrei Saison. Je nachdem, wie man Sorge definiert, war es eine Sorgefrei Saison bei Hertha, weil man ja relativ früh einfach nicht mehr viel mit irgendwas zu tun hatte, was natürlich nicht den eigenen Ansprüchen genügt, das ist klar.
Ja, ich gebe auch noch kurz meinen Senf dazu. Also ich spreche gleich noch über dieses letzte Spiel. Deshalb würde ich das ein bisschen außen vornehmen. Ich wollte noch eine Sache sagen, bevor das untergeht. Und zwar gab es ja rund um das Religationsspiel Paderborn gegen Wolfsburg eine ziemlich tragische Geschichte von einem Fan, der hinter ins Krankenhaus musste. Und wie ich es vielleicht gelesen habe, ist das ein Mitglied des Padercast, wo Kevin Bublitz eben auch Teil von ist. Und Kevin ist wiederum Teil unseres All-Star-Teams. Und ich glaube, ich kann nochmal für uns alle sprechen, dass wir Marc weiterhin eine gute Genesung wünschen. Alles Gute für die Zukunft. Und dass er schnell auch vielleicht wieder hinter dem Podcastmico gegebenenfalls sitzt und vor allem auch wieder die Spiele seines SCP dann in der ersten Liga besuchen darf. Das sollte ich hier noch nicht untergehen. Und dann muss man natürlich sagen, also so entspannt, wie ich dann irgendwann ab dem 4.1 diesen Spieltag begleiten durfte, desto unentspannter wurde es dann die Wochen danach. Denn Namina Bielefeld hat sich entschieden, nicht mit Mitch Kniart in die nächste Saison zu gehen. Gründe wurden da genannt, dass es halt eine unterschiedliche Auffassung der nächsten Saison oder weiteren, wie man den Verein weiterbringen will, gab. Die Gespräche sollen wohl schon langer gefühlt werden. Also ich finde, es bin immer per se schon fern davon, nicht am letzten Spieltag festzumachen, ob man diesen Trainer jetzt behält oder nicht. Michael Mutzel wird da seine Gründe bekommen haben. Es steht jetzt eben auch fest, dass Oliver Kirch diesen Verein übernehmen wird. Ich muss gestehen, bei allen Namen von Markus Babbel bis Steffen Baumgart, die da so kursierten, bin ich da sehr fein mit. Aber das wird sehr spannend sein. Ich würde aber tatsächlich sagen, dass wir einfach auch noch nicht wissen, wie der Kader aussehen wird, außer, dass Noah Sarandin-Bazir zu Waldhof Mannheim gewechselt ist. Würde ich darüber dann in einer Saison vorschauen, die bestimmt irgendwann auch erscheinen wird, sprechen. Aber genau, ich glaube, ja, das ist vielleicht was darüber, kann man später nochmal sprechen. Aber ja, das noch von meiner Seite aus. So, jetzt haben wir ein bisschen geredet. Und deshalb würde ich sagen, wir kommen jetzt endlich zu unserer ersten Kategorie, zum ersten Teil unserer Awards. Ich erkenne nochmal kurz, wir haben sowohl unter uns als Team komplett das abgestimmt. Dazu findet ihr nachher eine Grafik bei Social Media, wenn diese Folge online ist. Genauso haben wir dann auch die Community gefragt. Ihr habt auch zahlreich abgestimmt. Vielen lieben Dank dafür. Ich habe jetzt nicht die Top 3 gewählt, sondern tatsächlich immer der, der es gewonnen hat. Von der Community aus. Aber das erzählen wir dann euch. Wir beginnen mit der Kategorie Bester Trainer. Matthias, ich würde einfach mal bei dir starten. Wer ist es bei dir geworden?
Es gab ja einige Anwärter. Der offensichtlichste Pick, den haben wir sicherlich auch noch im Zuge unseres Austauschs erwähnt. Für mich war es tatsächlich Ralf Kettemann. Er geht mehr aus der A-Junior-Bundesliga zu einem ganz anderen Verein, darf erstmals Zweitligas Erfahrungen sammeln und dann zum Aufstiegstrainer wird. Der hat schon vieles richtig gemacht. Wir haben ja auch so über die Saison hinweg gesehen, dass er viele Verwandlungen sammelt und auch mal gesperrt ein Spiel pausieren musste. Auf mich wirkt er aber dennoch so, dass er sich trotz mancher Serie-Entscheidungen, mit denen er nicht so einverstanden ist, sich jetzt nicht ewig dran aufhängt. Für mich ist er schnell wieder fokussiert und klar am Spielfeldrand. Er wirkt jetzt nicht so wie jemand, der mit seinen Gedanken gassi geht und sich von seinen Emotionen wegtragen lässt. Auf mich wirkt er doch herrlich unverbrauchten authentisch. Ist auch medial, finde ich, sofort angekommen, macht da eine gute Figur vor dem Mikrofon, scheint bei sich zu bleiben. Ich hatte auch damals im März gesagt, dass er sein Team in die Länderspielpause schickt. Also im wahrsten Sinne. Die haben eine Woche lang nicht trainiert. Muss man auch erstmal machen. Hinten raus wurde es zäh gegen die Spitzen-Teams. Haben sie am meisten Federn gelassen. Also von den ersten Vieren haben sie, glaube ich, nur einmal unschiegen gegen Hannover gespielt. Natürlich gegen den sonst in Hannover. Also da haben sie ein bisschen was liegen lassen. Und dennoch, man hat auch dann gesehen, freilich in Überzahl, aber was sie gegen Wolfsburg dann auch abrennen können und anzünden können. Also sie sind im Stande, schon auch ihre spielerischen Qualitäten einzubringen und ich finde das einfach sehr bemerkenswert, was er als Newcomer sozusagen in Paderborn vorfindet und daraus gemacht hat. Und er ist auch für mich so eine Fortsetzung des Paderborner unterwegs, also unglaublich gute Scouting sowohl im Team als auch auf dem Trainerstuhl. Wir hatten Quasniok, wir hatten Baumgart, freilich irgendwie schreitbare Charaktere, aber dennoch welche, die da ein Umfeld vorgefunden haben, dass sie wiederum in gute Ergebnisse haben umwünschen können und dann reiht sich Ralf Kettemann nahtlos ein. Also ich finde es beeindruckend, eben vom U19-Coach ganz andere Setting, ganz anderer Verein, in ein neues Umfeld zu kommen und da sofort zu funktionieren. Chapeau.
Auch wenn er nicht meine Wahl geworden ist, möchte ich das alles unterstreichen und bekräftigen. Er war meine Nummer 2 am Ende. Ich möchte da auch den sehr, sehr guten Podcast From Coach to Coach empfehlen. Da waren jetzt schon mehrere Zweitligatrainer auf Vincent Wagner oder Thomas Stamm zu Gast. Ich höre den Podcast sehr gerne. Da reden Trainer tatsächlich einfach mal eine Stunde, anderthalb ungeschnitten mehr oder weniger über sich, ihre Vita, über ihre Methodiken als Trainer. Und da hat Ralf Kettemann einen herausragenden Auftritt auch gehabt. Generell möchte ich nämlich auch unterstreichen, ich finde ihn kommunikativ absurd gut. Also ich würde so weit gehen, das ist ein sehr großer Vergleich. Aber der letzte Trainer auf Deutsch, der mich so abgeholt hat, in seinen Ansprachen, in seiner Analyse, in seiner Menschlichkeit, ist tatsächlich Jürgen Klopp. Und dazu passt auch, dass er vielleicht an der Seitenlinie ab und zu mal kurz überschlägt, das gehört schon dazu. Wobei auch da Ralph Kettemann sich da kritisch hinterfragt und sagt, das muss besser werden. Aber in dem jungen Alter, ohne jegliche Profi-Erfahrung, deine Trainer-Karriere war ja die, dass er lange im Amateurbereich als Spielertrainer gearbeitet hat und seine Truppe hochgebracht hat in den gehobenen Amateurbereich und so dann zum KSC kam. Das fände ich schon herausragend. Dazu der definitiv durchtrainierteste Trainer in den ersten zwei Ligen Deutschlands. Das kann man jetzt auch sagen. Er hat ja blank gezogen, mehr oder weniger. Also dahingehend auch eine Maschine. Ich finde wirklich, dass das ein ganz fantastischer Trainer ist, der einen etwas anderen Ansatz fährt. Also wenn er auch darüber in diesem besagten Podcast erzählt, er trainiert fast ausschließlich 11 gegen 11. Weil das ist das, was er am Wochenende zählt. Er macht kaum kleine Spielformen. Das ist wiederum ein starker Kontrast zu einem Vincent Wagner, der fast nur kleine Spielform macht. Und du siehst, beides kann zum Erfolg führen. Das fände ich total schön auch, dass es da so unterschiedliche Typen geben kann und dass wir uns, glaube ich, in Deutschland auch wieder mehr lösen von diesem Idealbild Trainer, so wie es ein Idealbild Fußballer gab. Da geht es ja auch wieder mehr in Richtung Individualität fördern. Da habe ich das Gefühl, dass das im deutschen Trainerbereich auch wieder mehr wird. Und da ist Kettemann ein super Beispiel für– also ich möchte das auch unterschreiben– fantastische Saison geleistet und dieses Rückspiel gegen Wolfsburg über Zahl hin oder her, das war eine Machtdemonstration. Also wie die da angelaufen sind, extrem gut. Scheint dieser Truppe sehr viel Glauben zu schenken und sich auch nicht dann zu schäumen, irgendwie gefühlt den 19-Jährigen aus der Zeitenmannschaft irgendwie zur zweiten Halbzeit einzuwechseln, weil er glaubt halt an ihn und das macht einen guten Trainer aus.
Da ist auch interessant, dass er eben vom KSC kam und beim KSC würde man jetzt sicherlich gerne ein Asyl einsetzen wie ihn.
KSC auch, ja, gute Trainerschule, Quasenjau kommt da ja auch aus der Jugend, also.
Genau.
Anna, wer ist es denn bei dir geworden?
Ja, also ganz kurz einmal angeschlossen an meine Vorredner, kann ich alles total nachvollziehen. Ich würde gerne noch ergänzen, wie er es geschafft hat, dieses Nervenflattern, das man zwischenzeitlich, glaube ich, schon gesehen hat.
Voll.
Ich würde es gerne sehen, wie er es geschafft hat, in einem sehr jungen Kader, im Durchschnittsalter unter 25, wieder einzufangen und die aufzubauen. Und dann genau on point mit einem richtigen Energieakt gegen Wolfsburg im Rückspiel. Einerseits durch Konzentration und Fitness, aber gleichzeitig auch einfach so eine geringe Eitelkeit zu bestechen. Also kam ja dann Überzahl, also Standards, weil wir können das. Also machen wir das jetzt so lange, bis wir sie durchgekocht haben. Und das hat mir schon wirklich auch gut gefallen. Nichtsdestotrotz habe ich den offensichtlichen Miron Muslic auf die 1 gesetzt. Eigentlich aus ähnlichen Gründen, wie Marc sie gerade aufgezählt hat, sehr weit oben auch Rhetorik, öffentliches Auftreten. Was ich deswegen auffällig finde, weil ich glaube, dass das in Paderborn schon schwierig ist, wenn du dann plötzlich Aufmerksamkeit generierst, einfach weil deine Leistungen ganz gut sind. Und in Schalke hast du diese Aufmerksamkeit chronisch und ein Umfeld, das sehr enttäuscht war aus der vorigen Saison, dass du irgendwie wiederbeleben musstest. Das sind dann so die Soft-Skills. Dafür ist es dann doch irgendwie insgesamt zu wichtig. Das, was ich wirklich cool finde auf sportlicher Ebene, ist, dass sie vielleicht etwas knapper, aber den Aufstieg sehr wahrscheinlich auch geschafft hätten, mit dem Ansatz aus der Hinrunde. Eher defensiver, destruktiv, so weit würde ich vielleicht nicht gehen, aber jetzt nicht offensiv bestechend. Und das dann anzupassen, vielleicht um auf Nummer sicher zu gehen, aber auch, weil man dieses Potenzial noch hat und ausschöpfen kann bzw. als Schalke vielleicht sogar ausschöpfen sollte, fand ich gut, weil das auch, finde ich, für eine hohe Professionalität spricht. Also es passiert, glaube ich, im Fußball total oder viel zu oft, dass die Ergebnisse stimmen. Also geht man nicht in so eine radikale Fehleranalyse, sondern setzt den Weg halt fort, um sich dann halt langfristig in die Nesseln zu setzen, weil du die blinden Flecken ignorierst, weil ja die Punkte irgendwie kommen. Und in diese Falle ist Schalke nicht getappt, hat dann mit Jeko einen... Ich glaube, wir waren alle irgendwie so zwischen begeistert, irritiert, schockiert und das klappt niemals. Also alles auf dieser ganzen Skala. Und das passt, finde ich, auch zu Schalke. Und deswegen ist es irgendwie rund, dass du halt diesen Verein hast, der sich immer wieder aus dem Fenster lehnt und endlich funktioniert es auch wieder. Und ich glaube, wenn du jemanden hast, der dieses Umfeld nicht nur aushält, sondern embraced und da irgendwie reinpasst, ohne das zu spielen, weil das hast du so unerträglich häufig, dass ich die Leute da irgendwie anbiedere in einer Art, die eklig ist. Ich glaube, das ist einfach ein Match. Und ich habe es nicht mit Schalke und wünsche aufrichtig echt alles Gute für die Bundesliga, weil ich die Saison großartig fand. Und gerade dieser Endspur, das Spiel gegen Paderborn, das Spiel gegen Elbersberg, was für Nerven, mit unverdientem Platz verweisen und so dann einfach zu sagen, nein, wir machen das jetzt. Wir ziehen jetzt durch, wir suchen keine Ausreden. Bam! Und dann waren die da und sind aufgestiegen und sowas von verdient. Wirklich super.
Wunderbar gesagt. Gehe ich genauso mit. Ist auch mein Platz 1 geworden, Jura Muzlic. Eben aufgrund dieser erhöhten Fallhöhe, die du beschrieben hast, Anna, im Schalkeumfeld, weil das noch mal komplizierter ist. Es ist eine andere Erwartungshaltung, rein sportlich da, aber eben auch rein emotional möchtest du in einem Trainer auf Schalke anders abgeholt werden als jetzt in Paderborn. Und der hatte einen riesigen Rucksack auf Miron Muzlic. Das war der Trainer, der, also wenn man nur drauf geschaut hat, objektiv, nicht in die tiefer liegenden Zahlen. Das war der Trainer, der in die dritte englische Liga abgeschiegen ist und für den Zahlen jetzt auch noch ablöse, sind die denn bescheuert. So, das war die Erwartungshaltung. Und dann dieses Umfeld so abzuholen, kommunikativ diesen Glauben in der Mannschaft auszulösen und dann durch Ergebnisse eben auch bei den Zuschauern und den Journalistinnen, das fand ich ganz beeindruckend. Und das hätte ich nämlich auch noch herausgearbeitet, dieser fußballerische Wandel zur Rückrunde. Das können die wenigsten Trainer allein schon aus Ego gründen heraus, weil die dann ja auch meistens sagen, ich stehe jetzt dafür. Dafür möchte ich jetzt gelobt werden, aber wie du sagst, Anna, da so selbstlos in diese Fehleranalyse zu gehen, das muss auch vom Verein gesteuert werden. Das ist ja auch eines der Probleme, die Hertha seit Jahren hat. Dass man das eben nicht tiefgehend genug gemacht hat. Das so zu tun und zu sagen, wir haben einen ganz klaren Plan in der Hinrunde, wollen wir gucken, was auch mit dem bestehenden Kader geht. In der Zeit hat da ja auch Spieler wie Vitali Becker sehr, sehr, sehr viel besser gemacht. Also das kommt ja noch dazu, die werden am Ende Meister und haben sogar noch junge Spieler gefördert. Und dann gucken wir in der Winterpause, wo sind unsere Schwächen und passen dementsprechend an. Ja, Eden Dzeko ist in den Shows gefallen, aber darüber hinaus gab es ja auch Spieler mit Aoshisho und Co., die vielleicht auch später bei Awards eine Rolle spielen werden. Das kann schon sein. Ich fand es taktisch wie kommunikativ war das eine glatte Eins. Und deswegen muss für mich das am Ende auch dieser Award sein.
Ja, da gehe ich tatsächlich mit. Also wir haben hier drei von vier, die Miron Muslice haben, weil eben auch bei mir reingezählt hat, dass einfach, was ich schon gesagt habe, diese Erwartungshaltung, die mit reinkam, dass nach der letzten Saison, wo man mit jemandem wie Kies van Wonderen einen Trainer geholt hat, den vielleicht niemand auf dem Schirm hatte. Und wir eigentlich auch immer sagen, dieses Trainer-Karussell in der 2. Liga nervt uns eigentlich brutal. Also gerade vor allem in der 2. Liga, weil du eigentlich immer die gleichen 4, 5 Namen in so einem wirklich auf einem Karussell sitzen hast und wirklich denkst, ach, jetzt fährt der schon wieder an mir vorbei. Und eigentlich, du dann klar davon wissensfällst, dann so ein bisschen, was sie erwarten können. Und vielleicht auch haben schon Erwartungen, positiv und negativ. Bei der Muslice war es halt einfach diese dann doch weitreichende Unbekanntheit. Und ich muss auch wirklich sagen, also mit was für einer Ruhe man das am Ende geschafft hat und wie man da ins Ziel rein ja vorsichtig gejoggt ist eigentlich. Das war schon echt eine krasse Nummer und man muss auch sagen, ich glaube es passiert einfach generell am Standort Schalke gerade relativ viel. Auch mit den Frauen und so, die sind gerade Westfalen-Pokalsieger geworden, die spielen dann nächstes Jahr auch im DFB-Pokal mit. Das heißt, ich glaube generell passiert einfach an dem Standort relativ viel. Und ich glaube, dass aber alles, wie man so das Gefühl hat, es ist endlich mal ein Entwachstum im Vergleich zum letzten Bundesliga-Aufstieg, das so ein bisschen smoother verläuft und mehr mit Ziel und mehr mit Plan und auch finanziell, dass man da irgendwie das Gefühl hat, da sitzen jetzt vielleicht auch endlich mal die richtigen Leute. Und das ist das Wichtigste, was für Schalke ansteht. Man hat ja, wie ich finde, so ein bisschen mit dem HSV so eine Blaupause bekommen vielleicht in dieser Saison, wie es gehen könnte, wie es vielleicht auch nicht geht. Also nicht, dass man es eins zu eins umsetzen kann. Aber ich glaube, wir haben ja schon gesehen, dass den HSV hinterher dann doch zum Klassenerhalt geführt hat, wo man eben dann doch vielleicht noch mal auch den Stellenwert, den Schalke 04 dann im deutschen Fußball hat, ausnutzen sollte, um Spieler auch zu holen. Da bin ich deshalb auch sehr gespannt, wie es dann in der Bundesliga weitergeht. Ich kann euch noch sagen, bei euch, bei der Community, hat Miron Muslitsch mit über 50 Prozent der Stimmen gewonnen. Oder auch Moron Muslitsch oder Mirko Muslitsch. Ich glaube, ich habe mehr unterschiedliche Namensweisen bekommen, als Bielefeld Auswärtspunkte geholt hat in dieser Saison.
Oder Herrtheim.
Also es war wirklich Schapo. Vielen Dank dafür. Aber wie gesagt, Miron Muslitsch mit wirklich hoher Musik. Vielleicht noch einen honorable mention, weil er hinterher tatsächlich auch bei uns in den Awards vom Allstar-Team war. Wir haben jetzt relativ wenig über Vincent Wagner gesprochen, auch der. Also ich musste mich zwischen den beiden entscheiden. Bei mir war es tatsächlich Vincent Wagner quasi Platz 1B, weil ich da eben auch fand, wir haben so viel darüber geredet, dass er dieses Erbe antreten musste von Horst Steffen. Und dann ging Ebnut Talib auch noch im Winter und so. Man dachte, ja, jetzt brechen sie aber ja ein. Und sie haben es am Ende trotzdem geschafft. Und das, finde ich, muss man dennoch auch noch honorieren. Anna?
Ja, also meinen Platz, jetzt gehen wir hier aufs Treppchen sogar. Ich finde, auch Thomas Stamm ist absolut zu erwähnen. Weil, what the fuck, die waren ja zum Winter eigentlich weg. Und da dann einen Verein zu haben, der sagt, nein, wir machen weiter, weil spielerisch passt das. Und wir stärken jetzt den Trainer, indem wir ein bisschen nochmal hier auf die Transfer-Tube drücken. Und dann reißt er das wirklich rum. Ich glaube, Rückrunden, Tabellenplatz 4. Überragend, wirklich ganz großartig. Richtig, richtig starke Leistung.
Bitte nicht zu viel spoilern, dann eventuell taucht Dynamo Dresden auch mal in mir schon auf. Matthias, du wolltest gerne auch noch was erkennen.
Genau, also auch die 4 schwebten mir im Kopf rum. Die, die wir gerade erwähnt hatten, wenn man jetzt nochmal an die Tabellenspitze guckt. Also drei Teams sind hochgegangen, die allesamt Trainerwunsch und Novizen für die 2. Liga hatten. Das heißt, die sind ausgebrochen aus dem Karussell, das wir gerade so ein bisschen angehäupt haben. Und das ist schon wirklich aller Ehren wert. Und verdiene da auch nochmal eine Erwähnung, dass es eben auch so geht. Und bin gespannt, wie sie sich dann in der Erstlastigkeit schlagen.
Und das sind auch alles Trainer, die einfach trotz gewisser Situation in der Saison oder vor der Saison an ihrem Fußball festgehalten haben. Dynamo Dresden hat durchgängig denselben Fußball eigentlich gespielt. Und damit meine ich nicht– das meine ich eben nicht negativ, sondern positiv– dieser mutige, lebensbejahende Fußball mit viel Struktur, der, wie Anna richtig herausgestellt hat, in der Hinrunde vor allem individuelle Probleme hatte. Denen haben sie dann weiter durchgezogen und wurden dafür belohnt. Sie haben am Ende den Trainer über den Sportdirektor gestellt. Das haben wir ja nicht vergessen. Also Sören Gontahal hat ja dann im Winter benommen, weil es mit dem vorherigen Sportdirektor nicht weiterging, weil der diese Strategie anscheinend nicht mittragen wollte. Wahrscheinlich weil sein Glauben in Thomas Stamm vielleicht nicht so groß war. So habe ich es zumindest gelesen, aus dieser personalen Entscheidung heraus. Also ich finde, dass Thomas Stamm einen fantastischen Job gemacht hat. Keine Frage. Und Vincent Wagner auch da, was Elversberg wieder für den Fußball gespielt hat. Allein das wäre ja– selbst wenn sie nicht aufgestiegen wären– allein schon wieder eine Leistung gewesen, dass man am Ende das dann sogar so über die Ziellinie bringt, mit diesem Fußball. Brutal. Also alle hätten es in dem Sinne verdient, mit unterschiedlichen Ausgangsvoraussetzungen. Deswegen finde ich, ist es letztendlich dieses Viererpack.
Zeigt auch. Man hat mit Stamm ja auch jemanden, der aus einem Unterbau von einem anderen Bundesligisten kommt. Also aus der Freiburger Schule. Wagner aus der Hoffenheimer Schule, wenn man so will und eben Kettimann aus der Karlsruhe-Schule. Irgendwas muss da in Baden-Württemberg verdammt gut laufen.
Ich sag mal so, Hertha hatte damals wohl die Entscheidung zwischen Thomas Stamm und Christian Fier. Nein.
Das wird dir doch immer noch ein Marc muss seine emotionalen Ballast von Hertha BSC. Ich kann mal spoilern. Ich wollte eigentlich noch einen Marc-Schwitzky-Award machen. Ich hab's dir ja sogar geschrieben von wegen so. Ein Verein, der mich so enttäuscht hat, wie Hertha BSC, Marc. Also ich war kurz davor. Ich dachte, das ist uncallt vor, dann noch am Ende. Aber was nicht uncallt vor ist, dass wir jetzt als Nächstes unseren besten Spieler wählen und ich sag jetzt einfach mal, Marc, fang du doch jetzt einfach mal an.
Einmal kurz vorher die Frage an euch gestellt. Habt ihr euch bei dem Award schwer getan?
Nee.
Sieht nicht so aus. Okay, Award relativ.
Es gab schon viele, die in der Verlosung hätten sein können, aber ich hab mich dann auf einen eingeschossen, der vielleicht nicht bei den anderen vorne dran ist.
Okay, bin ich gespannt, bin ich gespannt. Dann mach ich jetzt einfach mal den Anfang. Meine Wahl ist letztendlich auf Marvin Wainizek herausgekommen, der vielleicht die offensichtliche Wahl ist. Auch da habe ich wieder ein paar Randbemerkungen für andere Spieler, die es durchaus verdient gehabt hätten. Aber an sich ist es erstmal Marvin Wainizek. Ich habe mir den früh notiert und bin dann noch mal in die Zahlen gegangen und war so, ich komme nicht um ihn herum, es geht nicht. Der Mann ist bei 22 direkten Torbeteiligung rausgegangen aus der Saison. Das ist das absolute Herz dieser Mannschaft. Dann geht es auch noch tiefergehend um Dinge wie, der ist Platz 3 beim Kriieren von Chancen, Platz 5 bei Großchancen, Platz 3 bei Expected Assists. Wenn seine Kollegen noch ein bisschen effizienter gewesen wären, hätte der noch mehr direkte Torbeteiligung verdient gehabt. Er hat mehr Tore aufgelegt, als es letztendlich geworden sind. Dann kommt noch so etwas hinzu, mit 33 Jahren übrigens, dass der auf Platz 23 der gesamten Liga beim Erobern von Bällen im letzten Drittel ist. Vor ihm stehen sehr viele Spieler, die meist nur eingewechselt wurden. Diese Contees und so weiter dieser Welt, die eine Viertelstunde haben, um noch vorne anzulaufen. Deswegen finde ich, ist diese Zahl noch höher zu bewerten, weil der nur mal jedes Spiel macht, über 90 Minuten. Also, wenn man sich ein KSC-Spiel anguckt und man bräuchte gar nicht die Historie von Wanił Cech und Co., man würde sofort sehen, um diesen Spieler geht es beim KSC. Der hat sich in dieser Saison auch nie beeindrucken lassen von den Schwächephasen seiner Mannschaft. Er hat eigentlich immer gescord. Er hat jetzt nicht immer Spiele, wo er plötzlich vier Scorer hatte, sondern er hat vielleicht mal drei Spiele ohne Scorer verbracht. Und dann kam wieder was vom Laster gefallen. Er ist immer da gewesen. Ich standard schütze, par excellence. Also für mich war das einfach der präsenteste Spieler dieser Saison. Und deswegen kam ich nicht um ihn herum. Ich glaube aber auch, dass es andere sehr verdiente Spieler gibt.
Ja, dann frage ich dich einfach mal, Anna, was gibt es denn noch für andere verdiente Spieler?
Also ich habe viel hin und her geschoben, weil wir haben ja auch noch andere Kategorien und ich wollte nicht doppelt nennen.
Deswegen kommt Ron Torbenhoffmann jetzt hier.
Nein, nein, nein. Könnte aber, könnte aber. Meine Wahl ist tatsächlich Noel Futtkoi, weil, also aka Lebensversicherung, ohne den würde Greuther Fürth, glaube ich, im Winter schon direkt abgestiegen sein. Und dessen Leistungsdaten auch wirklich absolut absurd. 19 Tore, 5 Vorlagen in der Relegation, nur noch ein Tor dann im Rückspiel gegen Rot-Weiß-Essen und damit tatsächlich eben wesentlich dazu beigetragen, dass der Verein die Klasse hält. Und die Leistungsdaten offensiver Natur sind schon wirklich, also ich glaube, es sind insgesamt mit dem Tor in der Relegation dann viermal so viele Tore wie der beste Stürmer in der Braunschweiger Eintracht, also Stürme, der Torschütze, der Braunschweiger Eintracht geschossen hat. Also nicht ganz ohne Neid verleihe ich diesen Award, auch wenn ich tatsächlich gar nicht so krass an so Stürmern hänge. Also ich finde andere Positionen im Fußball eigentlich spannender, weil es irgendwie so offensichtlich ist. Auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite ist es halt einfach da so messbar, wie sie dazu beitragen, dass ein Verein Erfolg hat. Und die Leistungsdaten sind nicht nur grundsätzlich auffällig, sondern eben auch hervorgegangen in einer Saison, die sehr schwierig gewesen ist, sehr turbulent, wo der Kader viel umgebaut worden ist, mit verschiedenen Kollegen zusammenspielen musste, die nicht immer performt haben. Also, oh Gott, na egal, also dieses, na ja. Also wirklich, ja so, dass man wirklich, ich hab Wirtspiele gesehen und dachte, manchmal, das ist ja wie auf Pause gedrückt. Warum hören die dann plötzlich auf, sich zu bewegen? Das ist ja unglaublich. Und…
Wir erinnern uns an das Kenneth-Eichhaut-Tor in der Rückrunde.
Also wirklich unglaublich. Und dann innerhalb eines solchen Kuddelmudels, das ist ein Wort, das mir jetzt einfach da in den Sinn kommt, so hervorzustechen, ist natürlich einerseits leicht und andererseits sehr schwer. Weil hervorzustechen ist leicht, aber dafür zu sorgen, dass man hervorstecht, ist sehr schwer, weil du wirklich das Beste aus allem machen musst, was du bekommst. Und das hat der Junge auf jeden Fall gemacht. Deswegen mein Award an.
Voll verdient.
Ja. Matthias, wer ist es denn bei dir geworden?
Ja, bei mir wurde es ein Local Player. Also ich habe mich tatsächlich für Fraser Hornby entschieden.
Wolfsburg-Legende.
Sorry, zu früh, zu früh. Wir greifen vor, aber ich hätte tatsächlich geschlossen mit dem Worten, er geht zum Lord Voldemort in der nächsten Zweitligasaison. Also leider geht er nach Wolfsburg, aber ich glaube, er hat auch gute Gründe geliefert, warum Wolfsburg ihn will. Also er ist einfach ein Keyplayer für Darmstadt gewesen, hat lange Zeit den Höhenflug mitgetragen, ist sehr flexibel einsetzbar, initiiert oft genug das Pressing, ist im Spielaufbau präsent, Spielverlagerung, Spielverständnis, Körperlichkeit, ist fast so groß wie Voldemort, technisch ähnlich beschlagen.
Zweitiger Voldemort, das sage ich immer wieder, fast perfekt dahingehend.
Er hat auch eine enorme Spielfreude ausgedrückt und war jetzt 3 Jahre in Darmstadt aus einem anfänglich sehr schweren, wie soll man sagen, aus einem großen Tief herausgekämpft. Mit ihm hatte ich mal ein Interview und ich glaube, ich habe sie auch schon mal erwähnt. Er hatte tatsächlich mentale Probleme, kam her, hatte eine schwere Verletzung, war kaum präsent, wurde dann von den Fans auch ein bisschen verhöhnt, wenn er beim Warmmachen das vorgetroffen hat. Was macht das mit einem, wenn er in ein anderes Land kommt und da plötzlich liefern soll, aber sich selbst enttäuscht. Das ist auch sehr selbstkritisch und sehr reflektiert im Gespräch. Und dann so rauszukommen und zu einer Säule des Teams zu werden, auch zum Vizekapitän, das heißt da schon Kapitän. Das hat er dann immer auf dem Feld auch die Gespräche mit dem Schiedsrichter gesucht, aber jetzt nicht irgendwie überzogen, sondern hat er auch versucht, ja, quasi parat zu stehen und auch seinen Punkt natürlich zu machen. Und er hatte letztlich nur in 24 von 34 Spielen gespielt. Das ist vielleicht auch mit dem Grund, warum es dann zum Ende hin dünn wurde bei den Ligien. Und ja, im Endeffekt ist es persönlich gefärbt natürlich, ihn da jetzt hier in der Kategorie zu erwähnen. Aber ich glaube, auch FodMob, diese Datenbank, die wir hier gerne auch erwähnen, hat ihn zum besten Offensivspieler der 2. Liga nicht gekürt, aber sie haben ihn zumindest so bewertet. Und auch das zeigt ja schon, da gab es andere, wie Kindern, Karaman oder Bilbia oder sonst wer, die da durchaus in Frage kamen. Aber er wurde am besten bewertet. Und ich glaube eben, wie anfangs gesagt, wenn ihn Wolfsburg holt, dann ist da sicherlich viel gut gelaufen. Letzten Saison insbesondere und zu Lasten der Lilien. Aber man kriegt ja auch ein bisschen Kleingeld insofern. Fraser Horn wie mein Pick.
Finde ich sehr, sehr schön. Bei mir ist es tatsächlich auch Noel Futkoy geworden. Auch einfach, weil ich es ein bisschen interpretiert habe als MVP. Also wirklich Most Valuable Player. Was ist, wenn ich den Spieler aus einer Mannschaft nehme, performt sie dann immer noch so. Und Anna hat eben schon sehr gut aufgearbeitet, warum sie das nicht tun würde. Und deshalb war es bei mir eben auch Noel Futkoy. Er hat sicherlich, also konnte eben auch herausstechen in diesem Team. Aber ja, also es gab ja auch, wer die Relegationsspiele gesehen hat, da gab es so eine kleine Side-Story mit ihm und seinem ersten Gegenspieler. Vielleicht auch ein bisschen unrühmlich zum Teil. Aber ich glaube, man hat ihn per se schon angesehen, dass es, also auch wenn er eben, ist ja klar, dass eigentlich die Eintracht die eben die Rückkaufoption nimmt. Und dann hätte es ihm ab dem Zeitpunkt ja in der Theorie, sag ich jetzt mal, auch egal sein können, weil er wusste, er ist zumindest immer Eintracht Frankfurt Kosmos in der nächsten Saison. Und das fand ich schon, also der hat sich schon reingeworfen. Ich hatte schon das Gefühl, dem bedeutet das dann schon auch noch was für die Führter zu spielen und da eben diesen Klassenerhalt abseits von selber Kickbase-Statistiken zu machen. Also das war schon wichtig. Die Community, er fiel hier eben schon mal, die haben Kenan Karaman gewählt. Ich kann euch sagen, bevor jetzt hier die Heugabeln ausgepackt werden, Kenan Karaman war durchaus auch im Old-Zeit-Team gut vertreten. Wir haben jetzt gerade genau eine Vierer-Runde hier gewählt. Wo es Kenan Karaman nicht auf Platz 1 geschafft hat. Aber er ist vielleicht, also, wir haben eben glaube ich schon mal gesagt, wir haben schon immer versucht, nicht immer den ersten Pick zu nehmen, so und den offensichtlichen. Und ich glaube, das erklärt es dann auch gefolgt. Aber übrigens von Furtkow und Vanicek. Also mal mit Vanicek auch bei der Community weiter hoch. Wie gesagt, ich nenne euch jetzt keine genauen Prozente, weil auch Kenan Karaman hatte unterschiedliche Schreibweisen. Also wie nur in Furtkow. Ich habe es dann einfach irgendwann gelassen. Ich wollte, die habe ich noch bei Miranuslitsch den Taschenrechner ausgepackt. Dann wurde es mir ehrlich gesagt irgendwann zu doof. Bitte verzeiht das. Gibt es noch irgendwelche honorable mentions, die ihr hier unterbringen wollt, ohne vielleicht gleichzeitig zu viel für die späteren Kategorien wegzunehmen?
Ich hatte noch drei Namen. Der eine ist, also ich mache es wirklich schnell, der eine ist Laurin Koda. Der hat eine absurd gute Saison für Paderborn gespielt, auch in der Relegation. Er war ja der mit dem entscheidenden Treffer. Bin ich jetzt doof? Genau. Das war ja nach Michel-Vorlage war es auch Koda. Herausragende Saison, auch in den Scorer-Werten. Auch eine tolle Karriere über Oberliga und so weiter zu Paderborn. Fantastische Saison, auch als Kapitän. Ich würde gerne Hasan Kurucay zumindest erwähnen. Also Karaman hat letztens irgendwo gesagt, der kam ablösefrei zur Schalke. Der kannte ihn vorher auch nicht. Um nachhinein rafft er überhaupt nicht, wie das möglich war, dass der ablösefrei zu haben war.
Der kam aus Braunschweig, das ist der Grund.
So, aber was ist da denn los, Anna? Da kannst du vielleicht gleich noch mal Worte zu verlieren, falls er nicht bei dir irgendwo nur vorkommt oder so. Hasan Kurucay hat eine überragende Saison gespielt und ist eigentlich das Gesicht dieser irren Schalke Abwehrleistung dieser Saison, besonders eben in dieser Viererkette. Also den, finde ich, muss man auch irgendwie erwähnen. Und wenn wir im Tor sind, dann kann man zwar Loris Karius nennen. Ich bin bei Thiago Ernst rausgekommen, was ich auch gerne erwähnen würde. Thiago Ernst hat eine absolut gute Saison gespielt. Auch da, das, was du eben gesagt hast, Eva, wenn man ihn aus dem Team rausnehmen würde, würde die Mannschaft genauso spielen. Nein, das kann man bei Hertha definitiv sagen. Der Mann hat nämlich fast 10 Tore statistisch verhindert. Und deswegen sieht Hertha's Defensive auf dem Blatt sehr gut aus. Aber es lag zu großen Teilen an Thiago Ernst, der auch eine riesige Steigung zur letzten Saison hatte. Ich würde ihn aufgrund seines Alters noch ein bisschen vor Karius schieben, weil man das da noch weniger erwartet bei so jungen Teutern. Also die drei Namen würde ich gerne nennen. Aber Anna, möchtest du ganz kurz, wenn Kurochall bei euch jetzt irgendwo nicht mehr vorkommt, ganz kurz sagen, wie das möglich ist, dass man den verloren hat, weil er mehr wollte? Oder hat er das schon bei Braunschweig gezeigt? Wie ist das?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also, ohne den wäre es bei uns auch arg duscher gewesen, schon vorher. Ich fand es sehr, sehr bedauerlich, dass er ging, weil der, ähm... Ich finde, ich weiß nicht genau, ich müsste jetzt noch mal drauf achten, aber der ist so ein bisschen, der hat Seite an Seite gespielt, in Ermin Bičačić letzter Zweitliga-Saison. Und ich fand, dass du irgendwann gesehen hast, wie sehr der von diesem seniorigen Schlacht raus profitiert hat, dass es richtig so quasi Bewegungsabläufe waren, die angefangen haben, sich zu ähneln. Und der ist dann zur Schalke gegangen und ich finde es so unterhaltsam. Weiß ich nicht, ob unterhaltsam das richtige Wort ist. Aber dass er dann manchmal so ein bisschen gehöhnt wird, wenn er irgendwie gegen den Abstieg gespielt hat, dann kann er ja nicht so gut sein. So was wollt ihr damit, ihr heutigen Scout so. Und dass du aber gerade als Abwehrspieler dir im Abstiegskampf halt echt ziemlich stabile Sporen verdienen kannst. Das finde ich aktuell auch– Torben Hoffmann wird ja auch beispielsweise in Paderborn gehandelt oder so. Und dann heißt es immer, naja, gut, die Eintracht, die hat ja keine gute Saison gespielt. Und dann denk ich, ja, aber du willst den Torhüter eines unterdurchschnittlichen Kaders, der es irgendwie gebacken bekommen hat, zum Klassenerhalt beizutragen. Also vielleicht ist das nicht die schlechteste Referenz. Insofern bin ich von der Entwicklung wirklich, also vielleicht in der Spitze, kann man das prophezeien, weiß ich nicht genau, in der Summe, aber nicht überrascht. Ja, und insofern fair, ne? Also ich habe so das Gefühl, es ist eine gewisse Scouting-Verbindung aktuell zwischen Schalke und Braunschweig.
Weiß nicht, was du meinst.
Wir haben jetzt auch einen Torhüter wieder verpflichtet aus Schalke.
Wann wird da die offizielle Kooperation eigentlich mal verkündet?
Das frage ich mich auch.
Das ist ja wirklich sehr offensichtlich. Aber ich wollte so Leute wie Kurochai oder Ernst nennen, weil das Positionen sind, die eigentlich nie genannt werden, weil sie eben nicht die hohen Scorer-Werte oder so präsentieren können, finde ich total wichtig, die auch mal zu nennen. Aber lasst uns gerne weitermachen.
Tja, würde ich sagen, also ich glaube nochmal gute Namen. Wie auch immer der Hinweis, wenn ihr da noch mehr Ergänzungen habt, schreibt es einfach gerne hinter in Feedback. Aber ich glaube, wir haben es schon mal ganz gut abgedeckt. Und wie gesagt, nochmal der Hinweis, es kommen auch noch mehr Namen in dem gesamten Olzer-Team. Aber ich dachte, es wäre ein bisschen repetitiv, dann immer die gesamten 12 Namen aufzulisten. Ich glaube, das möchte hier auch keiner hören. Dann kommen wir tatsächlich zur nächsten Kategorie. Und das ist die des besten Zweitliganewcomer, der 23 Jahre oder älter ist. Ich sage schon mal, zwei zumindest bei uns, aber auch woanders. Also ich hatte zwischendurch übrigens auch bei Trainer sowas wie Sebastian Hoeneß dastehen, wo ich dachte so, Zweitliga, Zweite Liga. Er kann nicht überall gewinnen, ich fasse so. Genau, und da hatten wir eben genau auf die Spieler geguckt, die neu in die Zweite Liga kamen, aber nicht diesen klassischen Youngster-Effekt erfüllen, sondern eben auch als Aufsteiger oder wie auch immer die erste Zweitliga-Saison spielen. Und Matthias legt da doch gerne mal los. Wer ist es denn da bei dir geworden?
Matthias Zuckowski ist es geworden. Ja, kam ja wie Phönix aus der Asche. Plötzlich hatten sie einen Neuzugang im Spätherbst so ein bisschen. Und ich hatte jetzt Magdeburg nicht verfolgt und konnte deshalb gar nicht sagen, dass er bei denen auf dem Gehaltszettel steht. Aber er hatte ja offenbar einen Mittelfußbruch und man hat sich auf den letzten Drücker trotzdem entschieden, ihn zu verpflichten aus der polnischen ersten Liga. Und selbst da galt er ja nicht unbedingt als Torjäger, sondern eher als Außenbahnspieler mitunter sogar defensiv. Keine Ahnung, was da schiefgelaufen ist. Auf jeden Fall hat er sich ja hier sehr treffsicher präsentiert. 17 Treffer, 3 Assists und sein erstes Spiel war am 13. Spieltag. Und ab dann war er mehr oder minder Stammkraft und hat dann auch prompt gezündet, in dem der erfolgreiche Hinrunden-Endspurt durchaus mit ihm verbunden werden konnte. Als er kam, hatten sie 9 Tore geschossen und 7 Punkte gesammelt in 12 Spielen und dann ging es schon mal in die richtige Richtung. Gefolgt dann von einem eher stotternden Rückrunden-Auftakt und dann war es ein bisschen zäh, aber er hat trotzdem verlässlich geknipst und schlussendlich auch Martijn Kars vergessen gemacht, der ja auch eine sehr gute Trefferquote in Magdeburg hatte.
Und das hat man ja fast ausgeschlossen gehalten, oder?
Definitiv, definitiv, ja. Und was einfach seine Qualitäten sind, sofern ich das aus den Highlights und mitunter auch mal spielen heraus sehen konnte, ich denke, er ist durchaus flink, also ein schnellerer Angreifer. Eine gute Ballbehandlung und auch Verarbeitung, also es steht mit dem Ball jetzt nicht auf Kriegsfuß und der Torabschluss, klar, die Quote spricht für sich, hat auch eine gewisse Wucht und Dynamik. Ist auch ins Angriffsspiel mit eingebunden, also ist jetzt nicht nur der Abnehmer mit Artikatz gut funktioniert. Und wenn ich es richtig gesehen habe, zuletzt auch für die Nationalmannschaft nominiert worden und auch prompt zum Einsatz gekommen. Also hat sich mit einem Mittelfußbruch eingeschrieben und ging als glorreicher König in die Sommerpause. Also schon bemerkenswert. Mir überhaupt kein Begriff gewesen, aber hat auf sich aufmerksam gemacht.
Marc, möchtest du direkt ergänzen, wenn du sagst, dass du als Mittelfuß-Bundesliga-Spieler in der Liga-Szene gewinnen möchtest?
Ich finde die Zahlen wirklich absurd. Da kommt jemand als etatmäßiger Rechtsverteidiger, der dann, ich glaube, er hatte fünf Spiele bis dahin als Mittelstürmer in seiner Karriere. Also irgendwo in der letzten Saison hat man es kurz gerochen, anscheinend bei seinem Ex-Club. Aber auch da hat er noch kein Tor, glaube ich, als Mittelstürmer gemacht. Und dann muss man als Magdeburg, die ja auch kreativ scouten, darauf kommen zu sagen, das wird übrigens unsere Sturmhoffnung für die nächste Saison. Das ist schon, da muss man sehr viel sehen. Und der Scout, der das gesehen hat, dem muss man eigentlich, weiß ich nicht, nochmal 13. Gehalt zuschießen, weil das schon irre gut ist. Der hat in, wie gesagt, 21 Spielen 17 Toren, drei Vorlagen gemacht. Wenn wir nur auf die Minuten pro Tor, nee, andersrum gucken, dann liegt er bei 0,83 pro 90 Minuten. Wenn wir, wenn wir Ebnut Alip mal rausrechnen, ist niemand ansatzweise so gut gewesen in dieser Saison in der 2. Liga. Das finde ich wirklich Wahnsinn. Und was nicht noch zu seinen Stärken zählen würde, Matthias, Laufwege. Der hat ein so natürliches Gespür als Mittelstürmer für gute Laufwege, wo man sich auch fragt eben, wo das herkommt. Verrückt. Also da würde mich irgendwann noch mal ein längeres Interview mit ihm eigentlich interessieren, weil er glaube ich selber noch nicht viel gesprochen hat, ob der das vielleicht trotzdem in der Jugend mal gespielt hat und dann vielleicht, es gibt ja diese Geschichten, spielst du es in der Jugend, aber vielleicht bist du körperlich dann nicht an dem Punkt, wo dich gewisse Trainer sehen, dann wirst du nach hinten verfrachtet, weil du bist vielleicht schnell so und so. Finde ich eine irre Geschichte. Bin mir recht sicher, dass er diese Saison für viel Geld irgendwo anders hingehen wird. Ich glaube nicht, dass Magdeburg den halten kann. Und dann ist das wirklich ein One-Season-Wonder-Welt, vielleicht zu viel, weil vielleicht beweist er es ja noch weitere Saisons, aber völlig irre und muss hier gewinnen.
Oh, direkt provokant.
Ja, nein, stimmt nicht. Es gibt auch da, wo ich mir andere Namen notiert habe. Aber ich finde schon, als wir diese Awards gemacht haben, war das der allererste Name, den ich notiert habe. Von allem.
Anna, hattest du auch direkt was im Kopf?
Ja, tatsächlich. Und auch da taktisch platziert, weil wir haben noch andere Kategorien, in die er auch hätte einsortiert werden können. Nämlich ist Mitte Januar zu Hannover 96 gewechselt mit Stefan Taito-Thorderson aus der 2. englischen Liga, vom Zweitligisten Preston Northend. Er ist Isländer, auch isländischer Nationalspieler und spielt im Mittelfeld. Hat von dort aus durchaus, ja, also für jemanden, der nicht im Sturm spielt und nur eine Serie, die die Rückserie mitgemacht hat, 3 Tore geschossen, 2 vorgelegt bei 50 Prozent Startelf-Quote, 50 Prozent eingewechselt. Und meiner Einschätzung nach wesentlicher Anteil dafür, dass Hannover 96 überhaupt noch in die Situation gekommen ist, oben mitzuspielen, in der Hinrundentabelle auf Platz 5 mit 29 Punkten, in der Rückrundentabelle dann auf Platz 2 vorgeklettert, leider ja über diese chronische Heimschwäche nicht hinweggekommen, die vielleicht noch mit dem Trainer zu tun hat. Bei Magdeburg hatte das gleiche Problem in der letzten Saison, ich weiß es nicht genau. Auf jeden Fall hat es mir sehr imponiert und so anekdotisch wähle ich hier meine Awardkandidaten, dass ich das Spiel in Karlsruhe von Hannover 96 live im Stadion gesehen habe und mir ist eine Szene in Erinnerung geblieben. Da gab es eine Freistoßsituation vom rechten Strafe am Eck und Todderson hat den Freistoß nicht selbst ausgeführt, hat aber den Ball platziert und dem Spieler, der den Freistoß schießen sollte, angedeutet, er solle jetzt bitte hier diesen Freistoß schießen. Und ich glaube, dass du ohne einen Spieler, der so schnell gerne Verantwortung übernimmt und das auch konstruktiv tut und positiv tut, nicht auf diese Straße kommst, auf die Hannover ja tatsächlich dann noch eingebogen ist. Und deswegen, genau, mein Platz 1 an dieser Stelle, Todderson, denn ich finde auch den Namen einfach großartig. Ich wollte ihm gerne einen Platz zugeben. Ich finde ihn cool.
Ich habe gerade in sein Profil bei Trazemin geguckt und gesehen, der hat übrigens 16 Spiele als Mittelschürmer gemacht und sechs Zore gemacht. Vielleicht ist das ja der Zukofsky der Zukunft.
Direkt mal, direkt mal hier Kontakt aufnehmen. Scouting-Tipps, Scouting-Tipps aus dem Rasenfunk.
Naja, und vielleicht auch Jonas Boldt nochmal mitgeben, könnte vielleicht auch sein Ergeben, Trazemin zu behalten. Bei mir ist es tatsächlich, Matthias hat ja eben einen local player genommen und deshalb habe ich mich dafür jetzt auch mal entschieden. Und zwar ist es bei mir mal Korbos geworden, der Mann ist 31 Jahre alt, also ist 23 unter älter, das kann man schon so sagen. Und es klingt immer so ein bisschen weird, dann halt doch irgendwie einen Spieler zu nehmen, der dann von weiter unten kommt und vielleicht auch nicht die auffälligste Saison gespielt hat. Aber ich finde halt einfach, ich glaube, er hat die zweitmeisten Kilometer in dieser Saison gelaufen. Du hast schon immer ein bisschen gesehen, was gefehlt hat, wenn er dann mal früher runtergenommen wurde. Er musste eben manchmal, Kniet hat ihn manchmal vorher runtergenommen als Kapitän. Aber ich finde trotzdem, dass du ihm immer angemerkt hast, dass er vorweggeht. Er hat keine, ich habe das öfter schon mal erzählt, er hat keine einfachen Startier gehabt. Er hat bis heute, glaube ich, nicht bei allen einen einfachen Stand. Und er ist aber, also das muss ich dann nochmal hervorheben, einfach weil er ist auch ein Mensch, der sich eben sehr viel mit Umweltschutz auseinander setzt, sehr, sehr viel ankurbelt im Verein, in der Liga, mit dem DFB zusammen, mit der DFL zusammen und mit seinem Unternehmen Levin Green. Und ich das einfach schon sehr beachtlich finde, weil er eben damit auch immer wieder betont, zu sagen, so ja, okay, wir haben vielleicht als Fußballspieler so und so viel Training, aber wir haben auch sehr viel Verantwortung und wir haben so und so viel Zeit und dann kannst du dich halt auch mal engagieren. Matthias, du wolltest gerne was ergänzen.
Ja, genau. Also es gibt ja diesen Ausspruch, wo es Bele, die älteren 90 Jahre lang lauft, Deutschland, 1980, Olympische Spiele oder wann? In den 80ern irgendwann. Und bei Corbis stellt sich die Frage gar nicht. Er ist immer da. Also er ist wirklich immer involviert. Das ist schon bemerkenswert, wie so ein Dua-Zellhäschen und verkörpert für mich auch so ein bisschen das, was Bielefeld einfach ausmacht, dass es sich nicht unterkriegen lässt und er geht als Kapitän voran. Also finde ich schon eine erwähnenswerte Nennung, ihn tatsächlich an der Stelle auch mal für einen Club, der jetzt nicht so herausgestochen ist in der Saison, ihn an der Stelle einfach auch unterzubekommen.
Dann liefert er halt noch acht direkte Torbeteiligungen, ne?
Ja, und er lacht ja selber ein bisschen, wer sich an dieses Tor gegen Münster erinnert, für das er ja auch für das Tor des Monats nominiert worden ist. Dieses komische Hackending und manchmal denkst du bei dem halt auch so, der steht immer fünf Meter vorm Torhüter und knallt das Ding irgendwie direkt über den Torhüter oder macht Field Goal, es ist halt auch immer so.
Er ist ja auch US-Amerikaner, es hat halt ein Blut.
Ja, genau. Und Franzose, also weiß ich jetzt nicht. Aber genau, also von daher fand ich schon irgendwie nochmal wichtig, ihn da zu erwähnen. Ich hab ihn tatsächlich, glaube ich, auch bei den Community Awards einmal gesehen, Grüße gehen raus, gesagt, ich fand das nicht ganz unwichtig, ihn hier vielleicht auch einmal zu nennen. Und ja, die Community, da muss ich jetzt, ich glaube, Edin Dzeko ist bei uns im All-Star-Team überhaupt nicht irgendwie als zweiten Liger.
Er schwebt über den Ding.
Ja, irgendwie eingekommen, weil man ihn irgendwie so, der war halt da und irgendwie passte er aber nicht so richtig in die Kategorie rein. Aber das ist es eben bei der Community, ist es Edin Dzeko geworden, gefolgt tatsächlich von Matheusz Zukowski. Also da auch nochmal die Bestätigung, dass mehrere Leute ihn da auf den Zettel hatten. Und von den besten Zweitliganewcomer kommen wir jetzt zum besten Youngster.
Ich wollte noch kurz Menschen wieder, auch da damit keine Menschen krackeeln. Und zwar müssen wir einmal ganz kurz Sofiane El-Fauzy erwähnen. Irre Saison gespielt bei Schalke, kommt vielleicht irgendwann noch vor, aber irre Saison gespielt.
In den Allstars kommt er auf jeden Fall vor.
Wenn das so ist, dann ist das definitiv verdient. Mika Bauer hat zwar letzte Saison schon irgendwie 6 Kurzeinsätze gehabt, aber für mich ist das, ehrlich gesagt, ein Zweitliga-Newcomer. Deswegen habe ich ihn trotzdem kurz hier notiert, weil der irre war. Nathan Skute von Casas Lautan. Also ohne den wäre Lautan gefühlt auf Platz 12 rausgekommen am Ende. Und ich habe auch Nicola Kartec, habe ich auch notiert. Auch der, finde ich, hat dieser Saison direkten Stempel aufgedrückt als Newcomer. Alle mal erwähnt, namentlich.
Ich muss dich leider kurz regieren. Mika Bauer ist aber 21 Jahre alt.
Ach, scheiße.
Stimmt.
Irgendwas war da. Irgendwas war da.
Also er taucht auf jeden Fall, das kann ich schon mal spoilern, bei den Youngstern, beim All-Star-Team auf. Perfekt. Dann ist es umso besser.
Umso besser. Ja, stimmt, da hab ich ihn kurz älter gemacht.
Guck mal, bei dir jetzt winkt schon, ich hab es, es tut mir leid, ich habe gespoilert. Aber, äh, das muss nicht so kurz kommen.
Dann El-Fauzi, Sküthé und Cartage genannt. So, fertig, weiter.
Sehr schön. Dann starten wir jetzt aber rein mit den besten Youngster. Und Anna, welcher Jung-Spund, Gott, furchtbarer Sorte, war bei dir am besten am Radar?
Äh, ja, ich bin Nummer 3 in Local-Playern. Ich glaube, Marc fehlt da noch, ne? 4-4 Local-Player.
Ich kann spoilern, passiert eventuell gleich.
Okay, sehr gut. Max-Marie von der Braunschweiger Eintracht. 21 Jahre alt, tolle Entwicklung. Ähm, ja, ist über Einwechslung in der vergangenen Saison zum absoluten Stammspieler groß geworden. Wirklich nicht wegzudenken aus der Braunschweiger Startelf. Mit Ausnahme tatsächlich dieses letztes Spiels auf Schalke. Da hat der Trainer allerdings erklärt, er wollte unbedingt mit der Raute spielen und hat deswegen auf Max-Marie in der Startelf verzichtet. Er kommt immerhin auf drei Tore und ein Assist, spielt meistens im defensiven Mittelfeld und profitiert, wie glaube ich, wir alle– und da schließe ich mich mit ein– von dem Trainerwechsel von einer Packhaus zu Lars Konnecker, der ihm nämlich Florian Flick, der letzten Sommer vom Club nach Braunschweig gewechselt ist. Und die beiden funktionieren einfach richtig gut zusammen. Der eine ein bisschen gröber, der eine ein bisschen feiner, spielerische Ansätze, tolle Ideen. Und der ist, glaube ich, auch noch nicht an seinem Top-Niveau angelangt. Also da zeigt die Kurve eher nach oben, als dass sie stagniert. Ich bin sehr gespannt, berüchteweise, wird er hier oder da schon gehandelt als irgendwie Kandidat für erfolgreichere Vereine, als die Braunschweiger Eintracht. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wer damit gemeint sein könnte. Allerdings mein Bauchgefühl sagt, und das paart sich natürlich mit einer gewissen Hoffnung, dass er bleibt, weil ich glaube, dass eine, noch eine Zweitliga-Saison wirklich als nicht zu diskutierender Stammspieler bei der Eintracht ihm in der Entwicklung absolut gut tun würde. Und auch dann ist er erst 22 und kann immer noch irgendwie in größere Stadien und reichere Konten und so weiter und so fort aufsteigen. Genau, Max-Marie, wirklich super Typ, sympathisch, auch in der Podcast-Folger der Braunschweiger Zeitung schon zu Gast gewesen und so. Und ja, ein Junge, auf den wir alle glaube ich sehr gerne gucken in Braunschweig.
Schöner Pick, schöner Pick.
Finde ich auch. Matthias, ich habe ja glaube ich jetzt einfach schon dein Youngster gespoilert, aber du darfst ihn natürlich trotzdem jetzt noch ein bisschen Lob hudeln.
Genau, Mika Bauer finde ich einen fantastischen Player, ganz klar das Bundesliga-Potenzial, wenn sie nicht hochgegangen wären. Für mich vermutlich ein Spieler, der die Pader Bona in die 1. Liga verlassen hätte können. Ich finde ihn unglaublich präsent im Spiel und auch gegen den Ball. Also kann nicht nur die 6er-Position begleiten, sondern auch andere offensiv ausgerichtete Mittelfeldpositionen. Ist laufstark, gutes Spielübersicht, sehr gutes Passspiel, macht die Standards. Finde ich fast schon schockverliebt. Wunderbarer Spieler, stellt sich clever an, positioniert sich auch gut im Zweikampfverhalten, stärkt in der Balleroberung. Auch mit seiner familiären Geschichte der Vater, der Kapitän der Handball-Nationalmannschaft, der auch da irgendwie Leistungssport in der Familie etabliert und er beweist auf einem anderen Feld, dass er da genauso gut sich reinfuchsen kann. Einer aus der Freiburger Schule in Dresden letztes Jahr schon ein bisschen auf sich aufmerksam gemacht bei einer Laie und jetzt, wie man es kennt, in Paderborn als junger Spieler, der Unterklassik dahin kommt, funktioniert er sehr schnell und man hat es vielleicht auch im Hinspiel in der Relegation ein bisschen gesehen, dass er da durchaus gefehlt hat, auch wenn das mit dem Unentschieden vollkommen fein war für Paderborn. Aber ich finde ihn einfach für sein Alter 21 schon einen relativ kompletten Spieler. Und er wird nicht größer werden. Ich glaube, er ist irgendwas Anfang 1,70. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen limitierend, aber nichtsdestotrotz hat auch sein U21-Debüt gefeiert in der Nationalmannschaft. Ich halte große Stücke auf ihn, wenn er schon raushört. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wo es mit ihm noch hingeht.
Ja, finde ich eine sehr gute Begründung, ein sehr guter Pick. Marc, wer ist es denn bei dir geworden?
Ich möchte unterstreichen, ich habe mich auch schockverliebt dem Mika Bauer, finde ihn irre gut. Also Wahnsinn, Wahnsinnspieler. Schockverliert trifft es aber auch bei meinem Kandidaten und da ist der Localplayer, wenn man ihn so benennen möchte, Kenneth Eichhorn. Dieses Ranking kommt nicht ohne Kenneth Eichhorn aus, würde ich sagen. Ein Spieler wirklicher historischen Ausmaßes, muss man ja klar so sagen. Mit frischen 16 Jahren unamtdingbarer Stammspieler, dabei härter geworden, wurde nur durch Sperren oder Verletzungen ausgebremst, ansonsten hätte er letztendlich jedes Spiel gemacht, gefühlt. Wir müssen uns daran erinnern, im letzten Sommer war er so jung, nämlich noch 15, dass er nicht mal die Testspiele in der Vorbereitung mitmachen durfte. So jung ist dieser Spieler, das ist absolut Wahnsinn. Er ist so irritierend weit für sein Alter, so irritierend weit in allen Belangen, in seiner Physis, in seiner Mentalität, in seiner spielerischen Klasse. Der steht seinen so vielen älteren Mitspielern und auch Gegenspielern in so vielen Dingen in nichts nach. Und das jetzt schon. Er wirkt in einigen Momenten nicht mal angestrengt. Er verzieht nie eine Mine. Er diktiert das Spiel. Er drückt Gegenspieler weg, als wären sie die jüngeren Spieler teilweise. Alle Aktionen mit einer krassen Souveränität, aber irgendwie auch nie Arroganz geprägt. Und das macht ganz, ganz großen Spaß, diesem Jungen beim Fußballspielen zuzugucken. Natürlich hat auch er noch Verbesserungspotenzial. Das wäre absurd, wenn das nicht so wäre. Natürlich gibt es Momente, wo er noch– und das hat man beispielsweise auch bei gewissen Fouls gesehen oder der roten Karte– er ist im Zweikampfverhalten manchmal noch ein bisschen ungestühmt. Das ist normal, dass da teilweise das Timing noch ein bisschen fehlt oder er gegen den Ball ein bisschen zu zackhaft. Aber er macht so viele Dinge schon so richtig. Ich finde diesen Vergleich mit Toni Kroos gar nicht so passend, weil Toni Kroos sich ja immens über das Passspiel definiert hat. Das kann Kenneth Eichhorn schon, aber ich finde, seine beste Qualität ist bislang das Ball schleppen. Also wie er den Ball bis ins letzte Drittel trägt, dann solche Tore macht wie gegen Fird, dass er sich das überhaupt traut. Wie Fird darauf reagiert, das ist das eine, aber dass der 16-jährige sich traut, in dieses Tripling zu gehen. Der Mann hat jetzt schon für verschiedenste Rekorde gesorgt, ob es der jüngste Spieler überhaupt in der 2. Liga ist, der jüngste Torschütze in der 2. Liga oder im DFB-Pokal. Der jüngste Spieler, der hier eine rote Karte gesehen hat im deutschen Profifußball, naja, zweifelhafter Rekord, aber auch den nimmt er mit. Ein Satz vielleicht dazu, weil ich das noch nirgendwo jetzt groß loswerden konnte, auf Podcast-Ebene. Ich finde die Berichterstattung rund um ihn einigermaßen ekelhaft. Kann ich einmal so klar sagen. Wir reden hier über einen 16-jährigen Jungen und wie seit Monaten ihm verschiedenste Gerüchte um die Schulter gehangen werden und sich ja jeden Tag ein großer Verein entweder zurückzieht oder angeblich in den Pokal einschaltet und was er angeblich alles fordert bezüglich Handgeld und Spielweise und Startplatzgarantie und so weiter. Das finde ich wirklich krass. Da sollten sich einige Medien stark überdenken, wie ich finde. Stefan Leitel hat zum Saison-Endspurt auch mal angemerkt auf dem PK, dass er spürt, dass das Eichhorn auch beschäftigt, diese ganze Zukunftsfrage. Er ist so talentiert, dass es diese Gerüchte um ihn geben wird. Das ist so und du kannst natürlich einmal aufschreiben, dass die halbe Welt hinter ihm her ist, um Gottes willen. Das ist auch nur realistisch, weil sonst würden diese Jungs ihren Job nicht machen. Was darüber hinaus teilweise für Implikationen gemacht werden, finde ich einigermaßen schwierig. Das hast du zum Saisonendsport an manchen Momenten im Spiel auch gemerkt. Also sei es, wie er da in Bielefeld mituntergangen ist oder ein, zwei Auftritte davor. Soll diesem Jungen aber nichts nehmen, für mich muss das der beste Youngster diese Saison sein, weil das in dem Alter einfach nicht normal ist, was wir da sehen. Das erinnert an Bellingham und Co. und ist schon außerordentlich auf der Weltbühne.
Ja, finde ich. Erstmal ein gutes Plädoyer und ich glaube, jeder, der irgendwie schon mal selber von einer Entscheidung stand, was mache ich denn, nachdem das und das weiß, dass es dann, glaube ich, noch doppelt so blöd ist, wenn allein die Familie alle zwei Minuten nachfragt, ja, was machst du denn jetzt? Dann müssen sich noch alle Medien machen, aber Matthias, gerne.
Ja, er war ja nach allem, was man hört, auch letztes Jahr schon im Schaufenster gestanden. Also mit 15 wollten ihn auch schon ganz andere Clubs verpflichten und da konnte sich er wohl noch mit ihm einigen und mit seinem Berater, dass man, glaube ich, eine Klausel reinsetzt in den Vertrag ab dann und dann darf er wechseln. Das heißt, er hat ohnehin schon viel Vorschusslorbeeren gehabt und hat sie vollauf bestätigt. Also das ist ja auch beeindruckend, dass man das in so einem Alter zu so einem präsenten und prägnanten Spieler in einem ausgewachsenen Profiklub hinbekommt. Also da kann man schon einige Hüte ziehen.
Ja, ja.
Auf jeden Fall.
Eva, du musst noch dein Langstil loswerden, ne?
Ja genau, ich wollte abwarten, bevor du hier wieder noch mit drei anderen Kandidaten um die Ecke kommst. Bei mir ist tatsächlich Mohamed Ali Soma geworden. Vom 1. FC Nürnberg, weil ich auch finde, er ist jetzt noch 22. Aber immer, wenn ich ihn am Spielen sehe, dann dachte ich so, okay, krass. Und wieder mal ein Talent, was vielleicht so ein bisschen unterm Radar fliegt, auch weil Nürnberg halt einfach so eine, ich darf jetzt mal einfach nicht sagen, eine Saison am Ende des Tages gespielt hat. Deshalb ist er ein bisschen untergegangen. Aber auch bei ihm, also echt gute Statistik, 14 Tore, vier Assists in dieser Saison. Es war auch noch seine erste Zweitligasaison. Und man muss ja schon sagen, das ist ja das, wo von Nürnberg einfach kennt, dass sie ja schon so Spieler sehr schnell auf ein hohes Niveau bringen können. Und ich finde einfach, dass er, also ich habe vor allem ehrlich gesagt, dieses Spiel, ich glaube, ging Hannover in einer Hinrunde war das, glaube ich, wo man, wo er eben auch dieser kreative Einzelpart war und der sicherlich ja auch dafür gesorgt hat, dass einfach da ja bestimmte Spiele auch gewonnen wurden und dass es für Nürnberg am Ende dann um nichts mehr ging. Relativ schnell und ich finde einfach, ja, ich fand irgendwie, er hat das auf jeden Fall auch verdient, da noch drin zu landen, auch gerade weil vielleicht Nürnberg sonst ein Team ist, was wir vielleicht nicht mehr so wahnsinnig oft hier hören werden, aber genau, deshalb kurz und schmerzlos ist es bei mir Mohamed Ali Soma geworden.
Schöner Pick, sehr verdient. Das schon.
Hast du deine Honour bemerkt?
Natürlich, natürlich. Auch da, wie gesagt, auch um ein bisschen vorzubauen, dass da Leute nicht sagen, warum nicht der? Sollen alle hier ihre Aufmerksamkeit bekommen. Auch da nur die Namen genannt, Dennis Simon, Louis Ben Fahad, Noel Aseco und Kajetan Lenz hätten es auch alle verdient gehabt.
Jo, auf jeden Fall. Ich kann sagen, ich glaube, Dennis Simon ist auf jeden Fall auch im All-Star-Pick mit drin.
Ich meine, Noel Aseco wird zugetraut jetzt. Das ist ja das neueste Gerücht und kenntet euch noch, wenn man sich da zurückzieht, weil man Noel Aseco zutraut, in den kommenden Saison bei den Bayern schon eine Rolle zu spielen. Ich würde es verdient finden, und das spricht ja auch nochmal für seine irre Entwicklung. Übrigens auch Hertha Youngster, also auch aus der Hertha-Jugend.
Das musst du nochmal erwähnen werden, ne?
Klar, klar. Louis-Ben Fahad hat auch eine ganz tolle Saison gespielt. Spielt jetzt bei der WM einfach, bei Tunesien. Das ist auch eine irre Entwicklung. Und Kajetan Lenzweig selbst, für knapp 10 Millionen Euro zu hoffen, einem auch das unterstreicht, was für ein Riesentalent das ist.
Aber Louis-Ben Fahad wirklich im Kader. Ich dachte, er wäre nicht schlussendlich aufgesprungen. Was mich ein bisschen überrascht hat, klären wir noch.
Ich finde das raus.
Finde du das mal raus?
Top-Talent sagt wer immer, warum Louis-Ben Fahad überraschend auf die Regeneration setzt. Guck mal. Gut.
Fact-Check. War man das wenigstens noch live?
Aber er hat gesagt, er hätte sie mitgenommen. So.
So. Der Punkt bleibt bestehen. Wir kommen jetzt zu einer Kategorie, die ich sehr, sehr schön fand, ehrlich gesagt. Shout-out gehen raus an Marc, der sich die ausgedacht hat, glaube ich. Und zwar mehr Liebe für. Und es ist erstmal sehr witzig, weil ich glaube, wir hatten uns eher, bzw. Initiativ war deine Idee, wirklich zu sagen, mehr Liebe für Spieler, die vielleicht ein bisschen unterm Radar fliegen, so ein bisschen, was man sonst in der Bundesliga der Männer an Sangiro nennt. Was ich aber sehr schön fand, dass sowohl wir im Eulzerteam, als auch in der Community das sehr schnell, sehr weit gefasst haben. Und eigentlich fand ich es, also, ich muss direkt einmal eine On-Ramp-Mention vornherein schicken. Und es hat mich sehr überrascht, dass diese, dieses mehr Liebe für, nicht von Anna kam, sondern von Thorsten. Und zwar, dass es die mehr Liebe für Lauterer Weißweinschorne gibt. Insider wissen Bescheid.
Das ist richtig.
Also wir hatten hier sehr große Diskussionen schon über die unterschiedlichen Weinschorlen in der 2. Liga. Und ich glaube, in unserem Ranking hat der 1. Kaiserslautern dieses gewonnen. Shout-out geht raus. Aber wir wollen jetzt wirklich zu viel mehr Liebe kommen. Und dann will ich einfach sagen, Marc, fang du doch mal direkt an.
Ja, ich habe es auch dann weitergefasst. Ich habe es erst auf Spielerebene gedacht und bin so ein bisschen durchgegangen. Und am Ende bin ich bei einem Trainer gelandet. Und du hattest eben gesagt, Eva, dass wir nicht mehr so viel über den 1. FC Nürnberg reden werden. An dieser Stelle werden wir es doch nochmal tun. Denn ich sage mehr Liebe für Miroslav Klose. Ich finde, dass zu wenig darauf geschaut wird, was der Mann da eigentlich leistet. Und im Zweifel wird eher negativ auf ihn geguckt. Ich bin mir bis heute nicht so ganz sicher, wie gut Miroslav Klose als Trainer ist. Das sei gesagt. Aber für mich ist er in der Regel Opfer der Umstände in Nürnberg, wenn man das so negativ frame möchte. Er schafft es jetzt seit zwei Jahren, einen stets nervösen Verein sehr souverän zu moderieren. Das haben wir auch schon bei Kettemann und Muslisch und Co. gelobt. Auch das gilt bei Nürnberg, wie ich finde. Also macht das sehr ruhig. Trotzdem ist er aber auch bestimmt in seiner Art. Aber für mich ist das Ding. Jedes Jahr betreibt Nürnberg sehr große Kade-Experimente. Da wird gefühlt jedes Jahr die komplette Achse rausgerissen. Jedes Jahr werden ihm dann neue, sehr junge Spieler hingestellt, die entweder keine Profi-Erfahrung haben oder keine Deutschland-Erfahrung. Und er muss aus diesem Gewühl an Spielern, die teilweise auch sehr spät kommen, wie jetzt im vergangenen Sommer, dann wieder etwas bauen, was möglichst in der Klasse bleibt und vielleicht sogar Ausblick auf mehr hat. Und ich finde, das ist sehr, sehr, sehr undankbar. Ja, darauf hat er sich eingelassen, das macht es aber nicht undankbarer an der Stelle. Auch in dem vergangenen Sommer ist wieder viel passiert. Da sind dann die Caspar Jandas dieser Welt gegangen und das alles ist sehr spät passiert. Wenn man sich auf den letzten Sommer guckt, hat er viele Leistungsträger verloren. Es gab viele Spätetransfers, viele Neue, die keine Zweitliga-Erfahrung hatten, viele Leihspieler, kein Mittelstürmer mit genügend Zweitliga-Qualität. Das vergisst man auch gerne mal. Die haben am Ende notdürftig Grimaldi verpflichtet. Das hat eigentlich alles ausgesagt. Der Saisonstart durfte dann eigentlich nicht überraschen. Der lief ja nicht gut in der Saison. Aber ich habe da schon Struktur im Spiel erkannt. So Dinge wie keine Griffigkeit, keine identifische Cleverness, keine Kalt-Schneidigkeit sind ja Symptome einer jungen Mannschaft, die sich noch finden muss. Damals hing ja auch seine Vertragsverlängerung an dieser Phase dran. Da hat man sich rausgekämpft, er hat den Vertrag verlängert. Man muss gucken, der spielt mit dem jüngsten Kader der Liga. Und wenn ich jetzt nur mal das Positive aufzähle, der moderiert diesen sehr nervösen Club sehr ruhig. Er bleibt bei sich, er integriert bei einer zahllosen Talente ohne Profi der Deutschland-Erfahrung. Er schafft Marktwerte und hält Nürnberg jetzt das zweite Mal in Folge zu 90 Prozent aus dem Abstiegskampf raus. Viel mehr kann man nicht wollen. Die haben 24, 25 laut Transfermarkt einen Transferplus von 30 Millionen Euro erzielt. 25, 26 knapp 11 Millionen Euro. Diese Saison werden es durch– du hast ihn schon gelobt– Eva Sommer wahrscheinlich erneut Millionen. Und es wird wieder dasselbe Experiment wahrscheinlich im Sommer. Viel mehr kannst du von einem Trainer in der Situation nicht haben wollen. Und deswegen finde ich, dass Virus auf Closen mehr Liebe verdient hat.
Ich kann schon mal spoilern, das sieht die Community ähnlich. Also logischerweise war es bei diesem Award etwas schwieriger, so eine wirklich Rangfolge zu bilden. Aber ich kann sagen, Miro Klose hat das dann doch irgendwie mit den meisten Vengeance gewonnen, was relativ schwierig war. Von daher, ja, Liebe geht raus an der Stelle. Mehr Liebe für Miroslav Klose. Matthias, für wen hast du denn mehr Liebe übrig?
Das finde ich tatsächlich eine gute Wahl, weil er wirkt auch doch immer wieder angegriffen, so ein bisschen, wenn man ihn nach Spielschluss sieht oder wenn es irgendwie einen Treffer oder einen Gegentreffer gibt, dann denkt man sich, oh, das geht ihm echt an die Nieren. Aber dann doch zwei Jahre lang hier Stahlbad auszuhalten, à la Bonheur. Ich habe mich für Christian Eichner entschieden. Also ihm wurde ja durchaus übel mitgespielt. Er hat auch Werte geschaffen. Du hast sie gerade für Nürnberg aufgezählt. Er hat es auch immer wieder verstanden, Youngster einzubauen. Max Weiss ging nach England. Kieper vielleicht in eine andere Position, wo man als Trainer doch durchaus auch dem Torwart-Trainer folgt. Aber auch Tim Breithaupt, jetzt David Herold, Ben Fahd, Pinto Petrosa. Das heißt, er bekommt per se jetzt nie wirklich Spitzenkader hingestellt, sondern muss aus dem, was er bekommt, das Beste machen. Das hat er jetzt über sechs Jahre hinweg gemacht. Er war sozusagen das Urgestein auf der Trainerbank in der 2. Liga. Dann wird ihm der Co-Trainer und Vertraute Zlatan Baramovic genommen. Er trägt historisch fast schon bis zur Selbstaufgabe, finde ich. Er hat da alles mehr oder minder mit sich machen lassen. Er wird dann selbst vor die Tür gesetzt und ist dann auch kommunikativ immer noch so klar. Tritt nicht nach, weiß um das Konstrukt KSC und ist dem Verein sehr verbunden. Er hat aber auch zu verstehen gegeben, es geht ihm schon auch sehr an die Nieren selbst wiederum, dass ihm jetzt die Entlassungspapiere in die Hand gedrückt wurden. Ich finde, man hat keinen Abnutzungseffekt wirklich angespürt. Die Frage ist, wo will der KSC hin? Mit der Politik muss man erst mal einen Trainer finden, der das auf ein anderes Level hebt oder nicht den Rückwärtsgang plötzlich einschlägt. Deshalb finde ich, wäre das durchaus ehrenwert, ihn an der Stelle zu sagen, You've come a long way, Christian. Du hast das Beste er tragen und daraus gemacht. Ich weiß von einem KSC-Fan, dass nicht alle Fans ihm durchweg Tränen nachweiden, aber sehr, sehr viele. Ich denke, er ist das Gesicht des KSC. Man hat ihn mutwillig jetzt vor die Tür gesetzt. Da bin ich gespannt, wo es mit dem Klub hingeht. Props an Christian Eichner.
Ich finde es sehr, sehr schön, dass er hier noch mal einfach Erwähnung findet. Ja, weil er– ich auch einfach das Gefühl hätte– es war für ihn dann einfach nicht leicht. Er wollte es dann trotzdem aber für alle drum herum, für die Fans vor allem auch. Er wollte das schon irgendwie zu Ende bringen und da irgendwie sein Gesicht warnen und dann dem Verein auch irgendwie den Respekt geben, den er meiner Meinung nach dann eben hinten raus nicht mehr erhalten hat von bestimmten Offiziellen. Von daher sehr, sehr guter Pick. Anna, wer ist es denn bei dir geworden?
Jetzt muss ich ein bisschen hier improvisieren. Das ist ein bisschen wie– ah ja, der Lehrer hat ja gesagt, heute kommt Stochastik und ich habe es einfach vergessen. Ich habe es einfach falsch verstanden.
Ne, du kannst es nicht falsch verstehen.
Ich kann es einfach– okay, also, dann hole ich kurz aus, weil jetzt, wo mir klar ist, dass wir eigentlich über Personen hätten sprechen sollen, kam ja als erstes auch Christian Eichler in den Sinn. Dann dachte ich, okay, ich könnte auch über Fabio Kaufmann sprechen, der wesentlich zum Klassenerhalt der Braunschweiger Eintracht beigetragen hat. Wenn ich jetzt eine Person nennen möchte als treue Braunschweiger Seele, dann möchte ich hier Thorsten Lieberknecht nennen, der einfach ein super Typ ist. Und, ja, genau, einfach unabhängig davon, ich will die Saison in Kaiserslautern, deren Ansprüche und woher die kommen, aus Marlon Ritter gewachsen. Ich weiß es nicht, kann ich nicht bewerten, will ich hier nicht bewerten. Aber Thorsten Lieberknecht ist ein super stabiler Typ, der politisch in einer Richtung zu verorten ist, in der es öffentlich in der Welt des Fußballs sicherlich die eine oder offizielle Person mehr bräuchte. Deswegen, wenn ich hier einen Namen nennen soll, dann ist es Thorsten Lieberknecht. Wenn ich sagen soll, was ich eingetragen habe, dann ist es– und jetzt werde ich ein bisschen fachfremd, aber ich möchte es trotzdem sagen– und zwar der Kampf, der Fans und Ultras in Fürth um ihren originären Vereinsnamen.
Toller, schöner Pick. Aufgabe verstanden.
Also, es ist tatsächlich etwas, was ich nicht wüsste, wenn ich nicht Teil dieser schon oft zitierten WhatsApp-Gruppe wäre. Und ich möchte das kurz, was ich hier recherchieren konnte, zusammentragen, um diejenigen, die so wenig im Bilde sind wie ich es war, dazu abzuholen, denn die heutige Spielvereinigung Kräuterfurt, das ist zurückzuführen auf die Fusion von zwei Vereinen Mitte der 90er Jahre, 1996, und zwar zwischen dem TSV Festenbergs Kreut, das kann man als Franke wahrscheinlich eleganter aussprechen, und der Spielvereinigung Fürth. Und dieses Kräuter aus Festenbergs Kreut, das ist lange schon ein Bestreben, wieder loszuwerden und auch zurückzukehren zum traditionellen Logo, die Initiative heißt Zurück zur Spielvereinigung Fürth. Und da stecken viele Personen sehr viel Konzentration und sehr viel Engagement rein. Und der Plan ist, ganz konkret für 2026, hier wieder zurückzukommen, dafür braucht es eine Mehrheit bei der Jahreshauptversammlung, und zwar über 90%, was ein bisschen schwierig ist, weil juristische Personen der TSV Festmax kreu 20% der Stimmanteile anhaben. Allerdings ist es so, dass seit dem 1. Juli 2025 Fans die passive Mitgliedschaft für 80 Euro pro Jahr erwerben können. Und dann haben sie nach einem Jahr das Recht zur Abstimmung bei der Jahreshauptversammlung. Und wenn der Plan so aufgeht, dann könnte im Herbst 2026, und zwar zum Vereinsgeburtstag, tatsächlich der Weg zurückgehen zur originären Spielvereinigung Fürth. Und dafür wünsche ich an dieser Stelle sehr viel Liebe und viel Erfolg.
Matthias, du dahst sofort. Eine Sache wollte ich noch kurz ergänzen, weil mir das dann tatsächlich immer sauer aufstößt, wenn selbsternannte Fußballromantiker, die auch Kommentatoren sind oder so, dann wirklich immer Gräuter führt sagen. Und ich finde, das ist irgendwie eine Sache von Respekt, dann auch irgendwie zu schauen, dass einem zwischendurch mal ein Gräuter rausrutscht. Überhaupt gar kein Problem. Bitte nicht falsch verstehen. Ist mir sicherlich auch schon passiert. Aber ich finde schon, das dann zum Teil auch ins Lächerliche zu ziehen, finde ich einfach daneben. Nur weil es vielleicht ein etwas kleinerer Verein ist, der national nicht so viel Stahlkraft hat, finde ich das trotzdem wichtig. Und man hat ja auch gesehen, man verzeihe mir bitte den Vergleich, aber wie viel zum Beispiel beim VfL Wolfsburg es den Fans bedeutet hat, dass man da zurück zum Zinnwappen zurückgekehrt ist. Und manchmal ist es tatsächlich gar nicht so schwer, auch als Verein, Fans irgendwie das Symbol zu geben, hey, ihr werdet ernst genommen. Und wir checken das schon irgendwie. Und in diesem super kommenzialisierten Fußball kann es manchmal doch einfach wichtig sein, bei sowas wieder irgendwie auf die Fans zu hören, auf sie einen Schritt zuzugehen. Weil gerade dem, was führt, eben auch bevorsteht, wenn man so ein bisschen geguckt hat, was nach dem Viertessenspiel eben auch für Plakate direkt hing, dass es schon wichtig ist, vielleicht durch sowas eine gemeinsame Basis zu bilden, um so in die nächste Saison zu starten. Aber Matthias, ich glaube, du wolltest noch was zu Thorsten Lieberknecht sagen.
Korrekt. Anna und ich verbinden ja quasi Thorsten Lieberknecht, weil er ein und so weiter Klubs Spieleiter war oder Trainings-Trainer. Und ich finde, wenn man mit ihm spricht, er ist wirklich ein Mensch. Er ist jetzt keiner, der sich für was Besseres hält. Er begegnet einem auf Augenhöhe und er verschreibt sich seinen Aufgaben mit Haut und Haaren. Und ich glaube, deshalb wirkt er auch oft ein bisschen unsouverän und polarisiert auch sehr. Aber ich glaube, er ist gerade bei so Niederlagen einfach zum einen selbst extrem enttäuscht und er weiß, dass er wiederum die Fanszene enttäuscht. Und das macht mit ihm sehr viel. Also er ist jemand, der um die Bedeutung des Trainer-Jobs und um die Bedeutung eines Trainers in Vereinen mit Tausenden von Fans weiß und deshalb so auftritt, wie er auftritt. Und ich kann ihn, glaube ich, spüren, wenn er so wirkt vor der Kamera, wie er manchmal eben wirkt und dass das vielen eher in sozialen Medien dann bitter aufstößt, wenn sie ihn sehen und schon nicht mehr sehen können. Aber ich finde, er ist wirklich einer, der jedem, dem er begegnet, mit erstmal einem offenen Mindset begegnet und ihn auch für voll nimmt und nicht irgendwie sagt, hier, ich bin der Coach, was willst du? Du weißt ja eh überhaupt nicht, wie es bei uns hier im Inner Circle abläuft. Und deshalb finde ich, kann man lieber Knecht schon auch gut finden, selbst wenn ihn manche eher anstrengend finden, aber ich finde, wenn man mal die Gelegenheit bekommt, sich mit ihm zu unterhalten und er ist jemand, der auch auf der Straße stehen bleibt und sich mit einem unterhält, dann ist es schon augenöffnend und sehr, sehr gut, auch so eine Person, die, wie du auch Anna sagst, politisch durchaus stabil ist, in so einer Situation, in so einer Position weiß. Und um das abzubinden bei MehrLiebeFür, hätte ich auch noch einen Pick, aber ich lasse jetzt erstmal dich, Eva Maria, da was sagen. Eva Lotzer. Eva Maria, mein Gott.
Ist okay.
Eva Lotzer.
Ist okay. Nö, nö, alles gut.
Dann würde ich den Abbilder zum Schluss machen.
Ja, na klar, sehr gerne. Bei mir sind es tatsächlich dann auch, weil ich hatte dann auch überlegt und dachte, hm, irgendwie ist es dann doch schöner, eben auch auf das große Ganze zu gucken. Und da muss ich einfach sagen, MehrLiebe für Zweitliga-Fans. Also ich glaube, sie bekommen schon viel lieber ab, aber trotzdem, wir hatten einen Zuschauerschnitt von 30.911 in dieser Saison, 30.911. Über 9,4 Millionen Menschen sind in dieser Zweitligasaison ins Stadion gekommen. Und als eine Person, die tatsächlich mit Pokalspielen und Co. 34 von 36 Spielen live im Stadion gesehen hat, kann man schon sagen, es sind manchmal wirklich schlimme Fahrten dabei. Und wenn du dann Freitag abends nach Karlsruhe fährst und dann nach den 90 Minuten denkst, ach so, ja, perfekt und jetzt noch mal 4 Stunden zurück und du bist hier wie Morgens gefühlt um halb zwei zu Hause, dann ist es schon manchmal ein bisschen anstrengend. Aber ich möchte einfach wirklich für jeden einzelnen Fan, der egal in welcher Phase, egal wo sein Verein steht, ins Stadion geht, die Möglichkeiten dafür hat, auch bei den zum Teil wirklich absurden Ticketpreisen, die es gibt, die das jede Woche machen, einfach größter Respekt durch euch lebt, einfach Fan-Kultur in der 2. Liga. Und ihr seid, glaub ich, ihr seid für mich auch der Grund, warum ich mir zum Teil sehr, sehr viel lieber mal ein Zweitligaspiel angucke als ein Bundesligaspiel. Weil ich einfach– es klingt so sehr pathetisch, aber ich finde manchmal schon, du merkst eben, dass die 2. Liga einfach zum Teil noch mit anderen Vereinen besetzt ist. Und ja, für mich hat es einfach jeder verdient. Ach so, ich habe einfach die falsche Statistik offen. Perfekt, das ist einfach die falsche Saison. Ich korrigiere jetzt gerade nochmal. Es waren im Durchschnitt 28.000 ZuschauerInnen und 8,7 Millionen. Aber ganz ehrlich, das macht den Kohl jetzt auch nicht mehr fett. Das ist immer noch eine sehr hohe Zahl. Ich habe mich kurz gewundert, warum da Köln auf einmal drin stand. Also, Fact Check Live ist auch wieder am Start. Aber trotzdem, viel Liebe für Zweitliga-Fans. Ich freue mich auf die nächste Saison mit euch. Aber, Matthias, der hat jetzt noch eine Runde.
Genau, ich stimme da auch mit ein, obwohl ich es nicht auf dem Zettel hatte. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, die 2. Liga ist einfach eine Wettbewerbsliga. Man hat Aufsteiger, die sich in der Liga halten können. Man hat Absteiger von oben, die nicht per se wieder vorne mitschwimmen, sondern eher gucken müssen, dass sie die Bremse reinhauen. Also, das ist einfach ein guter Wettbewerb, vorne wie hinten. Das ist zwar nervenstrapazierend, aber es ist einfach ein Wettbewerb. Und das ist alabaneur. Und ich wollte noch Patrick Errers erwähnen. Jeden Spieler, der gar nicht gespielt hat in der vergangenen Saison, der jetzt seine Karriere beenden musste aufgrund einer Kopfverletzung oder mehreren Kopfverletzungen, die er litten hat. Und das muss ja für einen Profi, der sich über eine Funktionsfähigkeit seines Körpers definiert, enorm schwer sein, mit einer Kopfverletzung seine Karriere beenden zu müssen, wenn er offenbar seit mehreren Monaten bis anderthalb Jahren nicht weiß, wie vielleicht auch der Alltag zu bewältigen ist. Weil wir kennen es von Erzählungen von Eishockey-Profis, die Gehirnerschütterungen hatten und dann über Jahre hinweg mit Kopfschnazzen und Gleichgewichtsschörungen zu tun hatten. Auch Hübner, der Co-von der Nationalmannschaft, müsste mit Kopfverletzung seine Karriere, meine ich, beenden.
Diego Demme hatte das jetzt auch über ein Jahr bei Hertha.
Genau, konnte, hatte ich mir auch notiert, nur zwei Partien über die Vollradisanz bestreiten in der zurückliegenden Saison. Also ich glaube gerade für einen Leistungssportler ist so etwas enorm schwer, wenn er nicht an einer Muskelverletzung oder so laboriert, sondern der Kopf einfach der Wunde Punkt ist. Und sich das eingestehen zu müssen und erst mal nicht zu wissen, wie kann ich das beheben, stelle ich mir sehr, sehr schwer vor. Und deshalb wollte ich sagen, auch mehr Liebe für jemanden, der sein Liebstes einfach aufgeben muss. Und jetzt wahrscheinlich erst mal gucken muss, wo er dann bleibt.
Finde ich sehr, sehr gut. Sehr, sehr gute Erwähnung generell natürlich. Auch noch mal der Hinweis, dass Kopfverletzungen im Sport, vor allem im Fußball, vielleicht auch immer noch nicht die Aufmerksamkeit bekommen. Und die, ich sag mal, medizinische Aufmerksamkeit auch bekommen, die sie bekommen sollten, haben wir auch in dieser Saison an unterschiedlichen Stellen einfach gesehen, um hier einmal den Max ein bisschen reinzubringen. Aber wir haben noch eine letzte Kategorie in unserer Community-All-Star-Awards-Kategorie. Und natürlich wollten wir noch wissen, was war denn das beste Spiel? Und Anna, ich fange einfach mal mit dir an. Was war für dich das beste Spiel in dieser Saison?
Vereinsbrille abgesetzt, weil da war kein Spiel toll.
Ich fand euer Spiel gegen Dresden schon gut. Ich hab das in der Podcast-Folge viel gelobt.
Ja, ich hab die Folge gehört. Nichtsdestotrotz, also was mich einfach... Also dieser Spieltag war ja absurd. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht sagt Matthias quasi den entgegengesetzten Dominostein eures Spiels an diesem Spieltag. Denn mein Pick hier ist auf jeden Fall der Schalke-Auswärtssieg in Paderborn. Das war einfach absolut absurd. Die liegen 3 zu 0 zurück und du denkst, alles klar. Also wenn hier jemand einen Deckel drauf macht, dann ist es Paderborn. Und dann kommt Schalke und reißt das Ding einfach so was von nochmal rum. Dann steht es lang ja 3-3 und du denkst, ja okay, eigentlich ist es auch in Ordnung, fair. Und dann ja, doch nicht, Auswärtssieg. Und da war einfach, also eigentlich war es ja eh klar, das weiß ich nicht, ich kenne niemanden, der so ernsthaft, ernsthaft daran gezweifelt hat, dass Schalke das diese Saison schafft. Aber es gab dann, fand ich, wirklich so eine Saisonphase, auch deren Spiel gegen Elbersberg, hatte ich vorhin schon erwähnt, bei der dir einfach klar war, da schmuckt dir auch kein Statistik-Häschen noch in die Suche, dass irgendeine Ausnahme aus dem Hut zaubert. Die ziehen jetzt durch und das war wirklich phänomenal. Es war ein fantastisches Spiel, ein tolles Fußballspiel, ja, genau, ja, Punkt.
Ich glaube, es war so gut, dass du sogar zwei Tore zu viel dazu gedichtet hast. Ist das so? Es ging 2 zu 3 aus.
Es ging 2 zu 3 aus?
Aber der Spielverlauf war so, wie du sagtest.
Okay, ja, cool.
Also Pardobon führt und dann kommt vor der Pause Schalke zurück und zum Schluss machen sie den Deckel drauf.
Dann hattet ihr das 3-3, ne? Hattet ihr 3-3 gespielt an dem Spieltag oder war das auch ein 2-2?
Das kann sein, dass das 3-3 war, das vielleicht nochmal erwähnt wird.
Ja, okay.
Ja, genau, ich würde grad sagen.
Okay, alles klar.
Das kommt jetzt vielleicht nochmal rein.
Dann schluck ich an der Stelle. Okay, dann ist es ein 2-3, lange 2-2 und dann fällt das 3. Ich hab's nicht nochmal nachgeguckt.
Es war eine lange Saison.
Und macht das Drama auch nicht kleiner. Ich fand das Spiel auch ganz gut.
Der Punkt ist klar, denke ich.
Matthias, dann mach doch gerne direkt weiter.
Genau, es ist tatsächlich dasselbe Spieltag. 2 zu 3, Darmstadt gegen Elbersberg. Darmstadt hatte sich schon vor dem Spiel so ein bisschen aus dem Aufstiegsrennen verabschiedet. Hätte den letzten Strohhelm noch ergreifen können. Und ich hab das Spiel gewählt, weil ich selbst im Stadion war. Und bei dem Spiel mal so richtig wieder was gefühlt hab. Also es war, ich hab mit meinen Kids da, die haben auch ohne Sonne danach gesagt, was ein Spiel. Und es hatte einfach alles. Es war ausverkauft. Es war Flutlichtspiel. Zwei Spitzenteams für Doppelschlag für Darmstadt. Dann kommt Elbersberg vor der Pause noch zurück. Er zieht mit dem Pausenpfiff das 3 zu 2. Vorangegangen war ein Platzverweis. Der eingewechselte Spieler lenkt den Ball unhaltbar ins Tor ab. Also auch eher, wo ist das Karma? Und dann feiten sie sich aber in Unterzahl zurück, lassen Elbersberg nicht mehr so ins Spiel kommen. Und das muss man gegen Elbersberg ja auch erst mal schaffen. Wenn die so das Momentum haben, dann wird es schwer. Also das war das engste Band, das man sich zwischen Team und Fans vorstellen kann. In einer vergleichbaren Situation kriegt Elbersberg keinen Platz verweist. Das hat das Stadion nochmal angezündet. Also es war im Endeffekt, wenn man im Stadion ist und so ein Spiel miterlebt, dann ist es schon wirklich fantastisch. Und klar, der Aufstiegszug war abgefahren, aber das war auf den letzten Drucker doch nochmal so ein Spiel, das die Fans versöhnt hat, weil es gezeigt hat, wenn es hart auf hart kommt, dann packen sie auch nicht nur das Spielerische aus, sondern auch das Emotionale und haben sich da gegen einen, wie man jetzt auch an der Tabellenplatzierung absehen kann, starkes Elves-Werk behauptet. Und dass dann Hornby auch noch verletzt raus muss, seinen letzten Minuten für die, die ihn absolviert hat, ist ein bisschen bittersweet, aber das war ein Spiel, das schon mitreißen konnte.
Sehr schön. Marc, ich lese dir kurz ein Zitat vor oder paraphrasiere es aus der Community-Umfrage. Also eine Person schrieb auf jeden Fall keins mit härter Beteiligung.
Wow.
Also, ist es mein Spiel mit härter Beteiligung?
Autsch.
Also ich habe auch keins mit härter Beteiligung genommen. Also ich kann jetzt nicht den direkten Gegenweis liefern. Also je nachdem, wie man die Zweitliga-Saison definiert, dieses 6 zu 1 im Pokal gegen Karlsruhe, dann war ja quasi auch ein Zweitliga-Duell. Das hätte man nehmen können.
Das war tatsächlich drin, ja.
Dementsprechend, wie man es denn so begreift. Ja, also viele härter Spiele waren zum vergessen, aber es gab auch ein paar, die waren ganz okay. Ja, ich kann ja meinen Tipp jetzt mal nehmen oder meine Wahl. Thorsten, hör bitte weg, ich habe das Fürth-Düsseldorf-Spiel genommen. Weil ich mich schwer getan habe, das fußballerisch-taktisch beste Spiel auszuwählen. Deswegen habe ich das genommen, weil das für mich einfach die größte Geschichte geschrieben hat. Und das war das. Das war dramatisch auf dem Höhepunkt. Das ging nicht krasser. Also, dass die beiden überhaupt am Ende so aufeinandertreffen, ist ja schon verrückt. Und wie es dann auch verlaufen ist, Düsseldorf hätte letztendlich einen Punkt zu direkten Klassenhalt gereicht. Die hätten selbst ein Gegentor weniger und sie wären immerhin in die Relegation gekommen. Und Fürth gewinnt das einfach 3 zu 0. Wie gesagt, ist dieses eine Tor davon entfernt, dass sie sogar den direkten Nichtabstieg feiern zu können. Dann gab es diese Gerüchte, dass sie gar nicht wussten, dass sie 4 zu 0 gewinnen sollten. Das ist auch geil. Dementsprechend muss ich wirklich sagen, das ist für natürlich vor allen Dingen Unbeteiligte ein besonders cooles Spiel. Deswegen habe ich es einfach genommen. Ich glaube, vielmehr muss ich diesem Spiel, alle, die es in irgendeiner Weise verfolgt haben, dem muss ich das gar nicht weiter erklären. Diese Tragweite, diese Dramatik, dass Fird dann tatsächlich zugepackt hat, dass Düsseldorf dieses Momentum aus dem Sieg davor ja gegen Eversberg aus der Hand gegeben hat und so. Das sind solche Geschichten, die schreibt wirklich nur der Fußball und ausschließlich der Fußball. Keine andere Sportart, selbstverständlich. Ich habe mich für Fird Düsseldorf entschieden. Völlig verrücktes Ding. Sowohl in der Ansetzung, als auch dann, wie es sich ausgespielt hat. Das ist Fußball.
Ja, ich habe mich für ein Spiel entschieden, da kommt nämlich doch noch die Hertha-Beteiligung rein. Marc, hör du jetzt bitte weg.
Welches Spiel könnte das wohl sein?
Es muss das Spiel vom letzten Spieltag, Bielefeld, Hertha 6 zu 1 sein.
So fair. Joel Grudowski, du mieses Schwein.
Ich muss hier hinten so einen Explicit hinzufügen.
Der hat ja selbst Lichtgefühl nochmal angezündet, der Mann. Auch wenn man über seine Tattoo-Wahl reden kann. Die habe ich dann ja in vollster Güte einmal gesehen, als er ihm das Trikot ausgefungen hat. Interessante Wahl teilweise, aber ja.
Ja, auf jeden Fall einfach, weil ich muss über den, ich brauche jetzt dieses Spiel nicht zu sensieren, aber ich hatte hier ja im Podcast gesagt, so nach diesem 2 zu 0 gegen Kaiserslautern oder 0 zu 2 besser gesagt, ich war kurz emotional am Abgrund. Ja, ich dachte perfekt. Also weil alle auch immer meine Augen kommen gegen Kaiserslautern und Hertha, das wird doch was. Und es gab ja vorher einen Fan-Marsch. Und du hast einfach, ne, bis es dann losging, dann trafst du dich in der Stadt und alle so ja, und wie ist so deine Laune? Und ich so, schlecht, mir geht es auch gar nicht gut. Und so zog sich quasi einmal durch. Und dann aber halt wirklich mit diesem, du konntest allein beim Fan-Marsch, sondern irgendwie merken so, wir channeln jetzt irgendwie alles aus der letzten Saison. Wir nehmen eben, weil die letzten beiden Fan-Marsche waren eben vor dem Pokalspiel gegen Leverkusen und vor dem Eröffnungsspiel gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf. Du hast da eben noch mal das, was ich auch in der Folge angesprochen habe, dieses Zusammenhalt triumphiert und wir packen das jetzt alle zusammen. Und dann fuhr der Bus quasi durch das komplette Spalier, die Startmaustraße bei uns lang und wurde da von Pyro und Co. begleitet und eben von Tausenden von Fans. Und dann gingst du in dieses Spiel rein und hast Chance nach Chance und denkst so, um Gottes Willen, du machst das Tor nicht, jetzt macht Hertha gleich das Tor. Und dann macht Hertha das Tor. Aber irgendwie war ich so weirdly ruhig in der Halbzeit, weil ich dachte, nee, die packen das. Ich weiß nicht wie, aber die packen das. Und ich habe gesagt, also eine Freundin von mir meinte, es fallen alle Tore an der Nordtribüne heute. Und da meinte ich so, aus Spaß. Ja, in der zweiten Halbzeit jetzt halt einfach noch sechs Stück.
Und in Vier noch sechs Stück. Also es tut mir leid.
Aber ja, auch einfach die Anzahl, dass du eben noch mal die verschiedenen Torschützen hast, mit Grudovski, mit Mumulu, mit Russo, dass Telalovic auch nochmal durfte und hinten dann Ole Uldrikis. Das hat irgendwie, also ja, du konntest irgendwann merken, dieses Stadion kollektiv aufgeatmet. Und ja, das war, also du konntest aber auch zum Beispiel nach dem Spiel, kein Mensch konnte so richtig damit umgehen. Es war sehr witzig so. Hä? Ist das passiert? Übrigens so sehr kleiner Shoutout, dass eine Freundin von mir bei der DFB-Pokalauslosung dachte, wir sind abgestiegen und müssen nächste Saison dann dreimal nach Großasbach. Nein, nein, einmal reicht und ist schon schlimm genug. Aber wir müssen tatsächlich nur einmal nach Großasbach. Das war noch erwähnt worden. Gibt es denn, ach so, ich habe die Community vergessen. Ein Spiel, was hier in der Runde nicht ist, aber ich kann euch versprechen, ist auch im All-Star-Team gelandet. Das sind die Fürth-Magdeburg-Spiele und zwar beide. Und zwar vollkommen verdient. Sie haben schon am Ende die meisten Stimmen bekommen. Ich habe es dann zusammengerechnet, ob Magdeburg gegen Fürth oder Magdeburg gegen Fürth. Es ist ein Konglomerat. Diese Partie hatte wirklich alles drin. Wir können uns nächste Saison darauf nochmal freuen. Das ist doch auch schön für alle Katastrophentouristen oder wie man das auch nennen möchte. Also das ist auch nochmal dabei. Bielefeld Hertha hat tatsächlich Mitte Darmstadt gegen Elbersberg auf einem geteilten 2. Platz. Also auch da bei der Community hoch im Rennen. Aber gibt es noch irgendein Spiel, was ihr... Ich mache das jetzt einfach mal. Ich bin jetzt einmal so frech, ich bin die Moderatorin außerhalb der 2. Liga, wo ihr einfach sagt, da gab es so... Also ich treffe euch jetzt einfach unvorbereitet, aber wo ihr einfach sagt, wenn du jemanden, der so keinen Bock auf Fußball hat, so ein Fußballspiel zeigen willst, dann sagst du so, hier, guck dir das mal an. Und wenn es nur 10 Minuten sind, welches Spiel wäre das bei euch denn? Anna?
Ja, nah dran an der 2. Liga, weil die Eintracht war beteiligt, das erste Pokalspiel gegen den VfB Stuttgart. Das war absolut fantastisch und...
Da dachte man kurz Heiner Backhaus, der ist es.
Ja, der ist es. Das ist unser Mann. Das war wirklich, wirklich absolut absurd. Ja, ging ja dann auch ins Elfmeterschießen, das wir dann knapp verloren haben. Also natürlich knapp verloren. Welches Elfmeterschießen? Naja, egal. Das war wirklich großartig und hat uns, also wirklich sehr geheilt an vielen Stellen. Es hat sich angefühlt wie so Bipanthen auf die Fansäle, nachdem sich die Eintracht ja im Mai erst dem Free-TV-Publikum in der Relegation präsentiert hat.
Und war das schlimm?
Ja, glaube ich, da viele in Kondolenzbücher reingeschrieben haben, alles Gute, bitte nie wieder, Free-TV mit Eintracht Braunschweig. Sind wir dann, hallo, wie heißt das, Kai aus der Kiste oder so? Versteht ihr? Was ist das eigentlich, Kai aus der Kiste? Naja, egal. Also, wer es weiß, gerne mir den Kai erklären. Großartige Präsentation, weil ich weiß nicht genau, vielleicht auch da könnt ihr euch ins Verhältnis setzen. Du freust dich dann in diesen Momenten noch mehr darüber, dass das Spiel so ist, wie es ist, weil du irgendwie denkst, vielleicht versteht jemand, warum ich diesen Verein mag. Wenn man sich nicht so komplett wie Grütze präsentiert, sondern irgendwie cool spielt und es ist spannend und die Fans sind irgendwie cool und alles passt irgendwie. Und dann bist du auch noch der tragische Verlierer und dir fliegen die Herzen zu. Und endlich, weiß ich nicht, so Instagram ist voll mit irgendwelchen Eintracht-Pornschweigs-Sachen, aber gut und nicht schlecht. Und es ist so schön gewesen.
Die Geschichten schreibt Hertha zumindest im Pokal auch immer mal wieder. Sei es dieses Spiel gegen den HSV, wo Fabi Reese tatsächlich kurz unmenschlich gut wirkte, das 6 zu 1 gegen Kaiserslautern oder auch jetzt diese bitteren Niederlage gegen Freiburg am Ende, wo Pascal Gdemens in entscheidenden Eiffmeter verschießt. Also das schafft man ab und zu auch. Ich habe meinen Bildungsauftrag erfüllt. Anna, man kann dir jetzt Kai aus der Kiste erklären. Der Spruch, die Kai aus der Kiste, geht aus dem gleichnamigen Kinderroman Kai aus der Kiste hervor. Aus dem Jahr 1924 oder 1925. Darin versucht der Berliner Straßenjunge Kai, nach Amerika zu reisen und lässt sich kurzerhand als Waren-Sendung verpackt in einer Kiste zu einem reichen amerikanischen Hotelgast liefern. Und dann steigt Kai tatsächlich aus der Kiste. Ich sehe Bilder von Kai gerade vor mir.
Guck mal, mir sind so viele Kinderbücher vorgelesen worden. Ich bin sogar mit– also meine Mutter hat den Bildungsauftrag Kinderbücher so ernst genommen. Mir sind bewusst Kinderbücher aus der DDR vorgelesen worden. Also, die Wiedervereinigung ist nicht an unserem Haushalt hier irgendwie vor Herausforderungen gestellt worden. Aber das Kinderbuch hat sie geskippt. Danke Marc, das ist toll.
Irgendwie auch süß, wie auf dieser Kiste steht vor sich nicht schürzen.
Nicht schürzen?
Geht für Kai Havertz vielleicht auch. Bitte nicht schürzen.
Es gab auf jeden Fall damals, als Kai Bernstein Präsident wurde viele Kai aus der Kiste überschriften.
Aber trotzdem, vielleicht Matthias, bei dir die Frage. Ich weiß, ich habe euch damit brutter als überrumpelt, aber hast du irgendwie generell so ein Spiel, wo du denkst, boah, das habe ich gerne gesehen.
Also dieses erwähnte Spiel von Anna, Braunschweig gegen VfB, war schon wirklich atemberaubend. Da saß ich auch vor dem Fernsehen und dachte mir, wow, da ist von Eintracht wirklich einiges zu erwarten. In der Saison hat sich dann anders erwiesen, aber das war schon wirklich visierhoch und gut. Auch der Konter und die Moves dabei waren und auch diese Distanzschüsse in unmögliche Winkel. Krass, da hatte ich wirklich viel erwartet von der Eintracht. Ich bin mir leid. Kein Problem. Vielleicht reden wir nächstes Jahr wieder an der Stelle und wir reden über den Trainer der Saison, das ist Lars Konnetka. Who knows? Könnte sein. Klar, Paris gegen Bayern, dieses 5-4 oder sowas. Aber ich fand dann doch Freiburg in der Europa League, da möchte ich jetzt vielleicht das Spiel, das den Finaleinzug dann klargemacht hat gegen Braga. Also früher Überzahl, aber dennoch, da hat man gemerkt, das bedeute den Leuten so viel. Ihr Club ist dabei, Geschichte zu schreiben und dann haben sie zum Schluss ein bisschen die Flatter gekriegt, aber dann einen friedlichen Platzsturm hingelegt. Also da hat mich so das Gesamtsetting einfach abgeholt, das fand ich schön.
Voll gute Wahl. Ich glaube, das war das erste Mal, dass ich Lothar Matthäus aufgeregt am Mikrofon gehört habe. Dann habe ich gesagt, jetzt da dichtmachen, jetzt da schneller. Und ich dachte so, oh Gott, das geschieht ihm noch eigentlich nicht. Sehr gute Wahl, sehr gute Wahl.
Wenn man eine Einzelleistung vorheben will, die einen Bock auf Fußball macht, dann Harry Kane gegen Borussia Dortmund. Das war das perfekte Spiel, kann man auch eben zeigen und sagen, deswegen wird man Fußballfan.
Ja, fand ich jetzt irgendwie noch mal schön, das auch noch mal abzurinnen. Ich muss einfach sagen, ich hab irgendwie gefühlt zu viel Fußball geguckt in dieser Saison und es verschwimmt immer alles so ein bisschen. Da werden dann auch mal Spieler irgendwie zu anderen Vereinen geredet, aber ich muss einfach generell sagen, ich fand halt einfach da auch noch mal mehr Liebe für 2. Liga. Aber es ist halt einfach schon cooler, wenn du halt nicht, dass die ersten acht gefühlt irgendwie immer dann noch belohnt werden, selbst für vielleicht nicht so wahnsinnig gute Leistung. Und dann halt aber irgendwie, ja in der 2. Liga hast du dann schon wirklich noch mehr dieses, dass halt mehr um was geht, nach oben und nach unten. Und das finde ich einfach zum Gucken interessanter. Und deshalb fand ich einfach diesen letzten Spieltag an sich, auch wenn ich ihn halt nur im Stadion erlebt habe für eine Partei. Aber da halt auch einfach nur mal Play-Doh-Johi macht, doch die Spiele wieder zumindest am vorletzten Spieltag auch alle gleichzeitig. Es bockt einfach mehr, weil alle mehr um alles spielen. Und es macht den Wettbewerb für mich einfach in dieser Phase fairer, auch wenn meine Nerven das eher darunter leiden.
Man könnte auch sagen, der DFB-Pokal könnte in der Hinsicht so ein bisschen angepasst werden, dass per se der unterklassige Verein Heimrecht genießt. Also finde ich...
Na, ja, ja. Es ist sowieso, ich finde, diese Regelung, also ich finde diese Regelung, das ist halt nur halt wirklich die Amateur-Dingsens und dann das hatte Bielefeld ja zum Teil, zum Beispiel letzte Saison, weil sie halt als Drittliga-Aussteiger, also beziehungsweise Aussteiger aus der dritten Liga aus dem Amateur-Topf kamen, deshalb war man in der ersten Runde im Amateur-Topf, aber weil man dann ja Zweitligist war, war man dann im Prinzip nicht mehr im Amateur-Topf, sondern hatte dann halt auch das Ausschussspiel bei der Union Berlin, so und gerade jeder der Bundesliga verfolgt bei Union will zu sehr, sehr ungern spielen. Naja, also vollkommen, wir könnten glaube ich jetzt so eine Liste aufzählen, was der Fußball besser machen könnte. Aber bevor wir jetzt gleich zu unseren sonstigen Awards kommen, gibt es noch hier ein bisschen eine Feedback-Schleife. Erstmal natürlich der Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist im Lärm, werbe Paywall und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich durch eure Unterstützung. Wie ihr das machen könnt, das könnt ihr erfahren auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da findet ihr auch aufgedröselt, wie viel Unterstützung, wie viel bringt, wo euer Geld im Endeffekt prozentual landet und wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, auf welchen Wegen. Da würden wir uns sehr drüber freuen. Denn das sorgt eben auch dafür, dass Marc und ich diese Ligatour moderieren dürfen und dass wir unsere tollen Gastinnen dabei haben und die eben auch ein bisschen was für ihre Mühen hier bekommen. Stellvertretend geht der Dank heute an Daniel Treufelskicker, Patrick W., Toni et Penny Lane und Jan Christopher. Die sind bereits SupporterInnen und werden dann eben random ausgewählt, weil sie sich registriert haben und das ausgewählt haben, dass man sie hier erwähnt. Zur Feedback-Schleife, danke für eure rege Kommunikation, für eure rege Teilnahme im Forum. Ich glaube, es war sehr gut, dass wir es ausgelagert haben mit der Zweitligatur. Ich würde weiterhin verzichten für jede Sendung einen eigenen Thread anzulegen, weil das, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen den Rahmen und das Forum sprengt. Aber vielen, vielen Dank für eure Unterstützung. Danke auch fürs Auffüllen der Umfrage. Danke, dass ihr uns so begleitet und unterstützt. Ein Hinweis für die Sendungen demnächst. Zunächst ist auch eine Ligatour Europa mit Saisonrückblick. Jetzt verlässt mich wirklich hier komplett mein Sprachzentrum. Letzte Woche erschienen. Da hört doch auch gerne einmal rein. Da resümiert Max mit Gästen die europäischen Saisons. Dann ist in der Nacht zu heute eine Sendung zum Spiel der Männer gegen die USA erschienen. Und die WM 2026 der Männer ist tatsächlich ein gutes Stichwort, denn nächste Woche geht es da so richtig los, dass das von Max angekündigte WM-Panel startet. Es erscheint ein Tribütengespräch und ich sage schon mal vorsichtig, ich hoffe, ihr habt im Juni nicht zu schnell genug von mir. Eventuell werdet ihr mich da auch nochmal hören. Also auch toll, ich hatte mich darauf eingestellt, nichts von dieser WM mitzukriegen. Naja, für den Rasenfunk macht man das doch immer wieder gerne. So, so viel zu diesem Infoblock und jetzt starten wir in unsere sonstigen Awards rein. Und wenn man so ein bisschen überlegt– also ich habe mal so ein bisschen geguckt, was hat denn Marc so für Awards genommen? Und ich dachte, wir gucken jetzt mal so ein bisschen, wir nehmen jetzt einfach nicht langweilig irgendwelche dummen Titel, sondern vielleicht mal so ein paar Namen reingeworfen. Und wir starten rein mit dem Simon Tirode Award. Spieler, die zu gut eigentlich für die 2. Liga sind, aber in Anführungszeichen zu schlecht für die 1. Bundesliga. Das klingt ein bisschen gemeiner, als es eigentlich ist, aber eben so Spieler, die einfach Leuchttürme in der 2. Liga sind, wo man immer sagt, der Schritt in der Bundesliga, der ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit. Und Matthias, start doch gerne mal rein. Wer ist es da bei dir geworden?
Bei mir ist es Florian Muslia geworden. Jawohl, gut. Der fiel mir schon auf, als er beim KSC so begann, im Erwachsenenfußball ein bisschen Fuß in die Tür zu kriegen. Dann ging er nach Hannover. Die sind dann mit ihm aus der 1. Liga abgestiegen. Das lag jetzt nicht an ihm, weil er war einfach ein junger, aufstrebender Spieler. Dann hat ihn 5 Jahre in der 2. Liga gehalten, meine ich. Auch bei Paderborn. Dann ging er nach Freiburg und da dachte ich so, jetzt ist seine Zeit gekommen, weil er auch immer wieder schon einer der auffälligen Spieler war in der 2. Liga. In Freiburg braucht man ein bisschen Anlaufzeit, aber die kriegt man und dann funktioniert das. Aber 1,5 Jahre später, muss man sagen, hat bei ihm nicht funktioniert. Er ist zwar standardstark und auch mit dem Ball am Fuß einfach schon auffällig, aber so Tempo und Dynamik, glaube ich, da gibt es doch Spieler, die mehr auf dem Kasten haben. Und schlussendlich ist er jetzt in Düsseldorf gelandet, mit einem Kreuzbandriss früher aus der Saison ausgestiegen, als es hätte sein müssen. Ist kurz so wahr, er ist schon Nationalspieler, hat auch in den Playoffs gegen die Slowakei getroffen. Also das heißt, er hat schon Ansätze, die ihn eigentlich für eine 1. Liga geeignet erscheinen lassen. Aber gerade dieses Freiburg-Intermett so jetzt zuletzt lässt mich glauben, dass da er ist jetzt auch bald 28. Vielleicht der Schritt doch nicht so ist, der bei ihm richtig ist. Ich meine, er kehrt jetzt zurück nach Freiburg, aber gleich wohl mit einem Kreuzbandriss. Das lässt mich glauben, dass man vielleicht versucht, ihn wieder fit werden zu lassen, dann zur Rückrunde nochmal verleiht. Aber er hat schon das Potenzial zum Unterschiedspiel. Das hat man auch in Düsseldorf gesehen. Aber ich glaube, 1. Liga könnte tatsächlich ein bisschen zu weit hergeholt sein.
Ja, finde ich sehr, sehr gute Auswahl. Anna, wen hattest du als Simon Theraude der aktuellen Saison auf dem Zettel?
Er ist vielleicht ein bisschen gemein, weil es ihm vielleicht nicht gerecht wird. Aber tatsächlich nenne ich hier Kenan Karaman. Es ist ein bisschen richtig und falsch gleichzeitig, weil er hat ja schon gezeigt, dass er erste Bundesliga spielt und spielen kann. Aber Eva, du hattest gerade dieses Wort Leuchtturm genannt. Und ich glaube, er ist in der Bundesliga, wird er ein wichtiger Spieler für Schalke sein. Ich glaube, er wird aber nicht diese perfekte Referenz ligaübergreifend werden, wie er das in der 2. Liga in dieser Saison gewesen ist. Es kann aber auch sein, dass er mich lügen straft. Und dann muss er den Award natürlich zurückgehen.
Ja, das ist nochmal kurz, weil dieser Award klingt halt so ein bisschen gemein. Aber es ist glaube ich einfach so ein bisschen, es ist ja auch eine Kunst, in der 2. Liga so eine Leistung zu bringen, dass du eigentlich immer sagst, er wäre was für die Bundesliga. Aber manche Qualitäten, ich denke da irgendwie auch an Marcel Hartl oder so, die einfach diese Qualität in der 2. Liga hatten, aber dann in der Bundesliga vielleicht auch nicht mehr die Zeit, die sie brauchten. Aber Marc, ich möchte natürlich auch deinen Simon-Torben-Award wissen.
Früher wäre es noch der Benjamin Auer Award gewesen in meinen Augen. Der war auch immer so ein Spieler. Ja, ich gehe hier tatsächlich mit Fabian Reese. Denn Fabian Reese liefert Saison um Saison beeindruckende Scorer-Zahlen. Das hat er auch in den letzten beiden Jahren in Kiel getan. Er tut es bei Hertha. Zeitgleich ist er jetzt 28 Jahre alt und hat es in der ersten Liga noch nie nachweisen können. Dazu kommt natürlich, dass er diesen unglücklichen Wechsel zu Hertha hatte, denn er war ja schon offiziell Hertha-Spieler, als dann Hertha noch letztendlich dann abgestiegen ist. Er hat dann die Rückrunde noch in Kiel verbracht und dann zu einem Zweitligisten kam und nicht zu einem Erstligisten. Das hat er sich auch anders vorgestellt. Und zweifelsohne finde ich die ersten beiden Saisons von Fabian Reese bei Hertha sehr, sehr, sehr gut. Besonders die erste in Kombination mit Haris Tabakovic war herausragend. Die war wirklich unglaublich gut und da hätte man ihm diesen Schritt in die Erstliga definitiv zugetraut, denn in der letzten Saison hat er durchaus Verletzungsprobleme, kommt wieder, plötzlich ist er Mittelstürmer und schießt pro Spiel ein Tor und hat eine absurde Quote und denkt, ach, das kann er jetzt auch noch, ja, okay, dann ist er wirklich zu gut. Und wenn man jetzt nur auf die Scorer-Zahlen der abgelaufenen Saisoncode denkt, man wieder, ja gut, also offensichtlich gibt es nicht so viel bessere in dieser zweiten Liga. Wir reden bei uns im Hertha-Base-Podcast, den ich jetzt einmal hier namentlich kurz erwähne, sehr oft über Fabian Reese und auch über die tiefer liegenden Zahlen, die halt zeigen, na ja, aber Elfmeter bereinigt und so weiter, ist das teilweise doch nicht so berühmt. Also, da ist auch viel auf neudeutsch Stats-Padding dabei. Und er ist nun mal auch, also Hertha spielt so eine Art Hero-Boy mit ihm. Also alles ist ausschließlich auf Fabian Reese ausgelegt, deswegen hat er einfach eine immens hohe Frequenz an Aktionen. Er schießt sehr oft, er flankt sehr oft und dass dann irgendwann was runterfällt, ist fast logisch. Aber die Quoten, auch im Tripling beispielsweise, sind teilweise gar nicht so berühmt. Und auch in diesem Sommer ranken sich ja die Gerüchte um einen Abgang. Er und Hertha haben sich mit diesem immensen Vertrag, den man im letzten Sommer aufgesetzt hat, der ihn ja schon wie einen guten Erstligaspieler verdienen lässt, schon auch in so einem kleines Dilemma manövriert. Möchte ich jetzt nicht zu weit darauf eingehen. Aber es gibt vielleicht auch Gründe, weshalb bislang einzig der VfL Wolfsburg als selbst frischer Zweitligist, der sicherlich andere finanzielle Möglichkeiten hat. Der einzige Verein, der bei ihm genannt wird als sehr krasser Interessent. Glaube ich, dass Fabian Reese Vereinen wie Augsburg, Gladbach oder auch Aufsteigern was geben können in der 1. Liga. Ja, durchaus hat er seine Qualitäten, aber er wäre, glaube ich, eher ein Spieler von vielen. So und dementsprechend finde ich, allein was seine Vita angeht, die teilweise einfach auch unglücklich dahingehend war, ist er prädestiniert für diesen Award.
Und vor allem, er ging ja damals von Kiel nach Hertha, als Kiel aufgestiegen war. Also er hätte ja nur da bleiben müssen.
Das kommt noch dazu. Also er hätte eigentlich nur bleiben müssen und er wäre Erstligaspieler geworden. Das kommt noch erschwerend hinzu, ja.
Ich muss da kurz sagen, fußballdaten.de hat immer die Bilder gefühlt von deren ersten Profi-Debüt drin. Und das von Fabian Reese ist nicht stark.
Anderer Mensch, ne?
Teilt es nachher nochmal mit euch. Das holt mich komplett ab. Aber witzigerweise, ich hatte auch über Fabian Reese nachgedacht. Und war mir auch nicht ganz sicher. Ich habe tatsächlich einen gewählt, der hier heute auch schon mal gefallen ist. Und das ist Marvin Warnizak. Der hat tatsächlich einen Einsatz beim VfB Stuttgart 2015-16 gehabt in der Bundesliga. Daran kann man es nicht messen. Ich kann mich nicht dran erinnern. I'm sorry. Aber der ist eben seit 2017 bei Karlsruhe. Und er ist eben auch dieser Leuchtturm da. Marc, du hast ja eben beschrieben, warum er dein Spieler der Saison gewonnen ist. Das heißt, ich würde das jetzt gar nicht nochmal runterrattern. Aber es ist für mich eben auch so ein Spieler, der eben in einem Zweitligateam dieser Leuchte ist. Also ich meine, hier zum Beispiel auch bei Sofascore steht zum Beispiel unter, ich glaube, das steht irgendwie, die machen immer so Stärke, Schwächen, da steht zum Beispiel Stärken, Spielmacher, direkte Freischüsse, Weitschüsse, Schwächen, keine herausragenden Schwächen. Und das stimmt auch, weil das haben wir eben schon herausgestellt. Aber ich glaube trotzdem, gerade so diese Spielmacher-Qualität, dafür hat er meiner Meinung nach bei so einem klassischen Bundesligist, vielleicht, wenn ich jetzt mal in dem Niveau meins, Augsburg und Co., ich glaube, dafür würde ihm einfach so ein bisschen die Technik doch am Ende des Tages dann fehlen, um da wirklich diesen Spielmacher auch wirklich auszufüllen. Und daher war das tatsächlich mein Pick, nochmal aber betont, was wirklich für ein herausragender Spieler Warnizek ist, der meiner Meinung nach trotzdem auch immer noch extrem unterm Radar irgendwie fliegt, weil eben auch Karlsruhe diese wacke Saison irgendwie immer wieder drin hat und nicht überall so ein bestimmtes Limit drüber kommt. Marc, ich guck dich jetzt einmal mal so leicht schräg an. Hast du da noch honorable mentions oder können wir weitermachen?
Eventuell. Eventuell, ja, habe ich. Marvin Warnizek habe ich auch auf meiner Liste gehabt. Jonas Meffert, ich finde, der ist immer ein herausragender Sechser in der 2. Liga, in der 1. Liga, fällt da nicht auf. Philipp Hofmann, guck dir die Zahlen in der 2. Liga an. Die sind richtig gut. Und selbst jetzt im hohen Alter war der für Bochum wieder sehr, sehr wichtig. Aber in der 1. Liga ist das ein Viertore-Stürmer. Julian Justwahn, da war das Hoffenheim, Intermezzo wirklich nicht gut, bei Nürnberg und auch Darmstadt.
Da war eine Bundesliga in der Rückrunde, genau.
Exakt. Und jetzt Verletzungsgeplagd nicht so präsent, aber Ivan Prataiens Quote in der 2. Liga ist fantastisch. In der 1. Liga hat er es nicht nachweisen können, bei Union irgendwie nicht angekommen, aber das sind auch andere Mittelstürmer nicht. Und ich habe sogar einen Trainer dabei, Tim Walter. Muss ich weiter ausführen? Weiß ich nicht. Tor oder Fußball in der 2. Liga? Darüber hinaus. Ja.
Ja, könnte sogar Lukas Kwasniok vielleicht nennen.
Ja, bislang würde er da drunter laufen. Das stimmt tatsächlich.
Gut, dann würde ich aber tatsächlich sagen, außer der Rest hat noch Honorable Mentions. Dann würde ich tatsächlich... Aha! Dann gehen wir tatsächlich weiter zu unserem Philipp Thiebs Award, der ein bisschen Erklärung bedarf. Und zwar, wer die Saison-Awards der Bundesliga bei den Männern gehört hat, hat vielleicht gehört, dass es einen ED&J Co. Award gab für den besten Wintertransfer. Und ich dachte, ich drehe den Spieß mal um. Und wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war vor allem Philipp Thiebs so die Person, die eben zu einem Verein gekommen ist und da wirklich einfach diesen Impact hatte. Und eventuell war es halt auch einfach schon eine Anspielung darauf, was manche Menschen in der 2. Liga wählen würde. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ihr gepickt habt, aber Marc, starte du doch einfach mal.
Ich habe einen von Schalke genommen, aber nicht Idin Dzeko. Und zwar habe ich mich am Ende für Adil Aoui-Schiich entschieden. Was für ein Transfer, was für ein Transfer. Dazu kommt die Komponente, dass er ablösefrei aus Sunderland kam. Das habe ich auch mal mit einfließen lassen, dass es auch ein finanziell einfach ein Stil war. Eine herausragende Mischung aus Spielmacher und Arbeiter, der stellvertretend auch für diesen spielerischen Wandel von Schalke in der Rückrunde stand. Aber wie gesagt, diese Schalke DNA, die man ja auch in dem Scouting-Tool festgelegt hat, also diese Arbeit gegen den Ball trotzdem weiter erfüllt. Aoushish ist ein Spieler, der schon seit gefühlt 16 ist, als ein herausragendes Talent galt, dann irgendwann als ewiges Talent und der jetzt mit 23 Jahren vielleicht ja auch in der ersten Liga ankommen könnte, wenn er das einigermaßen beibehält. Acht direkte Torbeteiligungen in 14 Spielen. Dazu kommen noch so Dinge wie, dass er Top 10 in der Liga 2 unter einen Flügelspielern ist, Dinge wie progressiven Pässen, Beilschleppen, Schüsse, vorletzte Pässe vom Tor, erwartbare Assists. Also der dieses Spiel spielerisch irre ankurbelt, der auch so eine Art Spielmacher vom Flügel aus ist, kann eigentlich alles. Und deswegen habe ich mich für Aushisha entschieden. Herausragender Transfer, der ja mit, wie gesagt, 23 Jahren sogar noch theoretisch Potenzial nach oben hat. Also perfekt.
Matthias, du darfst gerne direkt mit deinem weitermachen, weil du, glaube ich, noch eine Ergänzung hast.
Genau, also ich habe auch Aushish so ein bisschen stellvertretend für alle Winterneuzugänge bei Schalke, weil man kann es verstehen. Ljubicic, N'Jaye Müller auf der Ersatzbank als Torwart. Also da ging viel auf. Und ich glaube, Anna, du hast vorhin erwähnt, dass ja auch so ein Spiel die Wechselreihen musste bei Schalke. Und das haben sie mit den Personalien hervorragend eingeleitet. Und es hat halt auch sofort sehr schnell funktioniert. Am Anfang hatten sie so ein bisschen Ergebniskrise. Und Aushish fiel vielleicht auch in den ersten Spielen nicht sofort auf, aber dann mit Wucht. Also das finde ich auch krass. Und ist ja so ein PSG-Eigengewächs, der dann Umwege gehen musste, um jetzt zumindest in der 2. Liga auf sich aufmerksam zu machen. Wir werden sehen, ob er dann nächstes Jahr in der 1. Liga kann. Also wir trauen uns ihm, glaube ich, zu. Und ich hatte mir auch notiert, ablösefrei Ausrufezeichen. Also das ist schon wirklich verrückt.
Also, hä? Haben wir das selbe Dokument?
Ja, wer weiß. Und auch da Fret the Props an Frank Baumann, der ja so ein bisschen auch der Gestalter im Hintergrund ist, der von Bremen kam und hier bei Schalke offenbar sehr viel richtig gemacht hat. Und Aushish ist für mich jetzt auch so derjenige, der vielleicht bei dem ganzen Chekhoi ein bisschen übersehen wird. Aber wenn man in die Daten guckt und ihn auch mal im Stadion sieht, dann ist es klar, dass er dem Spiel enorm viel gibt. Ja, also mehr als Lubicic für mich zumindest. Und der war ja schon ein Name, der hier bekannt war. Also deshalb schließe ich mich gleich an und kann es auch abhaken. Also bei mir war es auch Aushish.
Anna, hast du auch jemand von Schalke 04? Oder ist das bei dir wer anders geworden?
Nee, es ist tatsächlich jemand anders geworden. Und zwar Ben Bobzin von Dynamo Dresden. Auch eigentlich eine Wahl aufgrund von Repräsentation, weil es einfach dafür steht, wie smart Dynamo Dresden in der Winterpause vorgegangen ist. Unglaublich. Eine Leihgabe von Mainz 05 mit 23 verhältnismäßig jung. In Mainz hat es nicht so gut funktioniert. Dresden kamen dann auf 15 Einsätze, 4 Tore und 5 Vorlagen. Und auch hier nochmal die Erwähnung, Dresden stand zum Winter mit 13 Punkten auf dem letzten Platz und hatte damit 4 Punkte Rückstand auf den Relegationsplatz und Platz 15 Punkt gleich zu dem Zeitpunkt und schließt die Rückrunde auf Platz 4 mit 28 Punkten. Wow, ey, was für ein Brett. Und das nicht mit langfristigen Transfers, sondern mit kurzfristigen Leihgaben, die clever getätigt worden sind, mit denen du natürlich echt ein hohes Risiko eingehst. Also der Junge wechselt jetzt zu Ende, oder was heißt wechselt, geht halt zurück zum 1.05. Das heißt, du butternst halt für 6 Monate alles rein in die Mission Klassenerhalt. Und ich finde das so unglaublich zu sehen, dass das funktionieren kann. Dass du mit kurzfristig angesetzten Hebeln für ein halbes Jahr einfach, was heißt, alles auf links drehen kannst. Ich bin so gespannt, was Dresden jetzt im Sommer macht. Wie sie diese Lücken, die sie durch Laien geschlossen haben, im Winter füllen. Ob sie eher so Richtung Elbersberg tentieren und sich die Qualität des Kaders zusammenleihen. Oder ob es ihnen gelingt, Spieler auf dem Niveau langfristig zu binden. Welche Lehren sie daraus ziehen. Und genau, das alles bündelt für mich Ben Mobzin von Dynamo Dresden.
Sehr, sehr gute Wahl. Dann hast du Dresden schon aufgedeckt und muss ich es nicht mehr machen. Deshalb habe ich tatsächlich nochmal bei mir beim eigenen Verein geguckt. Und das ist bei mir Maximilian Bauer einfach gewesen. In der Winterpause vom FC Augsburg gekommen. Hatte eine Verletzungszeit davor. Hatte eigentlich gar keine Spielpraxis. Ich glaube seit Mitte August. Diese Stammkraft hat sofort das gemacht, was du dir von Wintertransfers erhoffst. Dass sie sofort funktionieren. Dass sie sofort eine Rolle spielen. Weil bei Bielefeld einfach dieser Bedarf da war. Weil Joel Felix sich verletzt hatte. Und gleichzeitig eben auch man mit Schneider jemanden hatte, der eben nicht wirklich an den Leistungen aus der 2. Liga anknüpfen konnte. Aus der 3. Liga anknüpfen konnte. Und der hat eben jedes Spiel von Anfang an gemacht. Ja, es gab halt eine Muster gegen Kaiserslautern eben früh raus. Aber bleibt jetzt eben auch fest bei der Aminia, weil es da eben eine Klausel im Vertrag gab, dass man eben die Kaufoption ziehen muss, glaube ich, bei Klassenerhalt. Ich freue mich aber sehr, weil ich ihn tatsächlich auch als Mensch sehr, sehr sympathisch finde. Es gibt einen Aminia-Podcast mit ihm, also einen vereins-eigenen Aminia-Podcast mit ihm, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, er ist eine sehr reflektierte Person, ein sehr reflektierter Spieler, der eben auch klar benennen kann, warum es für ihn in der Bundesliga nicht gereicht hat. Und ich weiß gerade so diese Halbserie bei Kaiserslautern hat viele nicht so überzeugt, ich fand schon, dass er bei Bielefeld eine andere, bessere Rolle gespielt hat. Vielleicht auch aufgrund der Spieler, die da sonst neben ihm standen. Aber ich fand ihn im Vergleich, er ist halt neben Robin Knoche so ein bisschen untergegangen damals bei der Verpflichtung. Ich fand ihn hinten raus dann um einiges wichtiger. Und wie gesagt, ein sehr korrekter Mensch auch von einem, was man so hört aus dem Verein. Von daher ist es bei mir Maxi Bauer geworden.
Natürlich habe ich noch weitere Namen dabei.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich da frage.
Ja, deswegen dachte ich, mir presche ich da einfach mal vor. Ich möchte würdigen Satoshi Tanaka von Fortuna Düsseldorf. An ihm lag es wirklich gar nicht. Eigentlich ein grandioser Transfer von Mislintat. Kann man ihm einfach nichts sagen. Mislintat und Japaner, das funktioniert einfach. Übrigens gerade die Meldung gelesen, dass Tanaka und Schalke sich einig sein sollen. Das wird auch herausragend gut passen. Und ich glaube, dass Tanaka beweisen wird, dass er auch in der Bundesliga sehr gut mithalten kann. Und dann beweist es noch umso mehr, dass Düsseldorf da eigentlich einen Supertransfer getätigt hatte. Ich möchte Paul Will loben, der für die Stabilität im 4. Mittelfeld, glaube ich, immens wichtig war, der bewiesen hat, dass er eigentlich mehr kann, als er es vielleicht zuletzt auch verletzungsbedingt in Darmstadt zeigen konnte. Eden Dzeko kann man nennen, aber auch der hat dann natürlich verletzungsbedingt oder auch durch seine Sperre gar nicht mal so viele Einsatzzeiten. Und bei Dresden möchte ich auch noch Robert Wagner und Thomas Keller erwähnen, die alle drei zusammen dann mit Ben Bobzin das Ding aus dem Dreck gezogen haben. Thomas Keller über Standardstärke vor allem. Und Robert Wagner war ein immens stabilisierender Faktor im Mittelfeld. Der hatte eine sehr unglückliche Laie in Kiel, die sein Talent gar nicht widergespiegelt hat. Hat das jetzt in Dresden bewiesen, hat auch, glaube ich, schon gesagt, dass er sich vorstellen könnte, da länger zu bleiben. Da könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass man sich auf eine weitere Laie einigen kann. Jetzt auch, wo Amoako zum HSV wechselt, wird man im Mittelfeld richtig Bedarf haben in Dresden. Und was ich noch zu Anna sagen wollte zur Zukunft vom Dresdens Kader, weil das jetzt viele Laien waren, mit diesen Positivbeispielen machst du dich aber wieder attraktiv für Laien. Das hat der Elvesberg genauso gemacht. Das kann auch quasi trotzdem eine langfristige Wirkung haben, von dem einzelnen Spieler weggedacht. Das kann ich Dresden durchaus zutrauen, dass Vereine draufgucken und sagen, okay, dann laien wir halt unsere Spieler zu Thomas Stamm aus. Das wird sich lohnen.
Ja, sehr gute Ergänzung. Ich würde sagen, dann gehen wir zu unserem nächsten Award. Ich habe mich ein bisschen gesträubt, ihm den Namen zu geben, weil das ein bisschen sehr egozentrisch klingt. Es ist der Eva-Lotta-Bohle-Award. Warum habe ich ihn so genannt? Weil es darum ging, welcher Verein hat eigentlich für uns die beste Serie der Saison. Da zum Teil Menschen hier in den Podcast reinkommen und sagen, du sprichst ja immer von Serien, aber ich dachte, das kannst du so anschmeißen. Dann erzählt so eine kleine Eva-Lotta dir die ganze Zeit etwas von irgendwelchen Serien und dass das ja super wichtig ist. Sowohl in eine Richtung als auch in die andere Richtung. Deshalb misst ihr da jetzt mit mir durch. Bitte entschuldigt wirklich den Namen. Von daher, Anna, starte doch gerne. Was ist denn dein Verein mit der besten Serie-Saison-Award?
Also ich habe ein paar Haken geschlagen, weil es ist weder eine Serie, noch ist es gut. Aber ich wollte es gerne unterbringen. Und zwar sind es 6 Platzverweise in den ersten 11 Spielen. Der Braunschweiger Eintracht, was für eine tolle Serie. Also du musst ja die Fans erstmal auf ein Level gasleiten, auf dem sie glücklich sind, wenn ein Spiel einfach mit 11 Leuten beendet wird. Also du musst ja deine Erwartungshaltung einfach auch züchten. Und die, den wirklich, also neben Teilnehmenden an dieser Serie wird stellvertretend der Eva-Lotta-Bulle-Award in Gold an Kevin Ehlers verliehen, der innerhalb dieser Partien 2 Platzverweise bekommen hat. Genau, einmal rot, einmal gelb-rot und ja, genau, das ist meine Wahl.
Ich finde es ganz hervorragend, Anna, ich finde es wirklich top. Matthias, möchtest du gerne weitermachen?
Ja, ich habe mich tatsächlich dann noch mit den Serien per se, die offensichtlicher sind, beschäftigt und du sagst ja, gerne, wenn man eben ein paar Spiele in Folge gewinnt, dann ist man schon wieder von eher unteres Tabellen-Mittelfeld hin zu Anschluss an die oberen Tabellenplätze. Da stechen natürlich dann im Endeffekt zwei ins Auge. Pardubon hat acht Spiele in Folge gewonnen, vom 5. bis 12. Spieltag und war dann, meine ich auch Tabellenführer, dann kamen die Big Fishes, also sie haben dann gegen die Spitzen-Teams gespielt und dann gar nicht so gut ausgesehen, haben dann von den darauffolgenden acht Partien aber fünf verloren und die Ligien haben 13 Spiele nicht verloren, vom 11. bis 23. Spieltag war da auch dick in der Verlosung um den Aufstieg und haben dann anschließend von den elf Partien nur noch eine Partie gewonnen, also das ist natürlich verheerend. Insofern kamen beide aus Erfolgsserien und haben dann erst mal zu Struggeln gehabt und das heißt, wenn dann mal eine Siegesserie oder eine ungeschlagene Serie endet, dann haben es beide nicht sofort verstanden, die richtigen Schlüsse daraus zu ziehen und das waren meine eher unspektakulären Beobachtungen, so würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, finde ich trotzdem ein guter Pick. Ich mache jetzt einfach mal weiter, damit Marc in Ruhe noch sein Müssen die Regeln aufbüßen kann. Und zwar habe ich tatsächlich einfach Hannover 96, also tatsächlich einfach einen statistisch neuen Spiele ohne Niederlage zwischen dem 26. und 34. Spieltag. Wir wissen alle, wie es geendet ist, weil es waren einfach zu viele Unentschieden dabei. Aber ja, also ich sage es schon mal so, Spoiler, Hannover 96 taucht gerade noch, taucht gleich bei mir nochmal auf. Anna nickt schon bei ihr auch. Von daher, ja, war ich kurz und schmerzlos. Muss am Ende trotzdem Hannover 96 sein, weil man dann schon immer so gesehen hat, wenn sie mal in dem Groove drin waren. Es hat am Ende halt, weil die, es reicht halt nicht, nur eine gute Serie zu haben. Es ist leider dann auch so, vielleicht ist das irgendwann der Award 2.0, eine erfolgreiche Serie für den Saisonverlauf. Und das Saisonergebnis zu haben. Marc?
Ihr ist aufgegessen, sorry. Ich merkte meinen Blutzucker-Spiegel. Der viel tiefer als Preußen Münster, sorry.
Kein Fall für Alexander Ender. Ich hoffe, dein Doktor ist...
Nee, nee. Ich hab mal geguckt, was man vielleicht auf Spielerebene auch an Serien findet. Und ich wollte unbedingt Noel Futtkoi für seine brutale Saison irgendwie noch irgendwo unterbekommen. Und habe deswegen geguckt, wie hat er so geknipst. Und der Mann hat in den letzten fünf Saisonspielen immer mindestens ein Tor geschossen zu Beginn der Serie. Matthias, du wirst dich erinnern, sogar mit drei Toren beim 3 zu 2 Heimsieg gegen Darmstadt. Und dementsprechend hat der Mann mit dieser Serie gezeigt, er war da, als er gebraucht wurde, hat das Team zum Klassenhalt getragen. Er hat auch in der Relegation getroffen, da war leider schon das Spiel dazwischen. Deswegen gilt das nicht mehr als Serie, da war eine Spielpause quasi. Aber ohne diese fünf Saisonspiele am Stück, in denen er getroffen hat, wäre Fird niemals drin geblieben. Und das wollte ich irgendwie noch loben. Und deswegen habe ich seine Torserie zum Ende der Saison genommen.
Ja, finde ich sehr, sehr schön. Ich lasse kurz stumm werden. Nein, keine honorable mentions, Marc. Nein, das ist ja wirklich gruselig hier.
Hey, ich stecke voll Überraschung. So wie der nächste Award.
Damit wurde... Du bist ein zu früh. Es kommt noch einer.
Ach, Scheiße. Wer kommt denn dann?
Bei mir kommt jetzt erst ein Moment der Saison.
Ja, also, nee, dann habe ich es richtig im Dokument stehen können. Aber das kann ja trotzdem überraschend sein, das wollte ich damit sagen. Damit rechte ja erst mal keiner, weil es nicht sportlich gemeint ist.
So, guck mal, er nimmt mir jetzt schon meine Moderation weg. Der nächste Award ist der Moment der Saison-Award. Und zwar eben, weil wir hatten ja schon beste Spiele und so. Deshalb wollten wir gerne was explizit nicht Sportliches haben. Ich überlege jetzt einfach mal, ja, Marc, dann fang doch einfach mal an.
Gerne, gerne. Und zwar schreiben wir den 25. Spieltag. Hertha ist zu Gast bei Preußen Münster. Und gerade als man denkt, man habe schon alles im Fußball gesehen, kommen zwei vermummte Münster-Fans und ziehen dem Videobeweis den Stecker. Im Preußen-Scheidung kam es zu einem durchaus kuriosen Moment, wie wir uns erinnern. Das wurde später ja auch von wirklich allen relevanten Playern auch so bestätigt, es ist aber wirklich kein Gerücht. Es haben Zuschauer dem VR-Monitor in diesem Spiel, den Stecker, gezogen. Als Schiedsrichter Felix Bickel Ende der ersten Halbzeit an die Seitenlinie ging, um zu gucken, naja, war das denn jetzt eine Elfmeter oder nicht, denn Cuisance wurde im Strafraum gefällt. Ja, guckt ihr auf einen schwarzen Bildschirm. Währenddessen, es gibt auch so wundervolle Bilder von Imago und Co., die diesen Moment einfangen. Das müsste man eigentlich in ein Museum hängen, weil in dem Moment, wo er vor diesem schwarzen Bildschirm steht, hangeln sich zwei Fans mehr schlecht als recht wieder über den Zaun rüber. Und währenddessen hat man schon das Banner in der Kurve gesehen, Zitat, dem VAR den Stecker ziehen. Übrigens, geil, was noch zum Gesamtbildbeitrug war, der Sponsor über der Kurve, den ich jetzt namentlich nicht mehr drin habe, aber das Motto war, zusammen digitale Erfolgsgeschichten schreiben. Das war wirklich ein Gesamtunfall par excellence. Jedenfalls musste der Schiedsrichter feststellen, jut, ich kann mir die Nummer wirklich nicht angucken. Letztendlich sagte er dann durch, Zitat, meine Kollegin Katharina Falzke hat festgestellt, dass der 24er von Münster Cuisance klar am Schienmein trifft. Deswegen lautet meine finale Entscheidung Strafstoß. Riese verwandelte und später kamen übrigens auch noch raus, um das noch besser zu machen. Man hätte einfach den Stecker wieder reinstecken müssen. Mehr war nicht los. Da wurde nichts durchgeschnitten oder irgendwas. Man hätte es einfach machen können. Das System braucht wohl irgendwie anderthalb Minuten, um wieder hochzufahren. Es wäre möglich gewesen. Hat man nicht gedacht, naja, sei es drum. Aber ich bin nun wirklich nicht für Vandalismus. Aber Stecker ziehen, ist das überhaupt schon Vandalismus? Weiß ich nicht. Ich fand, das war eine herrlich kreative Protestaktion. Wunderschön. Und ja, letztendlich muss man auch sagen, es ist in dem Sinne nicht zu Schaden gekommen, weil es auch wirklich ein berechtigter Elfmeter war. Also das kommt noch dazu. Dementsprechend kann sich da, glaube ich, keiner beschweren. Zumal es ja die Münster-Fans waren gegen ihren eigenen Verein in dem Moment. Also das war ein toller Moment und den werde ich nicht so schnell vergessen.
Sehr, sehr schön. Anna, mach doch gerne weiter.
Ja, wir schreiben Heilig Abend des Jahres 2025. Alle Sportjournalistinnen des Landes freuen sich darauf, in Ruhe essen zu können im Reise der Familie. Ich bin gerade im Bereich Norddeutschland-Niedersachsen und dann sendet Hannover 96 die Push-Mitteilung Man trenne sich von Jörg Schmatke. Und also ich in vielen Ebenen würde mir dieser Satz nicht rausrutschen, aber ich liebe Hannover 96 für diese Possen. Es ist wirklich eine absolut großartige, es ist so fantastisch. Weil wer will nicht Hannover 96? Also super, Markus Mann geht im Sommer zur RB Salzburg Richtung Österreich. Das war sein Wunsch. Jörg Schmatke übernimmt dieses Abend. Und mich fand man bei diesem Akt schon irritiert, also der Verpflichtung. Und dann aber, ich glaube, der Zähler steht bei 81 Tagen, entlässt man Jörg Schmatke wieder. Und die Hintergründe sollen unter anderem ein Streit in einer Stadionloge mit einem Gesellschafter gewesen sein, wo es irgendwie total eskaliert ist. Und das Ganze mündet dann in seinem Ausscheiden. Und, ja, also mich trifft das maximal erheitert. Natürlich auch nicht ganz unbegründet in der Zugehörigkeit, der Fan-Zugehörigkeit zu meinem Verein, dass ich so hin und her dann irgendwie amüsiert verfolge. Ja, hat vielleicht sogar seine positiven Effekte gehabt, dann langfristig in der Rückrunde zumindest, wenn man unter Jörg Schmatke, oder mit Jörg Schmatke in dieser Position ja weniger erfolgreich als ohne. Insofern, wer weiß, wozu es gut ist. Aber ja, Push-Mitteilung an Heiligabend, das ist mein Call.
Aber warte mal, war das nicht? Also ich gucke jetzt mal nach, er war doch bis Ende, er kam doch erst im Winter, weil Markus Mann ist doch erst im Winter zu Salzburg gegangen. Also er kam doch, er wurde am 31.3. dann, glaube ich, entlassen. Also es war dieses Mitte der Saison-Ding.
So kurz sogar?
Genau, ich glaube, Markus Mann ist im...
Jörg Schmatke war das Weihnachtsgeschenk quasi.
Genau, genau. Also Jörg Schmatke wurde, glaube ich, an Weihnachten angekündigt als neuer Geschäftsführer.
Ah, jetzt bin ich hier.
Ah, jetzt bin ich komplett verkehrt. Und hatte dann am 01.01. seinen offiziellen Arbeitszeit. Und dann war aber dieses Mitte in der Saison, dass Jörg Schmatke entlassen wurde, wo ja auch diese ganzen Gerüchte aufkamen, ob jetzt Tietz gehen muss oder nicht. Und am Ende ging ja Schmatke.
Dann war das die Push-Mitteilung an Heiligabend. Es war eine Push-Mitteilung an Heiligabend. Bei dem Moment der Saison bleibe ich auf jeden Fall. Das ist jetzt die zweite Korrektur an dieser Stelle. Es war eine lange Saison.
Ist okay. Hier ist wieder das Live-Korrektiv unterwegs. Die Saison war wirklich lang. Ja, und dann darf Matthias natürlich noch.
Es war der 16. November, um auch mal noch das Datum hier reizudrücken.
Ich habe hier irgendwas eingeleitet.
Genau. 16. November 2025, Länderspiel-Pause, Fandemo in Leipzig. Also sprich, viele Fan-Vertreter, viele Vereine haben sich in Leipzig getroffen, um gegen die drohenden Beschlüsse der Innenministerkonferenz zu protestieren. War sehr beeindruckend. Hat auch gezeigt, dass sich Fans zählen, die sich nicht gerade wohlgesonnen gegenüberstehen, in der Hinsicht sehr einig sind und es ging darum, irgendwie Verschärfungen der Stadion- und Verbotsrichtlinien oder auch personalisierte Tickets, KI, was weiß ich. Also wurde dann alles schlussendlich erstmal nicht umgesetzt. Ich sage bewusst erstmal, mal gucken, was noch kommt. Und es war für mich sehr schön zu sehen, dass da so ein Schulterschluss geübt wurde, der in friedlicher Szenerie über die Bühne ging. Nach Leipzig muss man auch erstmal reisen, aus allen Winkeln der Republik. Und ich habe zuletzt das Ronald-Reng-Buch gelesen über die WM 2006. Und da wurde unter anderem auch das Sicherheitskonzept erläutert. Und ich habe es jetzt leider nicht notiert, aber da wurde schon als ein wesentlicher Faktor, dass alles so positiv über die Bühne ging, erwähnt, dass die Polizei, Präsenz und die Kommunikation der Polizei als sehr lobend und Erfolgsfaktor dargelegt wurde, wie man Fanszenen begegnet. Also damals gab es auch Befürchtungen, dass Hooligans aus Polen etc. pp. anreisen und hier Krawall machen. Und Public Viewing war ja auch durchaus Neuland. Aber man hat es verstanden, Polizisten aus den jeweiligen Ländern hier auf die Straßen zu schicken, die Fanszenen anzusprechen und so einfach ein gutes Miteinander herbeizuführen. Und ich habe so den Verdacht, im Moment oder nicht nur im Moment, aber schon seit Längerem ist es eher konfrontativ. Und die WM 2006 hat gezeigt, da geht es auch in eine bessere Richtung. Und leider ist man dabei, das so ein bisschen zu vergessen. Natürlich war das Spiel Dresden gegen Hatta so ein bisschen wieder Wasser auf die Mühlen derjenigen, die eigentlich dafür sind, hier Tabula Rasa zu machen. Und deshalb war das eher ein Eigentor, das die positiven Eindrücke aus Leipzig so ein bisschen verwässert, muss ich sagen.
Ja, also ich würde es abwinden mit– das ist tatsächlich auch mein Moment der Saison gewesen.
Dresden-Hatta. Genau.
Ich bin hier nur für die Gewalt.
Krawall-Bohle.
Genau. Ich habe in Armband das Schikrawall-Ribmaus drauf. Ich muss dafür auch einstehen. Nein, das ist eben auch genau das, weil, wie gesagt, ich habe ja eben schon mal gesagt, ich bin halt auch viel in Fußballstadien. Ja, es ist halt auch was, was mich halt direkt betrifft und die Art und Weise, wie ich mich fortbewegen kann. Erstens, das möchte ich dann noch dazu erwähnen, die Berichterstattung drum herum. Ich hatte mal das Gefühl, es haben sich endlich auch mal außerhalb von Elf-Freunde wirklich Medienhäuser hingesetzt und haben gedacht, so, wir gucken jetzt wirklich mal, was da passiert und wie das abläuft und wir machen jetzt nicht nur Spekulation, sondern wir gucken auch ein bisschen, wo das herkommt. Dass dann hinterher Aussagen wie von Armin Thuster, der einfach komplett erfundene Statistiken rausgelabert hat, nicht eingeordnet wurden, halte ich dann wiederum für fatal, ehrlich gesagt. Das sei noch dazu gesagt, aber per se fand ich das nämlich auch, weil ich eben auch die Zweitliga-Fans gelobt habe und eben auch da eben nochmal einen Hinweis, dass das eben nicht nur irgendwelche Kurvengänger betrifft, sondern eben jeden Fan im Stadion, wenn wir da eine Verschärfung haben. Beziehungsweise auch einfach, also ja, ich glaube, man muss nur in andere Stadien gucken, um vielleicht– und in andere Länder gucken, um vielleicht auch zu gucken, welche Art von Fan-Kultur wollen wir denn eigentlich gerne haben. Und ja, also mein Negativbeispiel bleibt da für alle Zeit in England. Da kannst du dir halt in den ersten zwei Ligen mit Fan-Kultur. Also, ich mache mir jetzt vielleicht bei ganz vielen Leuten Feinde, aber es gibt mir halt wirklich gar nichts, mehr da ein Spiel anzugucken. Von daher, ja, das sei noch gesagt. Matthias, gerne.
Genau. Vielleicht um doch noch einen Moment, der ein bisschen einen sportlichen Anstrich hatte, in Erinnerung zu rufen. Und weil Marc auch den VAR einleitend erwähnt hat, für mich war das Spiel, ich glaube, es war Bielefeld gegen Fürth in der Hinrunde. Da war ein VAR ein Satz, weil ich meine, da fiel ein Tor und es wurde zurückgenommen. Und der Stürmer ist mit dem Verteidiger rausgelaufen. Also er hat sich Richtung Mittellinie orientiert und das Tor wurde aberkannt, weil er mit der Ferse näher zum Tor stand. Dabei ist er mit dem Verteidigenden Spieler rausgelaufen und hat womöglich dann auch später erst reagiert auf den langen Ball. Und so was dann zurückzunehmen, wird für mich so ein bisschen die Abseits-Regel durch den VOR ad absurdum, weil es ist einfach nicht mehr im Sinne des Spiels. Und dabei kann man es, glaube ich, auch belassen. Auf jeden Fall, das war für mich so rückgedrachtend in der Saison ein sportlicher Moment, wo ich mir dachte, wie kann ich das denn als abseits werten? Ich weiß nicht mal, wer es geschossen hat, ob es Furtwarr oder Bielefeld. Auf jeden Fall erschien es mir reichlich absurd, dass ein Spieler betraft wird. Weil einfach er mit dem Verteidiger rausläuft und die Ferse halten, die er zum Tor ist. Nicht mal die Fußspitze, sondern die Ferse. Und ich glaube, Anna, du hast die Schuhgrößen-Thematik auch hier schon mal erwähnt. Also es ist abseits heikel. Naja.
Ja, da kommt der VR. Bekommt ihr nochmal sein Special Place. Marc? Hast du noch einen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Oh, dann guckst du jetzt immer schon so richtig beleidigt.
Aber ich habe tatsächlich nichts mehr an ich. Diese ganze Polizei-Fußball-Fan-Thematik, da hüte ich jetzt meine Zunge, weil ich weiß, dass ich dann 6 Minuten Monolog halten würde. Nicht sinnvoll, nicht zielführend an dieser Stelle.
Gut, dann würde ich weitermachen. Und vielleicht ist das ja auch ein Plottwist. Das Marc dann einfach mal nicht zu einem 6 Minuten Monolog. Entschuldigung. Wow.
Wow. Du habst einfach...
Nee, hab ich auch lieb, Eva. Nee, mach mal, mach mal.
Wollen wir jetzt noch wissen, was ist denn euer Plottwist der Saison? Und Matthias, weil wir so zusammen aufgehört haben, würde ich dir da den Vortritt lassen.
Ja, Düsseldorf. So nach dem Motto, what could possibly go wrong, hold my beer. Also Fortuna wird hoch, geht schlussendlich runter. Für mich ist natürlich die Saison in vielerlei Hinsicht zu erklären, warum sie so lief, wie sie lief. Andererseits gibt es auch Fassungslosigkeit, wie sowas passieren kann. Und ja, Thorsten bei uns im Team musste jetzt leider Gottes uns immer wieder mit Infos füttern, die uns auch schon betroffen haben. Aber für mich ist so ein Punkt den zweiten Trainerwechsel von Anfang hin zu Alex Ende. Das war für mich der zweite Schritt vom ersten. Also wenn ich quasi schon perspektivisch den Neuen Bauer in der Zweitliga oder den spielerischen Stil in der Zweitliga in den Blick nehme, ohne schon gerettet zu sein, ist es vielleicht ein bisschen verfrüht. Also es hätte auch gut gehen können. Der Sieg gegen Elbersberg hat es gezeigt am vorletzten Spieltag. Aber schlussendlich hatten sie zu viele Verletzungen oder auch Sperren, insbesondere im letzten Spieltag hat ihnen sehr, sehr wehgetan. Das zeigt auch, dass die Abhängigkeit von ihm viel zu hoch war. Also er war der Garant, wenn es um Torabschlüsse und Tore erzielen ging. Aber für mich ist der Plot-Twist der Saison Fortuna Düsseldorf.
Ja, Marc, willst du noch was dazu ergänzen, weil du schon gesagt hast, sticht?
Ja, ich habe mir auch noch mal da die Platzierung der letzten Jahre angeguckt, die einfach unterstreichen, wie groß dieser Plot-Twist ist. Wir reden über einen Club in den letzten zehn Jahren, der in der 2. Liga 14. und 11. wurde, dann auch in der Bundesliga war, dann ist er in den letzten Jahren 5., 10., 4., 3., 6. geworden. Also die Fortuna war wirklich immer ein Club, der sehr gefestigt war, der immer nach oben geguckt hat, auch berechtigterweise, die Saison wieder aufsteigen wollte. Und das war halt dieses typische Team, bei dem alle dachten und wahrscheinlich auch sie selbst, die kann es gar nicht erwischen. Und das ist ja immer die größte Gefahr. Diese Trainerwechsel hin zu Anfang, hin zu Ende haben auch eine gewisse, jetzt im Nachhinein ist man immer schlauer, aber eine gewisse Ernsthaftigkeit vermissen lassen, weil man, wie du gesagt hast, Matthias, irgendwie da schon gedacht hat, wir holen schon die paar Siege und deswegen können wir schon die Zukunft vorbereiten, weil die Gegenwart regelt sich schon. Und gefühlt war das halt nie eine Mannschaft. Also dieser Verlust von erfahrenen Spielern wie Sobotka oder Hoffmann, Fermee, die waren alle vielleicht sportlich nicht super wichtig, aber wir alle können ein Lied davon singen von Spielern, die in der Kabine super wichtig sind, obwohl sie nicht mehr jedes Spiel spielen. Dazu die Abgänge von Sieber und vor allem Johannessohn, da hat man einfach die Achse weggerissen und das haben Alos und Co. massivst unterschätzt und sie werden dafür bezahlt, da klüger als das Umfeld zu sein, was da ab und zu mal draufguckt und sagt, naja, haben sie sich doch eigentlich wieder einen ganz talentierten Kader hingestellt. Sie müssen es besser wissen, haben sie nicht. Drei unterschiedliche Trainer haben diese Dynamik nicht mehr verändern können, nicht mehr umkehren können und natürlich, wenn Fortuna Düsseldorf den Aufstieg anpeilte, wir alle das nicht für völlig absurd gehalten haben und sie am Ende als 17. absteigen. Übrigens auch nach XG-Tabelle waren sie Platz 15 und nur drei Punkte besser. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die ein Spiel nach dem anderen unverdient verloren hätten, man am Ende sagen muss, das ist ein Freak-Accident. Nee, das ist schon insgesamt einigermaßen verdient und dementsprechend ja auch bei mir der Plot-Fist der Saison. Im Klammern habe ich aber auch den Jäger-Transfer gesetzt, um den einmal hier erwähnt zu haben, weil das war tatsächlich ein Plot-Fist.
Sehr, sehr schön. Anna, was ist es bei dir geworden? Was hat dich aus dem Hogger gehauen?
Ja, tatsächlich schließe ich mich da an. Auch die Fortuna sowohl– also der Plot-Twist vor der Saison, nach der Saison, aber auch innerhalb der Saison– liefern sie im Endspurt eigentlich zwei mit einem klaren und verdienten Sieg gegen Elbersberg. Und ja, da wird hinten gesperrt. Und natürlich hat das einen Effekt. Aber wie groß der Effekt dann sein würde und wie hilflos man am letzten Spieltag in Fürth ist, das hat mich dann doch überrascht und ja, genau, sowohl im Großen als auch im Kleinen mit vielen Wendungen gespickt und dann den tragischen Ausgang genommen. Das ist wirklich unglaublich. Also hier kurzer Einblick in die Informationen, die wir da zugespielt bekommen haben. Das ja Teil des Sponsorings der Tagobank war, diese Fortuna für– oder ja, dieser der Hauptsponsoren unter anderem Tagobank, diese Fortuna für alle Spiele zu finanzieren, bei denen der Eintritt frei war. Und jetzt steigt man ab. Das heißt, die Fortuna für alle Spiele fallen zum Beispiel aus den Dauerkarten natürlich raus bzw. wieder rein als zu finanzierende Spiele. Aber nicht nur das, man hat auch mehr Spiele, weil die Liga größer ist, sodass jetzt nach dem Abstieg mehr Spiele finanziert werden müssen und somit die Kartenpreise steigen. Und die Moderation dieses Vorgangs ist bestimmt sehr schwer, nahezu unmöglich. Und an der Stelle einfach alles Gute für das, was da jetzt kommt. Das ist ganz schön viel.
Ja, da will ich auf jeden Fall ergänzen. Und als Fan eines Vereins, der diesen kompletten Neustart durchmachen musste, jeder, der sagte, voll toll, nein, diese erste Saison ist einfach katastrophal. Und jeder, der mal in der dritten Liga mit seinem Verein spielen musste, weiß, nach einem Abstieg, das ist einfach brutal schwer. Weil egal, wie neu du da reingemischt kommst, du gehst immer als Favorit in die Saison rein. Gerade auch Fortuna Düsseldorf mit dem Namen. Und das wird wirklich alles andere als leicht. Und ich drücke der Fortuna da auch die Daumen. Viel Kraft auch an alle Fortuna-Fans. Und da kann ich auch sagen.
Sorry, ich wollte nur sagen, dazu kommt ja jetzt noch der Plot-Fist, dass es nicht mit Mislintat weiterging. Der sicherlich auch schon Dinge angeschossen hatte, sich reingearbeitet hatte. Da hieß es dann, dass es menschlich nicht gepasst habe. Da habe ich keine Einblicke. Das ist etwas, was man natürlich Sven Mislintat schnell vorwerfen kann. Und alle werden das schon abnehmen und sagen, na ja, das war ja bei anderen Stationen auch so. Ich will nicht sagen, dass es nicht so war. Aber anscheinend hat es ja insgesamt bei Fortuna nicht gestimmt. Und vielleicht wäre Mislintat sogar der gewesen, der explizit den Finger in die Wunde gelegt hätte. Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob dieser erneute Kurswechsel innerhalb von ein paar Monaten jetzt so viel erfolgsversprechender ist. Also das kommt ja noch dazu, dass die leichten Vorbereitungen, die man vielleicht hatte, denn er war ja der Trainer, der auch Alexander Ende rein geholt hat, das ist jetzt schon wieder– also da hat man schon wieder was über den Haufen geschmissen. Das ist wirklich eine Katastrophe.
Ja, und eben der Vorschönigkeit bei Sami Haravi geholt, der halt schon das kennt, also mit einem Verein eine Neustart zu wagen, eben mit Aminia Bielefeld 2011, aber da muss man sagen, sehr unbeschriebenes Blatt damals, der von Aachen kam und jetzt dann eben 12 Jahre bei Aminia Bielefeld war und sich dann natürlich auch selber entwickelt hat. Und es auch Gründe gab, warum man ihn hinten raus hier, also warum viele Bielefeld-Fans in der ersten Reaktion Fortuna des oder alles Gute für die Zukunft gewünscht haben und gehofft haben, dass da keine Schamanen jetzt rumlaufen. Also das hat alles seine Hintergründe, warum da die erste Reaktion vielleicht nicht so positiv ausfühlen und er ist im zweiten Satz gesagt, er kann das schon, aber Punkt. Ich habe mir tatsächlich, ich habe das eben schon mal angespoilert, für mich ist der Plottestell der Saison Dresden's Rückrunde. Auch einfach anhand dem, was wir glaube ich noch im Hinrunden-Fazit auch gesagt haben, dass wir uns einfach nicht wirklich vorstellen können, wie Dresden diese Spiele, die ja vorher auch nicht schlecht waren, aber halt nachhaltig so zu gestalten, dass man es gewinnt. Und nachdem man eben 18. war der Hinrunden-Tabelle, ist man eben als 4. ich glaube Anna hat es eben schon mal gesagt, hinten rausgekommen mit 28 Punkten. Das ist schon wirklich mehr als doppelt so viele Punkte wie in der Hinrunde. Bei Marc war kurzes Bild ein Chaos, aber gut. Und man muss einfach sagen, wirklich Respekt. Man hat eben auch das Torverhältnis von minus 10 auf plus 11 gesetzt. Also in dieser Rückrunde.
Hatte ja auch so Freaksieger, ne? Wie war das?
Ein 6 zu 0 gegen Münster? Und man muss wirklich sagen, man merkt dann doch auch schon, glaube ich, einfach, dass Thomas Stamm eben schon Zeit hatte, mit Dynamo Dresden in der dritten Liga zu arbeiten. Dass der, glaube ich, schon wusste, dann, wir haben eben schon gesagt, so einen Konter zu holen im Winter, die Transfers. Wie gesagt, der Rest wurde, glaube ich, schon ganz gut ausgeschmückt. Und sie auch wirklich. Also ich bin sehr gespannt, was wir da nächste Saison von Dynamo erwarten können. Vorsichtig gesagt, das ist, glaube ich, sowohl für Bielefeld als für Dynamo gar nicht mehr so schlecht, dass mit Osnabrück vielleicht schon noch der stärkere Aufsteiger, aber weil ja auch in der 3. Liga so mega eng war hinten raus, wer steigt da denn eigentlich auf? Da definitiv, also von Pfostentreffer in Duisburg und Co., da vielleicht so ein bisschen, ja, schauen wir mal, was da für Qualität mit reinkommt. Also ja, bin ich da mal sehr, sehr gespannt, was das eben auch für die letztjährigen Aufsteiger bedeutet. Aber wirklich, man kann Dynamo Dresden nicht genug Kompliment dafür geben. Ich hab noch vielleicht so einen weird, also noch einen Plot-Twist, das ist einfach Tim Walther. Also ich komme jetzt mal hier mit On-Road-Mention. Tim Walther bei Kiel. Also es hat geklappt und ich glaube, das hat uns alle so ein bisschen überrascht, dass es vor allem so auch dieser Serienaufbau und so war. Aber ja, also ja, Respekt, dass sie es hinten raus eben noch geschafft haben. Also ich meine, es sind trotzdem nur 21 Punkte in der Rückrunde. Aber ich bin noch mal sehr gespannt. Marcel Rapp, er ist eben auch neuer Trainer beim FC St. Pauli. Also den werden wir nächste Saison auf jeden Fall auch wieder sehen. Sehr, sehr spannende Geschichten für die nächste Saison. Definitiv. Ich glaube, man kann da noch ein paar andere nennen. Ja, aber das ist, das wäre jetzt so mein Call.
Schön.
Schön. Dann kommen, wir haben jetzt noch drei Kategorien, die ich auch sehr schön finde tatsächlich, muss ich gestehen. Und zwar kommen wir als Erstes, und ich habe da schon eine Ahnung, dass wir da vielleicht gegebenenfalls gleiche Tendenzen auch haben, wie schon im Vorherigen-Award, bei dem der Was-Währe-Wenn-Award, also die größten verpassten Chancen, das größte Drama, was es in dieser Saison, ich meine die ganze Saison, die 2. Liga ist ein einziges Drama. Aber wir wollen trotzdem draufgucken. Und dann starte ich mal bei dir, Anna. Wer bekommt dein Was-Währe-Wenn-Award?
Benjamin Kessel für die Winterpause bei Eintracht Pornschweig. Und zwar hatten wir, jetzt muss ich hier einmal schauen, 7 Zugänge und 7 Abgänge. Und zwar die Abgänge unter anderem von Sebastian Polter. Von Köhler, der Kapitän gewesen ist und vor allem von Christian Conté, der halt eine richtige Serie hatte und maßgeblich dazu beigetragen hat, dass die Pornschweig Eintracht deutlich, relativ für unsere Verhältnisse, deutlich über dem Strich stand vor dem Winter oder zum Winter. Und mein Was-Währe-Wenn-Award bekommt Benjamin Kessel bei Was wäre, wenn er da souveräner gewesen wäre? Und mit souverän meine ich nicht, Abgänge zu verhindern, weil Christian Conte, der nach Heidenheim gewechselt ist, was willst du da machen? Der hat noch ein halbes Jahr Vertrag, Heidenheim bietet anderthalb Millionen, der ist nicht richtig fit. Natürlich lässt du den gehen und sagst das Geld ein. Auch im Nachhinein, natürlich hilft da der Klassenerhalt bei der Betrachtung, würde ich sagen, richtige Entscheidung, weil er tatsächlich auch die gesamte Rückrunde nicht richtig fit geworden ist. Also wäre er diese Verstärkung gewesen. Ach ja, naja, der Konjunktiv und der Fußball, das ist einfach ein ewiges Match, was wäre, wäre wenn. Nichtsdestotrotz, wenn du dich dazu entscheidest, eben auch deinen Kapitän gehen zu lassen, beziehungsweise dich in die Situation bringst, ihn gehen lassen zu müssen, da spielt auch medialer Druck eine Rolle. Und so eine Berater-Posse, dass er gehen kann zu den Grashoppers Zürich. Und Sebastian Polter lässt du auch gehen, der vielleicht keine sportliche Stütze gewesen ist, aber natürlich als sehr senioriger Spieler total wichtig für einen Kader, der im Schnittverhältnismäßig jung gewesen ist. Und du reißt da einfach das Fundament raus und schiebst Styropor drunter. Das kann und konnte nicht funktionieren. Du nimmst da ganz viel Stabilität aus dem Kader und leist dir dann irgendwie ein bisschen was zusammen. Dann, ja klar, gibt es auch feste Verpflichtungen, aber so richtig überzeugt davon tatsächlich eigentlich nur an die Hottie in der Innenverteidigung.
Das hatte mehr was von Masse statt Klasse, ne? Wir nehmen mal von irgendwas mit. Ach, der Ranos fällt in Gladbach auch irgendwie runter. Nehmen wir mit. Das hatte irgendwie gar kein Konzept, hatte ich das Gefühl.
Ja, und du holst dir Spieler, die vielleicht sportlich grundsätzlich vielversprechend sind, aber einfach kein Selbstbewusstsein haben. Farideh Alidou kommt aus Kaiserslautern und hatte da nach einem guten Saisonstart insgesamt eher keine gute Zeit. Und wie sollen dir solche Typen im Abstiegskampf helfen? Das heißt, das sind so ganz viele Was-wäre-wenns. Deswegen finde ich es eine schöne Kategorie, denn was wäre wenn dieses Transferfenster insgesamt souveräner und erfolgreicher gestaltet worden wäre? Vielleicht hätte man aber bei einer Backhaus behalten. Und das wiederum finde ich einen langfristig eher positiven Effekt einer so chaotischen Transferphase, weil natürlich leidet der Trainer unter diesen Transferentscheidungen, die er so auch in dieser Tragweite nicht unterstützt haben soll, so das Hörensagen. Jetzt haben wir Lars Konnetka an der Seitenlinie, was ich insgesamt sehr begrüße. Und das wäre vielleicht nicht passiert, wenn einer Backhaus die Personalien bekommen hätte, die er sich gewünscht hätte. Also wofür ist es gut gewesen? Man weiß es nicht. Deswegen mein Award an Benny Kessel.
Sehr, sehr schön. Matthias, wer ist es bei dir geworden?
Was wäre gewesen, wenn Hannover aus 96 Elfmeter schießen könnte? Wäre mein Pick. Sie haben elf Meter in der Saison bekommen, inklusive Pokal. Und sechs davon haben sie verschossen. Das begann schon in der ersten Runde im DFB-Pokal, 1-0-Linie-Lage in Cottbus und Tomiak verschießt. Den Elfmeter, was womöglich die Verlängerung bedeutet hätte oder auch das Spiel schon hätte in die richtige Richtung aus Hannovers Sicht hätte kippen lassen können. Im Moment, wenn man sich einfach die Zweitliga-Saison vor Augen führt, sie hätten mit zwei Punkten Rückstand Paderborn auf den vierten Platz verdrängt, weil sie ein besseres Torverhältnis hatten. Sie verschießen Kjellmann am 16. Spieltag zu Hause gegen Borum, Endstand 0-0. Leopold am 25. Spieltag zu Hause gegen Fürth, verwandelt er nicht, Endstand 1-2. Und auch gegen Schalke verschießt Leopold, das ging dann zumindest noch unentschieden ausschließendlich. Und nach dem verschossenen Elfmeter gab es auch dann den Anschlusstreffer. Aber wer weiß, wie es gelaufen wäre. Aber es hätte ihn sicherlich nicht geschadet. Dann hättest du an der Stelle das Rennen um Platz 2 sogar durchaus aufrechterhalten können. Weil auch Elbersberg war nicht weit weg. Zwar besseres Torverhältnis, aber du hättest einfach Punkte einsammeln können, die ein leichtes gewesen wären. Und natürlich verfällt mir jetzt so ein bisschen die Erzählung. Tietz hat es in Magdeburg verbaselt und in Hannover auch. Verbaselt jetzt, er spielt schon den Aufstieg, was ja auch schon mal nicht schlecht ist. Aber ein Elfmeter kann er nicht verwandeln. Das ist dann schon die Aufgabe des treffsichersten Stürmers oder des Kapitäns. Und wenn es beide nicht hinkriegen, kann man Tietz da vielleicht auch keinen Vorwurf machen. Aber für mich ist es die Elfmeterschwäche, sagen wir mal, oder die mangelnde Nervenstärke bei Elfmetern, die Hannover durchaus hätte gut zu Gesicht stehen können.
Ich ziehe da kurz eine Verbindung zu den vorherigen Awards. Denn Tobi, also der 96er, hören wir uns aus, der Oldsterrunde, der hat tatsächlich bei mehr Liebe für Elfmetertraining eingetragen. Das ist vielleicht dann eine gute Abbindung. Marc, was ist es bei dir?
Ja, ich hatte mir auch gedacht, eigentlich kann man das auch den Hannover 96 Award nennen, bei den vielen Verevents und Konjunktivs. Und hätte man mal, also allein wenn man sich die XG-Tabelle anguckt, hätte Hannover eigentlich auf Platz 1 landen sollen. Sie haben viel dafür getan, dass es am Ende nicht so kam, durch hanebüchende Fehler oder nicht genutzte Chancen. Es war mir aber so offensichtlich, dass ich es zu offensichtlich fand, und deswegen habe ich Hannover am Ende gar nicht genommen, sondern ich habe Josep Bricaló genommen. Er kam im Winter aus Spanien zu Hertha. Man hat hier noch Erinnerungen aus vor allen Dingen Wolfsburg, aber auch Stuttgart wusste, dass das ein zwischenzeitlich fast schon etablierter kroatischer Nationalspieler war und dass er offensichtlich das Talent für die 2. Liga hat, wenn nicht eben mehr. Man muss sagen, dass Bricaló geliefert hat. In 11 Spielen hat er fünf direkte Torbeteiligung gesammelt. Man hat aber offensichtlich jedes Spiel von ihm gesehen. Er war in fast jedem der absolute Ausnahmespieler. Er hat mehr das geliefert, was man von Fabian Reese sich erwartet hatte. Das sogar auf verschiedenen Positionen. Er wurde dann irgendwann vom Viergespieler zum Zehner. Er hat das herausragend gut gespielt, sodass man dachte, plötzlich war dann kein Platz mehr für Cuisance, der da eigentlich der arrivierte Zehner war. Das war es, wenn es sich darauf bezieht, dass Brikalow gleich zweimal Fehler von Mitspielern ausbügeln musste, und dabei sehr unglücklich gehandelt hat und sich rote Karten abgeholt hat. Er hat zwei Rotsperren in dieser Rückrunde gesehen, deswegen nur elf Spiele gemacht. Wenn man sich die Zahlen mal anguckt, die drei Spiele, die er rotgesperrt gefällt hat, hat Hertha einen Punkt geholt. Die elf Spiele mit ihm hat Hertha 19 Punkte geholt, also fast einen Zweierschnitt. Wir brauchen überhaupt nicht darüber reden, dass Hertha diesen Aufstieg nicht verdient gehabt hätte. Aber es gab ja eine Zeit in der Rückrunde, in der Hertha wieder diese Serie aufgebaut hat und einfach nicht weit weg war. In diese Serie fällt dann diese Rotsperre von Precalo, der wirklich zu Topform langsam auflief. Am Ende wäre es dann egal gewesen, ob es ein verdienter Aufstieg ist oder nicht. Du hättest natürlich zugegriffen. Deswegen frage ich mich manchmal bis heute, was wäre gewesen, wenn Jose Precalo einfach alle Spiele hätte machen können, Hertha in diesem Flow geblieben wäre, die zwei, drei Siege mehr holt und plötzlich richtig oben dran gewesen wäre. Es wäre möglich gewesen. Und dann ist es wie gesagt, Schalke hatte diesen Aufstieg auch mal. Dieser Aufstieg unter Mike Miskins, der war auch nicht verdient, aber der ist aus dieser absurden Serie hinten raus entstanden. Und dann fragt am Ende keiner mehr, das hätte Hertha so ein Stück weit diese Saison sein können. Und dazu hätte Precalo sehr stark beigetragen. Und dementsprechend ist das mein, was wäre wenn.
Ja, finde ich tatsächlich sehr, sehr spannend. Bei mir ist es auch Hannover 96 letzter Spieltag, dieses 3-3 gegen Nürnberg, weil es einfach so das größte was wäre wenn. Für mich ist in einem Spiel zusammengefasst, Nürnberg geht in Führung, man schafft dann das 2-1, übrigens auch Torstand zu Soma. Für die Nürnberger geht dann in Führung durch ein Eigentor und dann kriegt man eben am 85. das 3-3. Ich habe mir aber tatsächlich noch eine andere was wäre wenn die Frage gestellt und zwar die Frage, was wäre gewesen, wenn der VfL Bochum im Sommer letzten Jahres sowohl auf eine neue sportliche Führung als auch auf einen neuen Trainer gesetzt hätte. Weil ich weiter in der Meinung bin, es war ein Fehler mit Dieter Hecking in dieser Saison zu starten. Es ist immer ein Risiko mit dem Abstiegstrainer rein zu starten und ich bleibe dabei, dass das für mich einfach keine gute Entscheidung war. Und ich glaube, die Winterpause war einfach zu kurz. Klar, Herr Schalke hat gezeigt, dass das geht, aber aus einer Rolle der Freude heraus. Und ich bin der Meinung, dass vielleicht Uwe Rößler mit einer ganzen Saison vielleicht nicht den Abstieg gepackt hätte, aber sie hätten vielleicht nichts mit dem Abstieg zu tun gehabt. Das ist mein potenzielles Was wäre Wenn, ein ganz, ganz großes Was wäre Wenn. Aber da habe ich so ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, weil ich einfach schon glaube, dass du per se mit diesem Kader mehr hättest machen können. Es steht jetzt, für mich steht für Bochum fast eine schwierigere Saison jetzt tatsächlich an, muss ich ehrlich gestehen, weil die ganzen Leihspieler, die du hast, da ist halt nicht die Wahrscheinlichkeit sonderlich groß, dass die, glaube ich, alle halten kannst. Gleichzeitig jemand wie Kaietan Lenz, der natürlich viele Millionen, mit 10 Millionen Hoffenheim geht, da Geld einbringt, aber man muss ja trotzdem sagen, so richtig überzeugende– es klingt vielleicht ein bisschen gemein– aber langfristige Transfers hat für mich Bochum zuletzt nicht gezeigt. Da ist halt die Frage, wie passiert das. Deshalb ist es– also Frau Bochum wird für mich ein ganz spannender Player, sagt man ja, so schön in der nächsten Saison, weil ich die tatsächlich im ersten, schon mal so als Vorausschau, ich würde im ersten Moment nicht als Ausstiegskandidat für die nächste Saison mitrechnen, weil mir dafür halt über die Weite– also das ist vielleicht noch so ein Gegenmoment– aber die Weiterentwicklung unter Uwe Rösler einfach gefehlt hat. Und da wird halt die Frage sein, liegt das nur am Kader? Und konnte man eben im Winter nicht so komplett neu sich daher finden? Und die Frage muss er dann eben im Sommer beantworten. Und da bin ich sehr, sehr gespannt tatsächlich, ob ihm das gelingt.
Ja, Bochum ist so der Club der vielen Wahrheiten, wie ich finde. Denn die eine Wahrheit war, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt klug war, mit Dieter Hecking in die Saison zu gehen. Die andere Wahrheit ist aber auch, dass er einen Trainer zu betreuen hatte, der von Dirk Dufner zusammengestellt wurde, der dann auch gefühlt drei Wochen nach dem Sommer-Transferfenster gehen musste. Man hat ja dann unter dem neuen Präsidenten– wie heißt der Kollege, der Ex-Torhüter, Andreas Lute– der hat ja dann tabula rasa gemacht. Die Entscheidungen davor waren ja, glaube ich, soweit, ich weiß gar nicht seine. Der hat dann schon den Kahlschlag vollzogen, den sehr notwendigen. Bringt natürlich auch so eine Frische rein, weil Lute ist noch nicht so lange raus aus dem Geschäft und ist vielleicht anders als so ein 60-jähriger, alt-erwilliger Präsident, der sagt, ja, ja, machen die Jungs schon. Sondern der wird da auch…
Du meinst Sportdirektor, ne? Du sagst immer Präsident.
Er ist Präsident. Andreas Lute ist Präsident des Vereins tatsächlich. Ich glaube, deine Verwechslung könnte auch daher kommen, weil er gefühlt bislang als CEO handelt, eher als CEO als als Präsident. Und dieses Führungsvakuum, das es bei Bochen, glaube ich, auch gab. Also wenn man sich mit Bochen-Journalistinnen und so weiter unterhält, haben die gesagt, dieser Verein ist in seinen Gremien eine Vollkatastrophe gewesen in den letzten Jahren. Das hat ihn ja auch in der Zeit, in der man dann abgestiegen ist und die neue Saison vorbereiten musste, extremst gelähmt. Und dann ist man irgendwie auf Dirk Dufner rausgekommen, der dann Dirk Dufner-Dinge getan hat. Und dann auch die nächsten Wahrheiten sind. Die eine Wahrheit ist, dass ich Uwe Rösler schon sehr positiv zuschreiben möchte, wie sehr er Bochum stabilisiert hat. Die andere Wahrheit ist für mich, dass wir, glaube ich, alles von Uwe Rösler taktisch gesehen haben. Und ich glaube nicht, dass man da große Neuheiten in der neuen Saison erwarten kann. Wenn der Kader insgesamt besser zusammengestellt ist, könnte insgesamt auch eine etwas bessere Platzierung bei rumkommen. Aber besonders diese Rück-Serie, wo man gefühlt kein Spiel gewinnt, sondern sehr viele Unentschieden sammelt, zeigt ein bisschen, dass auch ihm nicht mehr viel eingefallen ist. Ja, Teile davon sind im Kader begründet, nicht ohne Grund. Lässt man jetzt ja auch viele Spieler gehen, also Bero, Marzovic, Losli, Vogt, Rösch und so weiter, sind ja jetzt alle schon gegangen worden. Ich mag ein paar Transfers, die sie jetzt schon getätigt haben. Allen voran Berkan Tast, der die dritte Liga auseinandergenommen hat und glaube ich, dass dringend kreative Elemente und was man benötigt hat. Also da wird jetzt auch glaube ich gerade schon ganz gut gehandelt. Trotzdem bleibt dann wieder eine Wahrheit. Diese vielen Leichspieler, die du hattest, die sehr talentiert waren, Unijeka, Morgalla, ab und zu Alfa, Rubecht, die verlierst du jetzt. Heißt ja aber nicht, dass du nicht wieder talentierte Spieler leihen kannst, weil auch da, Borum, hat sich bewiesen, dass Unijeka und Kodi finden da Spielzeit, das finden Vereine in der ersten Liga erst mal gut. Also ja, am Ende glaube ich, um dein Was-wäre-wenn so für mich zu beantworten, wenn Uwe Rösler von Anfang an da gewesen wäre. Ja, ich glaube schon, dass dann Borum nicht so stark nach unten reingerutscht wäre, aber sie wären auch nicht besser als Platz 9 rausgekommen, glaube ich, trotzdem.
Okay. Ja, dafür ist ja die Kategorie auch ein bisschen da, um so ein bisschen zu diskutieren und am Ende natürlich trotzdem zu sagen, wir werden es eh nie wissen, wie es einfach gelaufen wäre. Aber ich würde sagen, wir kommen zu unserem vorletzten Award, auch sehr schön, der Expected Chaos Award. Ein Team, bei dem wirklich jedes Spiel komplett unberechenbar war, also XG egal, Ergebnis eigentlich egal, Hauptsache wild irgendwie und auch irgendwie so, wo du einfach wirklich auf dem Spielteam geguckt hast und sagst, da kann jetzt alles passieren. Und Anna, starte da doch gerne mal rein.
Super schwer, finde ich, weil es, finde ich, auch so ein bisschen an die Phasen anschließt, über die wir schon, oder Serien, über die wir schon gesprochen haben. Weil ich finde so richtig chaotisch, also ich fand, also sehr wundertütig fand ich, war immer Furt, die irgendwie diese Spiele hatten, bei denen sie, sie haben in 96 geschlagen, sie haben in Elbersberg geschlagen und man dachte so, okay, jetzt haben sie sich gefunden und dann brechen sie doch wieder komplett ein. Die Hertha, bei der man immer gedacht hat, okay, jetzt vielleicht, nein, doch nicht, okay. Aber nach langem Hin und Her und einem Platz 2, den ich glaube ich nach Hannover schicken wollen würde, ist es tatsächlich, weil ich den Verein gerne platzieren wollte, der KSC, der so eine mit so viel Erwartungen in die Saison gestartet und man dachte, das ist doch eigentlich, tickt das doch alle Boxen für eine richtig erfolgreiche Zweitliga-Saison. Marvin Vanicek, Christian Eichner, die hielten den Verein jetzt zurück in die Bundesliga. Und dann war der Start irgendwie, ja, die Ergebnisse okay, aber die Leistung eher aufregend. Dann so wilde Spiele wie dieses 3-3 gegen Dresden, wenn ihr euch daran erinnert, so meine Güte, ey, was ist da denn los? Und dann eben einfach dieses Hin und Her, der Co-Trainer wird entlassen, Spieler verlassen, die Weihnachtsfeier bleibt Christian Eichner, lässt er sich das bieten, ja tut er, aber er wird doch entlassen. Und dann geht damit, finde ich, ein Herr, dass du einfach diese umstrittene Qualität hast im Kader des KSC, die dann, wie es so schön heißt, Druckbefreiheit aufspielen konnte. Und dann schlägst du Bielefeld 4 zu 1, dann verlierst du aber sehr klar gegen Elbersberg und irgendwie klarer, als das Spiel es hergegeben hätte, gegen 96 zu Hause. Dann schlägst du aber trotzdem Darmstadt gegen Paderborn, reicht es dann wieder nur für einen Punkt. Also absolut unpredictable. Deswegen, weil ich irgendwie Christian Eichner gerne ein Award verleihen möchte, stellvertretend an ihn an dieser Stelle.
Sehr, sehr schön. Marc, wer ist es bei dir geworden?
Wir haben schon über diese verrückten Spiele gegeneinander gesprochen und deswegen bin ich am Ende bei Firt und Magdeburg rausgekommen, aber eher Firt. Irgendwann hattest du bei Magdeburg eher das Gefühl, dass du weißt, was du bekommst. Bei Firt nie. Nie, nie, nie. Ich erinnere mich auch an das Hinspiel gegen Hertha, wo Hertha die ersten Halbzeit zerlegt und dann kommt die aus der zweiten Halbzeit zurück, ja auch mit Mithilfe von Hertha. Hertha hat sich das bieten lassen und trotzdem sehen plötzlich Felix, Klaus und Co. wieder aus, als wären sie in ihrer Prime. Das hast du so oft gehabt innerhalb von Spielen, innerhalb von Wochen. Du wusstest wirklich nicht, was da passiert, weil sie auf der einen Seite ja auch diese wahnsinnige Abwehr hatten und auf der anderen Seite hatten sie aber Futtgäu, Hürgota, Klaus, die immer was liefern konnten offensiv. Diese Mischung war explosiv und hat dich nie wissen lassen, woran du bist. Also dementsprechend gehe ich mit Firt.
Sehr schön. Matthias, schließst du dich einem von uns an?
Ja, ich würde da auch zwei, drei Vereine nennen. Also Firt, klar, die waren anfänglich abgehängt, dann aufgeholt, dann wiederum nachgelassen, dann doch noch mal umgebogen. Also es war so eine Rollercoaster-Saison. Und bei mir, die Kids, einer tippt 1. Liga, die andere 2. Liga und in den ganzen Gruppen war bei der 2. Liga deutlich weniger Punktzahl. Was einfach belegt, das ist völlig random. Manchmal was da Teams zusammenfabrizieren. Und wir hatten es gerade schon über Bochum, die 8 Remis in der Rückrunde spielen. Und Remis tippt man eher selten. Man schlägt sich ja auf eine Seite. Also es war schon ein bisschen schwierig. Kaiserslautern da hingegen spielt 15 Spiele in Folge ohne Unentschieden. Also bis zum Saisonende, ab dem, dann muss es ja der 20. Spieltag gewesen sein, haben sie keine Remis mehr gesammelt und da waren dann auch Ergebnisse bei Gewinn gegen Hannover deutlich. Gegen Elbersberg verlieren sie. Das war zwar Verletzungsproteien und Platzverweis, aber ich glaube, sie hätten trotzdem gegen Elbersberg verloren. Dann verlieren sie zu Hause gegen Braunschweig. Spielnote 6 im Kicker habt ihr damals, glaube ich, herausgearbeitet. Und da war Thorsten schon auch so ein bisschen, hat einen Finger in die Wunde gelegt, dass er ausgerechnet in diesem Spiel Kaislautern den Junioren-Torwart einsetzt und die Mannschaft so gar nicht funktioniert. Und da hat er schon einen Punkt jetzt schlussendlich, weil Kaislautern gewinnt gegen Bielefeld und Düsseldorf, klar, aber gegen Braunschweig eben zu Hause verloren. Und ansonsten gehen sie gegen Nürnberg, Kiel, Darmstadt unter. Gewinnen dafür bei der Hertha. Also es war irgendwie manchmal auch so gar nicht absehbar, dass das Ergebnis so zustande kommt, wie es– also ich glaube, Hertha war jetzt nicht auf der Hand gelegen. Ich korrigiere mich, Marc, wenn das in der Luft lag, dass da Kaislautern auch nur ein Dreier mitnimmt. Also es zeigt so ein bisschen diese Flatterhaftigkeit der Lauter. Und dass die am Ende punktgleich mit Darmstadt über die Ziellinie gehen, hat mich total fertig gemacht, weil der Club war für mich schon zur Winterpause eigentlich kein Content oder kein Contenter mehr für irgendeinen oberen Drittelplatz. Also lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, ich gebe mir kaltes Lautern.
Finde ich eine sehr, sehr gute Begründung tatsächlich. Ich muss mit Marc mitgehen, für mich ist es auch Fürth einfach. Also erstens, weil Michi mir immer versprochen hat, bei den Bielefeld Fürth spielen, das gewinnt ihr locker. Wir wissen alle, wie die beiden Spieler– ich glaube, Fürth ist neben Schalke und Hannover oder so, die Mannschaft gegen die Bielefeld keinen einzigen Punkt geholt hat in den rückrunden. Also, juhu.
Hertha nur– nee, Hertha stimmt, Hertha hatte dieses Freak-Spiel gehabt am vorletzten Spieltag, wo Fürth das Tor einfach nicht trifft und Hertha dieses Spiel unter Zahl 2 zu 1 gewinnt und keiner weiß warum, kommt auch wieder in die Chaos-Quote rein. Dann spielen sie mal gut und dann gewinnen sie es nicht. Dazu kommt ja noch, der Chaos-Faktor wird ja noch dadurch erhöht, dass auch im Verein nur Chaos herrscht. Also diese ganzen Brandbriefe, die geschrieben wurden und Personalaustausch, hier Strategiewechsel, da, das kommt ja noch obendrauf.
Ja, also und von daher auch die Relegationsspieler an sich waren irgendwie so ganz, ganz komisch, fand ich, die anzugucken. Es hat mich auch ein bisschen verstört zurückgelassen, ehrlich gesagt. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was da nächste Saison so passieren wird. Von daher, ja, mach ich's kurz. Also Expected Chaos Award hat für mich für wirklich gepachtet. In dieser Saison fand aber eure Begründung, Matthias, Anna, auch sehr, sehr schlüssig irgendwie. Und dann kommen wir zu unserer letzten Kategorie, die so ein bisschen was Bitter-Süßes vielleicht mit dabei hat. Sie heißt der Never Fall in Love with a Lone Player Award. Kennt ihr vielleicht diese Memes, die da so ein bisschen rumgehen, immer wenn dann der Leihspieler da ist? Und das ist eigentlich schon klar.
Hat euer Verein diesen Einspieler? Ich glaube, bei Hertha war es Marco Grujic. Den haben alle unendlich geliebt. Bei Hertha hat es sogar so weit gereicht, dass man sogar eine zweite Leih gemacht hat. Aber da war die Gesamtsaison so schlimm, dass der mit untergegangen ist. Aber Marco Grujic ist oft so ein Sehnsuchtspieler bei Hertha gewesen dahingehend.
Ja, also bei Bielefeld war es einfach so, wie bei Marius World in der letzten Saison, wo es dann auch dieses ganze Hin und Her rund um die feste Verpflichtung und so. Das war einfach absurd, ehrlich gesagt. Aber Matthias, start doch gerne mal rein. Muss gar nicht von generell einfach, wo du sagen würdest.
Also da habe ich jetzt diese Dresden-Kohorte eingruppiert, weil es ja eben viele Leihspieler gegeben hat, wie wir schon erwähnt hatten. Also Keller, Stabilisator und anfinde ich auch Torschütze. Sterner und Wagner, die ja auch Stabilisatoren des Ganzen waren. Bobzien, Schäker, offensiv belebend und mehr Variabilität reinbringt. Also das hat schon in verschiedenen Stellen auf dem Feld gefruchtet, was da passiert ist. Will hatten wir auch schon erwähnt, der ja laut Michi, der aus unserer Expertengruppe auch neben Furtkoi bei Furt der wichtigste Spieler in der Rückrunde war. In Darmstadt konnte er es einfach durch seine Verletzung nicht zeigen bislang. Will ja wohl auch durchaus in Furt bleiben. Mal gucken, was draus wird. Ich würde ihn weiterhin gerne in Darmstadt sehen. Und ich gehe tatsächlich hier abschließend auch nochmal auf Darmstadt. Wir haben Akiyama anfangs geliehen aus Japan mit einer Kaufoption, die man dann auch sofort gezogen hat. Also unglaublich, wie schnell so ein Spieler, der noch nie außerhalb Japans aufgetreten ist, Fuß fassen kann, laufstark ist, umsichtig agiert, eine Passmaschine, sogar Torgefahr. Und inzwischen auch weite Einwürfe einstreut. Also das ist jemand, wo dann auch schon wohl im Training mal gesagt hat, wieso sagst du es erst jetzt, dass du weite Einwürfe kannst, nach einem halben Jahr. Und er kann sie tatsächlich. Ich bin ein Profi durch und durch, mit Fernie, dem Sportarbeiter bei Ligen, konnte ich mich unterhalten. Der meinte auch, dass sie natürlich bei den Neuzugängen doch immer gucken, welche Persönlichkeit bringt der Zugang mit. Und Akiyama hat im ersten Call mit ihm versucht, auf Deutsch und auf Englisch zu reden, was er sich wohl vorgestanzt irgendwie ausspucken hat lassen, hat nicht so ganz gefruchtet, aber was zeigt, wie sehr er sich vorbereitend auf was einlässt. Und er glaubt, dass man auch durch die Art und Weise, wie sich ein Spieler auf dem Feld präsentiert, auf seine Persönlichkeit schließen kann. Also er ist einfach druckresistent, er wird nicht nervös, er bringt in der Regel seine Pässe an. Das heißt, er ist ein unaufgeregter Zeitgenosse, und das ist er wohl auch tatsächlich. Also in der Hinsicht ging es auf. Also deshalb, wir haben ihn und mussten ihm nicht eine Träne nachweihen. Richter wäre vielleicht noch ein 2. Tor, ein Name, der hier zu droppen ist, weil er neun Assists hat und auch acht Pre-Assists, wie der Kiko herausgearbeitet hat. Er wird nicht bleiben. Ich denke, er würde weiterhin versuchen, irgendwo in der ersten Liga unterzukommen, was mich bei ihm überzeugt.
Auch mittlerweile der Simon Terodde Award.
Vielleicht auch das. Er hat durchaus auch defensiv zugelegt. Also normalerweise, wenn einer sich eher offensiv doofen fühlt, was zu kreieren, dann lässt das defensiv gerne schleifen. Aber da hat er durchaus auch gezeigt, dass er sich reinbeißen kann und das auch auf den Platz bringen kann. Am Ende der Saison ist er so ein bisschen mituntergegangen mit dem Rest des Teams. Trifft falsche Entscheidungen, schießt, wenn er passen sollte, passt, wenn er schießen sollte. Also, mit anderen Worten, Richter hat gezeigt, was so ein Zweite-Liga-Team geben kann, ob er das in einer Liga höher werden wird, bleibt abzuwatten. Also Richter Akiyama ist für mich so dieses Doppel. Akiyama ging gut zu Ende, Richter darf sich anderswo wahrscheinlich noch mal beweisen.
Sehr schön. Anna.
Ich schwanke zwischen zwei Torhütern. Da wir ja über die Zweite Liga sprechen, entscheide ich mich für den Torhüter des Vereins, der weiter Zweite Liga spielen wird und verleihe meinen… Ja, doch. Okay, ist ein knappes Ding, aber er geht an 0-0. Torhüter von Hannover 96, ausgeliehen von Anteuski Hoffenheim.
Da hat eine neue Saison gespielt.
Ja, ich füge hier 1-0-Witze ein, aber okay, das machen wir vielleicht an der Nachstelle. Sorry, du hast ihn gefangen. Genau, also Ron Robert Zieler wechselt letzten Sommer zum 1. FC Köln und der Trainer wechselt bei Hannover 96 und der wünscht sich auch darin, dieser Wechsel begründet, einen Torhüter, der Fußball spielt und gerne Fußball spielt, der, glaube ich, dem Vernehmen nach viele 96 Fans nervös gemacht hat, weil er so viel Fußball spielt und so weit weg teilweise vom Tor steht. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie sie diese Position füllen werden. Bei der Stimmung der Fans, das kann ich nicht beurteilen, weil sie sehr an dem hängen. Ich kann mir nur denken, dass für Christian Titz dieser Abgang wirklich schmerzhaft ist und mit Liebeskummer verknüpft. Deswegen mein Award an Nauel Neu.
Sehr schön. Marc, wer ist es bei dir?
Ja, Anna hat meinen gerettet quasi, denn ich nehme den anderen Torhüter, den sie wahrscheinlich genommen hätte, Dennis Simon. Ja, Wahnsinns-Saison gespielt. Dennis Simon wird ja schon sehr lange sehr viel Talent angedichtet. Was heißt angedichtet? Hinterhergesagt. Das musst du dann noch erstmal beweisen bei deiner ersten echten Profi-Station. Da war schon Druck drauf, glaube ich. Egal ob Standort Paderborn, der Druck war schon da, ob Dennis Simon das jetzt wirklich zeigen kann, weil ihm sicherlich auch schon der Platz bei Stuttgart lange vorreserviert wurde. Deswegen hat man ja Alexander Nügel seit gefühlt 7 Jahren ausgeliehen, wenn man auf diesen einen Moment wartet, wo man dann Simon hinterher schießen kann. Und am Ende stehen da ein Bundesliga-Aufstieg, 9 Weiße Westen, Platz 8 bei den verhinderten Gegentoren, Platz 6 bei den prozentual gehaltenen Bällen und Platz 8 bei den genauen Pässen pro 90 Minuten. Dennis Simon ist für mich ein kompletter Torhüter, der jetzt schon eine brutale Ausstrahlung hat, der Fußball spielen kann, der aber auch in den klassischen Torhüter-Attributen sehr gut ausgebildet ist und das jetzt in seiner ersten Profisaison auch wenn man diese Drittliga-Saison mit der VfB-Jugend sicherlich auch dazuzählen kann. Aber es ist trotzdem nochmal was anderes jetzt bei so einem Verein Verantwortung zu übernehmen. Der war auf Anhieb da. Ich erinnere mich auch an kaum bis keine krassen Torwart-Fehler bei ihm. Das kommt noch dazu. Also oft sind solche Jungkeeper ja auch gerne mal Hanebüchen unterwegs. Habe ich bei Dennis Simon gar nicht das Gefühl. Er hat so gut gespielt, dass Stuttgart jetzt entschieden hat, dass er kommende Saison auch dann in der ersten Liga das Tor hüten soll. Da gab es ja verschiedene Lager wohl im Verein und das Simon-Lager hat sich durchgesetzt. Das hat er sich verdient. Das hat er sich diese Saison erarbeitet. Und er war nicht der beste Torhüter der Saison in der 2. Liga. Soweit würde ich nicht gehen. Ich würde drei Torhüter auf jeden Fall vor ihm sehen, mit Ernst, Karius und Horn. Aber für diese erste Profi-Saison, für dieses Alter so abzuliefern, um am Ende sehr zu diesem Bundesliga-Ausstieg beizutragen, das ist aller Ehren wert. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wen Paderborn holen wird, um das zu ersetzen.
Ja, finde ich eine sehr, sehr gute Begründung. Bei mir ist das Musa Ndiaye geworden, also noch ein Wintertransfer von Schalke 04, kam von RSC Anderlecht. Vielleicht jetzt nicht so der herausragendste Spieler, hatte sicherlich Auf- und Abphasen auch, aber ich fand ihn trotzdem jemand, weil er einfach auch von der Position her vielleicht jetzt nicht so, die hat, die am meisten auffällt direkt im Spiel. Aber ich fand es trotzdem auch ein Spieler, der vielleicht ein bisschen untergegangen ist in den restlichen, aber wir hatten ja eben schon mal gesagt, generell Schalke ist Transferphase, sehr gut und auch da. Also wie gesagt, geht immer noch besser, aber der stand für mich irgendwie noch auf der Liste, dass das…
Total fair.
Matthias, gerne.
Absolut. Also ich kann mit allen euren Stimmen mitgehen und ich stelle gerade fest, wir sind jetzt weit fortgeschritten, wir haben quasi Elbersberg so gut wie unterholt gelassen.
Ja, ich habe es in meinen Awards auch gemerkt, das ist ganz schwierig gewesen.
Also man hätte irgendwann mal Petkov vielleicht droppen können, aber ich meine, dass Korn Thé doch auch ein Leihspieler ist, von Hoffenheim zu Elbersberg, ein saarländischer Kicker, also einer der wenigen, der wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Bezug zum Saarland tatsächlich hat in dem Kader und der ja schon auch ein Unterschiedspieler ist, also der einem schon auch mit seinen fußballerischen Qualitäten auffällt, wenn man ein Spiel von Elbersberg betrachtet. Und deshalb vielleicht dennoch auf so Honorable Mentions hier zukommen lassen, um auch das Gesamtkonstrukt Elbersberg durchaus noch mal zu erwähnen, weil sie haben tatsächlich eine fantastische Runde gespielt, also mit einer gewissen Leichtigkeit den Aufstieg tatsächlich gezogen zum Schluss.
Ich hatte da tatsächlich auch noch einen Elbersberg-Pick von den Honorable Mentions, nämlich Lukas Poreba. Der hat wirklich eine herausragende Saison bei Elbersberg, spielt so herausragend, dass Elbersberg, ja, Bundesliga-Aufstieg hin und her, 1,6 Millionen Euro jetzt in die Hand nimmt, um ihn fest zu verpflichten. Das sind für Elbersberg immer noch astronomische Summen. Aber ich finde es vollkommen gerechtfertigt. Der hat eine sehr, sehr gute Saison gespielt, sehr cleverer Laufstarker, zentraler Mittelfeldspieler. Das war richtig gut, muss man so klar sagen. Und den könnte man in dieser Kategorie sicherlich auch nennen.
Ja, finde ich sehr, sehr gut, da ich mich fast nicht rechtzeitig wieder entmutet. Auf Wunsch einer einzelnen Person in dieser Runde.
Oha.
Kommen wir jetzt noch kurz auf unsere Auf- und Aufsteigerung.
Oh nee, Anna!
Entschuldigung.
Oh, ich dachte, ich kann mich aus der Affäre ziehen. Das ist so bodenlos. Da kann ich wirklich meinen Beruf an den Nagel hängen, ne?
Ich bleibe nur bei dieser Runde. Das sprengt den Rahmen. Ich gehe jetzt alphabetisch. Anna, was möchtest du zu folgenden Wings-Kernitzer Aufsteiger? Hertha, Düsseldorf und Kiel?
Boah, okay, Düsseldorf altert ja noch schlimmer. Okay, ich bin fein raus.
Pass auf, es geht noch weiter, es geht noch weiter.
Absteiger? Schalke?
Naja. Also, wenn es durchgekommen wäre, dann hätte jetzt jeder gesagt, meine Güte.
Woher hast du was gemacht? Du musst ausgerutscht, du hast es falsch rumgetippt.
Ich muss zu meiner Ehrenrettung sagen, in dem Freundebeitrag zur 2. Liga habe ich gesagt, Elbersberg schafft den Aufstieg. Das ist dokumentiert, aber naja, gut. Risikostreuung.
Fair. Also ich sage meine auch kurz, ihr dürft jetzt auch nochmal lachen. Are you all ready?
Du warst auch so eine KSC-Jüngerin, ne?
Hannover, Karlsruhe, Düsseldorf, Elbersberg, Münster, Dresden. Jedenfalls mit Münster, finde ich nicht.
Ja, ja. Aber das habe ich eh, wir haben ja auch sehr, also was heißt gestritten? Für unsere Verhältnisse haben wir gestritten in der Saisonvorbereitung, in der Folge über den KSC, weil ich so war, where is the hype? Ich sehe ihn nicht. Die wären neunter. Am Ende habe ich, glaube ich, so gefühlt so gesagt. Ja.
Und ich habe dir folgenden Satz um die Ohren geworfen, ich sehe nicht, wie Hertha BSC aufsteigen will. Und daher jetzt für dich, Marc, Hertha, Kiel, Bochum.
Aber da ist Schwammintelligenz, da haben alle falsch kippt. Das ist in Ordnung.
Magdeburg, Elbersberg, Dresden.
Sag nochmal kurz oben.
Hertha, Kiel und Bochum.
Ja, das habe ich, das möchte ich nämlich auch, das wollte ich irgendwo noch anmerken in der Folge. Ich werde nie wieder den Fehler machen, nie wieder Absteiger wieder als Aufsteiger zu tippen. Das ist Kokolores. Das kann man lassen. So. Und was war unten?
Magdeburg, Elbersberg, Dresden.
Ich kann nicht fast mitleben. Magdeburg war ich deutlich negativer eingestellt als viele andere und viele haben mich fragend angeguckt, als ich gesagt habe, du, also Tietz ist weg, einige Spieler sind weg, das wird eine negative Eigendynamik annehmen, die ich schwierig finde. Dresden wäre lange Zeit gut gegangen und Elbersberg ja, gut, da brauchen wir gar nicht drüber reden, das ist natürlich eine Vollkatastrophe. Da haben viele, so wie ich, halt den Abgang von Horst Steffen und Aslani und Co. halt als Aus dieser ganzen Erfolgsgeschichte gewertet. Turns out, Ole Bok hatte noch ein Ass im Ärmel und ist jetzt bei Dortmund.
Ja, ist übrigens, also niemand hat alle Absteiger richtig getippt und niemand hatte Schalke.
Da muss ich ja sagen, es ist offiziell auf BlueSky festgehalten. Da habe ich zu seinem Antritt gesagt, nennt mich verrückt, aber ich glaube, wie auch im Blueslit will funktionieren. Das gebe ich mir noch, das hefte ich mir ins Revier.
Ja, ist okay. Aber also Münster war sehr oft dabei, tatsächlich für…
Ich habe Münster nicht auf die Abstiegsdezige gehört, das war so ein leichter Call. Ich habe an Alexander Ende geglaubt, naja.
Na ja, und Matthias, ich gebe dir deine auch noch. Hertha, Bochum, Kaiserslautern.
Oh Gott, das will ich nicht.
Lautern, auch geil.
Er war nicht der einzige. Fürth, Dresden, Braunschweig.
Hey, stark. Damit kann man richtig leben.
David, also ich glaube, du warst von uns allen am nächsten dran gefühlt.
Fürth, perfekt getippt und den Rest sehr nah. Das ist so in Ordnung.
Das heißt, ich darf jetzt in der nächsten Saison Wolfsburg auf den Abstieg tippen.
Ja, zumindest nicht auf den Aufstieg, ne?
Ja, nach meiner Regel, ja, aber ich glaube Wolfsburg, da können wir gut.
Doch, doch, du musst sie ja auf Wolfsburg tippen, wenn du nicht möchtest, dass sie aufsteigen.
Genau, genau. Irgendwo muss ich Wolfsburg erwähnen, aber ich glaube, um schon mal einen kleinen Blick vorauszuwerfen, das wird wirklich, puh.
Also, haut mir wirklich überall auf den Kopf, wenn Heidenheim, St. Pauli oder Wolfsburg, das läuft ja unter ferner liefen. Das ist ja schwierig, die mit den Investitionen dann zu tippen. Aber wenn St. Pauli und Heidenheim bei mir am Ende unter den ersten drei landen, dann haut mir auf den Kopf, weil das kann nicht sein.
Nee, nee, du bist schon für deine eigenen Tipps verantwortlich. Ihr habt keine Co-Host für ihre Co-Hosts. Und so funktioniert das nicht.
Ich bin, ja, ich...
Aber ich kann nochmal sagen, ich bin sehr froh, dass wir es nicht wie in der Bundesliga machen und die ganze Tabelle gucken, tippen. Also vielleicht, natürlich ist dann die Wahrscheinlichkeit höher, dass man für einige in die richtige Region tippt. Aber wir haben auch alle gelernt, es gibt kein Mittelfeld. Und dann zählt es auch nicht. Es ist wirklich viel schwieriger in der 2. Liga, wirklich die 3 Oberen und die 3 Unteren zu tippen. Weil das ist einfach unmöglich, ehrlich gesagt. Und alle, die gesagt haben, sie wissen es besser, ihr lügt. Es tut mir leid, aber ihr lügt einfach euch selber was vor. Und ja, also, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, was ich noch dazu sagen soll. Was ich aber jetzt gerne noch sagen möchte.
Was für ein Schlag in die Magengrube zum Ende der Sendung wirklich.
So, hier, Krawallbaus wird nochmal ausgepackt. Aber wir haben, also ich kann aus dem Nähkästchen plaudern. Ich hab so gesagt, ja, zwischen 2 und 3 Stunden.
Klassiker.
Wir sind bei dreieinhalb angekommen und deshalb möchte ich mich ganz, ganz herzlich bei Anna Lautenbach bedanken. Danke für deine Zeit. Danke, dass du diese Saison mit uns beendet hast.
Danke euch. Das war so schön. Ich hatte sehr viel Spaß. Vielen Dank.
Und dann natürlich auch vielen Dank an Matthias Kneifel. Danke für immer deine Inputs und sowieso vielen lieben Dank, dass du dir auch die Zeit genommen hast.
Ja, vielen, vielen Dank. Jetzt haben wir einfach 34 Spieltage in dreieinhalb Stunden gepresst. Glück ist ja auch kompakt.
Ist Rasenfunkmanier. Und dann möchte ich mich natürlich auch ganz, ganz herzlich bei meinem Co-Host und Podcast-Ehemann Marc Schurzki mit danken. Danke, dass du hier bist.
Machen wir es jetzt öffentlich, ja.
Machen wir es jetzt öffentlich, ja. Dann müssen wir auch nicht gegeneinander aussagen. So funktioniert das, glaube ich.
Du machst das nur dafür, für irgendwelche etwaigen Stadion-Krawallgeschichten. Ich hafte für dich, Eva, ist kein Problem.
Nein, aber so nehme ich. Lass mich erst meinen Dank zu Ende bringen, bevor du mich hier roastest. Vielen lieben Dank für die Saison mit dir. Es hat mir sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Das sei schon mal gesagt. Danke, Marc, dass du auch dir die Zeit trotz, das darf ich vielleicht sagen, Abschlussarbeit, Stress, die du hier genommen hast.
Danke, Marc. Sehr, sehr gerne für euch, für dich sehr, sehr gerne. Ich schicke euch ein digitaler Herzen zu. Es hat ganz großen Spaß gemacht, diese Sendung, aber auch die Saison. Ich finde, dass mit dieser All-Star-Gruppe ein ganz, ganz schönes Gewachsen ist, was auch genauso weitergeführt wird für die kommende Saison. Das können wir auch schon mal verraten. Also ihr habt uns nächste Saison auch alle an der Backe, wenn ihr 2. Liga hören wollt, müsst, dürft. Darauf freue ich mich. Und es wird genauso, wie ihr Lust weitergehen. Also wird eine gute Sache. Aber jetzt erst mal Sommerpause.
Ja, und dann bleibt es für mich auch noch mal zu sagen, vielen lieben Dank, dass ihr zugehört habt die ganze Saison über für euer Feedback. Freut uns sehr. Wie gesagt, ich kann auch schon mal verraten, unser Olszerteam wird um mindestens zwei Personen erweitert, um zwei Personen, die eigentlich auch nicht von mir eingeladen wurden, sondern in erster Linie von Max. Der hat ordentlich ausnahmsweise mal für den Rasenfunk die Werbetrommeln gedreht in dem Moment für diese Ligatur. Und ich glaube, diese WhatsApp-Rote wurde geschrieben, die, die Spaßigste, aber auch die Nerdigste. Auch die Nerdigste oder die mit dem meisten Spam. Also, je nachdem, wie ihr das interpretieren wollt, ich wünsche euch sonst auch eine sehr, sehr schöne Sommerpause. Wir hören uns bestimmt irgendwie mit einer Saisonvorschau wieder, diesmal vielleicht auch vor dem ersten Spiel. Bis dahin macht's gut, bleibt gesund, guckt sonst auf jeden Fall im Tribünengespräch und Nationalteams-Feed vorbei. Und dann. Das war der Rasenfunk. Wir freuen uns über ihre Unterstützung. Sie lernen es ab, ist die Geschichte und dann werden sie sehen, Herr Reporter, wie sich das damals im Parlament entwickelt hat.